foreign
it is no surprise that business
analytics and business intelligence are
two of the fastest growing markets in
the world organizations today are
generating data at a rapid rate there is
a need to use this business data and
make smarter decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable sites this is where business
analytics and intelligence can help play
a critical role business analytics is
the process of collecting analyzing and
drawing valuable conclusions from vast
volumes of data available it helps to
improve business performance through
fact-based decision making on the other
hand business intelligence of bi is a
technology that enables data preparation
data mining data management and data
visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively consider this
example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
Texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
Spike up in Texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in Texas who like to make
chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complementary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using cutting-edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth with this basic
knowledge of business analytics and
business intelligence let's look at the
topics we'll be covering in this video
we will start with learning the need for
business analytics and the
responsibilities of a business analyst
then we will look at the top business
analytics skills and learn about
business analytics and intelligence with
Microsoft Excel after that we will see
the basics of business intelligence and
get an idea about agile and scrum
methodologies
next we will learn to create reports and
dashboards in Microsoft Excel and
understand in detail how to visualize
data with top business intelligence
tools such as power bi and Tableau let's
get started we will understand the
importance of business analysts with a
short and interesting story
so meet Rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his Cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
Rob's Cafe was usually popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly Corona
virus
due to covid-19 like other eateries Rob
was forced to shut down his Cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his Cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for Coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts he remembered that business
analysts are professionals who enable a
change in an organization he felt like a
business analyst could help him sort out
his current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst he hired Ted the
business analyst to help him with his
ongoing business problems Rob interested
Ted with reopening the business
the first step Ted took was to have a
discussion with Rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take on
discussion with Rob Ted learned that the
business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that Rob also wanted Ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic Ted studied the case and he
came up with a few suggestions that he
thought was fit for Rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for Rob's
Cafe
this way Ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario next
Ted suggested that Rob has work from
home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
Professionals in the middle of a busy
day
Ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from Rob's Cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any sort of
price Cuts in the current situation
finally Ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by Ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by Rob for the app that began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the IT team that
became the intermediary between the I.T
team and Rob he provided suggestions to
the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well Ted
held regular meetings to gaze the
progress and also kept Rob in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project attending regular catch-ups
helped Rob Kane an insight into the
progress and gave his feedback from time
to time Ted made sure that the entire
case was well documented by doing so he
could always refer to the documents in
the future with similar cases as well
Ted made presentations that showed Rob
the business growth after implementing
the changes and Ted always supported his
presentations with data Rob was very
impressed with Ted's business approach
such an approach not only helped Rob
reopen his business amidst the covid-19
but also helped him get 80 percent of
his customer base back Ted successfully
brought about a positive change in Rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how Ted the business analyst
helped Rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in Rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst well yes
depending on the business domain and the
situation the roles and responsibilities
may vary let's start off and have a look
at a day in the life of a business
analyst through a small story so meet
Angela who is working as a business
analyst in an application development
firm her firm builds applications for
clients depending on their requirements
our next character is Rob he is a
budding entrepreneur with a vision of
setting up his own e-commerce app he
plans on selling several electronic
gadgets like phones laptops cameras Etc
on his app
so what is Rob's First Step well he
approaches Angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app Angela and Rob start talking
business and Angela promises to help Rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running Rob is happy about
it and increased to cooperate with
Angela regarding all the business
requirements from his end Angela as we
know is the business analyst she starts
planning drops project and without any
delay she embarks on this Project's
Journey she has a set of planned steps
that will help her fulfill Rob's
requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about Angela's approach that helps her
deliver Rob's project smoothly and
without any hassles these steps that we
are going to look at are the typical
roles and responsibilities of a business
analyst
here we will understand these rules
better with respect to Angela's and
Rob's story first and foremost Angela
understands Rob's business objectives
problems and requirements without
understanding this do you think Angela
will be able to proceed no hence a
business analyst like Angela understands
the problems related to Rob's business
and comes up with the right solution to
achieve the goals of the business she
brainstorms around what is best you did
for an e-commerce app focusing on
electronic Gadgets in The Next Step
Angela gathers all the necessary
requirements here she understands Rob's
requirement and makes sure that they are
on the same page regarding the project
and its goals both of them together
arrive at a stipulated deadline for the
project completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
ways to login cost of the products and
style to name a few once Angela has an
in-depth understanding of Rob's project
and gathers all the necessary
requirements she starts allocating
Resources by keeping in mind the budget
of the project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
Pas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
Angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
Rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
Angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to Rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the apps layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in The Next Step Angela
collects feedback of the Prototype
version of the app from the users
she notes down if the Prototype is fine
or if it requires more work p is
validate if the project is running fine
with the help of use acceptance testing
they verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use expectations
Bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback Angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba in order to gauge
the performance of the app and get
valuable insights from it Angela builds
reports using various data visualization
tools like Tableau power bi and kick
view reports can be General reports such
as detailed reports or it can be
dashboard reports such as visualized
reports with multi-dimensional analysis
based on display of business indicators
it is not uncommon for issues to crop up
amidst this entire process hence Angela
conducts regular meetings with the
development team and drop to solve
problems quickly having these meetings
will help Rob understand the status of
the project and it will also help the
teams proceed in the right path
throughout this project phase Angela
makes sure to maintain transparency on
completion of the project Angela
documents and presents the project
findings to Rob generally business
analysts present the project outcomes to
the stakeholders and clients along with
maintenance reports Angela noted on all
the project learnings and details in a
concise manner this will help her take
better decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project now that
she has completed all her duties and
responsibilities with respect to Rob's
project she is ready to deliver the
final e-commerce application to Rob for
use Rob is rest assured that the
application developed by Angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted Angela's streamlined approach
made it easier for the project to be
delivered within the stipulated time
period Rob is happy and I'm sure he will
come back to Angela's form for projects
in the future so those responsibilities
that we saw Angela carry out are ideally
the roles and responsibilities for any
business analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project
you're working on if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for Bridging the Gap
between it and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions growing a career in a
field with high demand such as business
analysis could be a challenge and
competition for business analyst
positions can be intense so you should
have a clear understanding of the roles
and responsibilities of a business
analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-function requirements in a business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally Bas write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem so let's have a look at the top
skills to become a successful business
analyst the first skill we have is
understanding the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale of production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improve revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increase in marketing budget according
to the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill of business
analyst would have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says
five percent of the people think 10
percent of the people think they think
and the other 85 percent would rather
die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the clients
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals where
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point they use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority as the
project progresses negotiation skills
help to determine the functional design
which fulfill the requirements technical
decisions also require negotiation
skills business analysts also perform
cost benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analysts is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have an act to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deeply tidier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualized Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth skill in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
the sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems
while business analysts are generally
not responsible for making decisions
regarding project Solutions decision
making skills are still important for
understanding Gathering and presenting
relevant information to assist decision
makers with selecting the optimal
solution
with that we have covered our top skills
for a business analyst if you have any
questions related to the skills that we
covered then please put it in the chat
section our team will help you solve
your queries
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career in business
analytics and help you become a business
analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analysts so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst Masters
program
now this program is endorsed education
provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this master's program
so if there is introduction to business
analysis certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum
there's business analytics with Excel
we'll also get training in SQL less
Tableau training
and you'll also get to work on business
analyst Capstone projects
if I scroll down
now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so this
Microsoft Excel Zera Tableau power bi
postgres SQL
then this plan box Target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if I scroll further
with the entire course content we have
these are the different courses that you
will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to this
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have postgraduate program in business
analysis
now this is in partnership with Purdue
University and endorsed education
provider is iipa
if I scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course you'll get
Purdue postgraduate program
certification Alumni Association
membership
master classes from Purdue faculties
enrollment in simply learns job assist
there's 170 Plus hours of Blended
learning 11 plus Hands-On projects
custom projects in three domains
if I scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
produce certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get the certificate
received by International Institute of
business analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to Simply learn job assist
program so you will get IM jobs Pro
membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring you'll
also have interview preparation and
career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so you'll learn about an introduction to
business analysis certified business
analysis professional this is Island
scrum
business analytics with Excel Tableau
training business and list Capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
Purdue University business analysis
Master Class
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there's Agilent scrum Foundation
if I scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so this
business analysis this allicitation and
collaboration requirement analysis
planning and monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing that's data visualization
statistical analysis using Excel SQL
database
this requirement lifecycle management
and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have Microsoft
Excel Zera fogbers
plan box that's rally power bi process
SQL that's version one target process
and others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industry related
projects that you will get to work on
once you enroll to this course so the
first project is canteen ordering system
for Unilever
we also have Library management system
for Stanford University that is WhatsApp
p and you can see the description of
these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
Hospital management system for Mayo
Clinic
there are course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
Purdue University
if you scroll further this is the
learner's profile and how the industry
trend has been for business analyst
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst now here is a quick roadmap that
depicts what a fresher needs to possess
to become a business analyst first they
need to have a graduation degree in a
related field then knowledge of SQL and
relational database is very important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst up next we have the
roadmap that depicts what an experienced
professional needs to possess to become
a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write SQL
queries
an experienced professionals should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by International
Institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial let's now
learn the business analysis knowledge
areas
first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring now this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize and coordinate business
analysis efforts it involves planning
business analysis approach stakeholder
engagement business analysis governance
as well as Information Management then
we have initiation and collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements life cycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
task that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their life cycle it covers the creation
changes prioritization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the Enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
Define the future State assess risk and
Define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures SS solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects the first methodology we are
going to talk about is the agile
methodology
Ajay is an incremental and iterative
approach to project management and
software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles teams can
manage a project by breaking it up into
several stages and involving constant
collaboration with stakeholders along
with continuous Improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes planning
the project in terms of business goals
budget time duration for completing the
project and resource needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application Etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders Etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints after each
Sprint we get a shippable product and
that product is reviewed by the client
or the stakeholder
the suggestions are Incorporated in the
next print
here you can see we have Sprint 1 Sprint
2 and Sprint 3 and all of them have the
six steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process now let's discuss
the scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process Frameworks for Agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members scrum significantly
increases productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals ok so the
concepts and practices in scrum can be
divided into three categories
first we have three rules
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria they are responsible for
prioritizing the product backlog and
deciding the release date and the
content a product owner is the one who
is responsible for the return on
investment or Roi of the product a scrum
Master is a servant who encourages and
demands the organization from the
development team they enable close
cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
Disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
increments the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each Sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or Project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
Sprint backlog includes only what needs
to be completed during the current
Sprint it often has greater detail and
more complete user stories than the rest
of the product backlog once created no
one can add to the Sprint backlog except
the development team the product
increment is the version of the product
that will be delivered at the end of
each Sprint while the Sprint backlog
outlines what must be completed within a
Sprint the product increment details the
outcome of all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer the final category we have
is Sprint ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total in
Sprint planning the team meets and
decides what they need to complete in
the coming Sprint
review is a type of meeting in which the
team demonstrates what they shipped in
the Sprint
in the Sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better daily scrum is a stand-up meeting
or a very short like 15 to 20 minutes
meeting for the team to make sure that
they are all on the same page
now let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst according
to pay scale the average annual salary
of a business analyst in the United
States is 68 973 dollars while in India
a business analyst can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the companies hiring for business
analysts we have the Indian e-commerce
payment system and financial technology
company paytm American immensely
cognizant and British Dutch
multinational Oil and Gas Company sell
we also have Cisco the search engine
giant Google and Dell finally in our
list of companies we have
Ernst and Young Global limited American
multinational computer technology
corporation Oracle and British
multinational Investment Bank and
financial services company Barclays with
that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts we have the widely
used spreadsheet application Microsoft
Excel web-based kanban style list making
application Trello relational database
Management systems such as MySQL
Microsoft SQL server and postgres SQL
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product Zera and
Tableau Software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training
oftentimes business analysts work on
structured data using Excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and po
charts to summarize and analyze data
find Trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the United States and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
Etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns you can see this is a sales
data set and the First Column is of
order date then we have the shipment
date we have the shipment mode next we
have the customer name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name there's only United States then we
have the different cities from the US we
have the state names
and if I go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the subcategories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value now you can
assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the years
in different regions of the United
States
so for that I'll click on any cell
inside this data set
go to the insert Tab and here I have the
option to create a pivot table
I'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data and here I'll choose new
worksheet that is the place where I want
to place this pivot table and let's
click on OK
so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet 2. and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table Fields so since I want to
know the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so I'll click on
remove field
I don't want this field so I have my
ears first and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for
all the years in different regions so
I'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this row labels and column labels
now with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will help you analyze your data
better
so what you can do is
go to the insert Tab and here under
recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here
and click on OK
there you go how easily Excel has
created a pivot chart for US based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region so the
sales had declined from 2014
to 2015 and then it gradually started
increasing from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was study from 2014
till 2015 then it increased in 2016 and
after 2016 it became constant
similarly you can analyze the South
Region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well let's go to our sheet1 where we
have our data set
let me click on any cell I'll go to
insert and I'll choose pivot table
here
Let It Be new worksheet I'll click on OK
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto a values field and now I'll choose
category
under rows so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what I can do is
I'll choose segment under columns you
can see I have my pivot table ready so
here you have the furniture office
supplies and Technology as the
categories of products and on the top
you can see consumer corporate home
office has the different segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so I'll
go to recommended charts and
let's say this time I want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on OK
if I close this
and I bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and Below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments now if
you want you can edit this chart as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons okay
all right
now
let's suppose we want to know which
segment meet the highest and the lowest
profits so for that you can create a
pivot table as well
so I'll click on any cell go to the
insert tab
and choose pivot table I click on OK
all right now see
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so I'll first choose profit onto values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows so we have our pivot table
ready
now here if you want to know which
segment meet the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do sort smallest to largest
which is in ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart let's do that
I'll go to insert and here under
recommended charts I'll select pi and
let's click on OK
there you go we have a nice pie chart
ready
now the gray color Pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table
while the blue segment which is actually
home office made the lowest amount of
profit now let's remove this field from
here I'll right click and select hide
all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is you can edit
the chart title here by default it has
shown total we can rename it to let's
say profit by
segment and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
I'll say seals by
segment
and category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
I'll click on the chart title and here
I'll write sales by
year and region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know
the total units that were sold for each
subcategory of products and the shipment
mode
so here we have the shipment mode and
you want to know the total units that
were sold which is basically this column
the quantity column for each
subcategories of product you can see we
have different subcategories like
bookcases chairs labels The Stables
Furnishings art phones binders Etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll go to the insert tab click on pivot
table
and click on OK
all right now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
I'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
sub category under rows
so I have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart I'll go to the
insert tab click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
Legends which show the
shipment mode Let's click on OK
I'll close this
now
first let's remove these fields I'll
right click and I'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see I'll select
yeah this one
you can see it has given dots for each
end points which means this is my first
subcategory as you can see the second
subcategory the third subcategory which
is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read and
understand the chart well
okay now let's add a chart title
I'll write
quantity
sold
by
sub category
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10. okay
foreign
different kinds of maps in Excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that meet the
highest and the lowest sales in the
United States so you can create a field
map for that so first of all let's go to
our data sheet
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
click on OK
all right so since we want the
State and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows and then
I'll choose the State field under rows
now let's
drag seals under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if I sort this
data you can easily know
that California state meet the highest
amount of sales now if I scroll down
below you can see
North Dakota made the lowest amount of
seals
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
Tab and under Grant totals you can
select the first option you can see the
grand total has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so I'll click on
United States
I'll right click and
I'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
I'll click on
show item labels in Tableau format and
I'll also click on
repeat item labels you can see
it will populate United States for all
the rows if I click on OK you can see
the United States have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here I'll close this go to
the design tab under subtotals
I'll choose do not show subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and I'll actually paste it somewhere
here
now with this data
I can go to the insert tab
and choose Maps let's select field map
there you go
you see we have a nice field map of the
United States
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue let's say California made
the highest amount of sales you can also
validate it from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart Title Here
I'll
give a chart title as
seals by
States
and let's remove this Legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if I choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the California state
is shaded in dark which means it meet
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well I'll just remove these two
all right
now similarly you can also create a
field map to see the profits by each
state so you can analyze which states
meet the highest amount of profit and
the state that made the lowest amount of
profit so let's do that
I'll go to my data sheet
I'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on OK
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows
and then I'll choose State under rows
next
let's drag
The Profit column under values
so I have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design Tab and remove
the subtotals
I'll select do not show subtotals if I
scroll down
okay I have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under Grant totals
we'll remove it
okay now let's just populate the United
States which is the country name for all
the rows
I'll right click on United States go to
field settings
click on layout and print I'll choose
select item labels in Tableau form and
select repeat item labels
let's click on OK
so I have my country name populated
throughout
let's
select the pivot table
I'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
I'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits
for each of the states
let's first delete this
and editor chart title
which is
profit by
States
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
I'll make it as white
and let's say
will
choose the color
as
set this one okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
Legend here
and just delete it all right so we have
our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our different pivot tables
and pivot charts let's build the final
dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing I need to do is I'll go
to the view Tab and I'll remove the grid
lines all right now let's go to the
insert Tab and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right let's pull this a little down
and this tool till right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's give the text as
sales
dashboard
and will
give a white color to the text and I'll
select my font
you can select any font you want
so I'll go with
let's say
Britannic bold
okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to 30
and we'll Center align it all right
now the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet so I'll first
copy my
pivot chart
and I'll paste it in sheet date let's
paste it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well I'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11 okay and let's drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the pie chart
and let me paste it here
let's reduce the size of this pie chart
foreign
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different subcategories of product I'll
copy it
and let me paste it
somewhere here
I'll close this
we need to reduce the size so that we
can fit in our other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this and
let's paste it
here
I'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our
dashboard ready you can see the
different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts so I'll
click on this first chart which is our
line chart I'll go to the insert tab
here you can see under filters we have
slicers and timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
I'll choose my order date column
let me click on OK
all right let's drag this a bit here on
to the right
and I'll show you how you can use this
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click and I'll go to report
connections here I'll select
all my Pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the tables or the charts we have on
the dashboard I click on OK
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
I'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
and go to insert click on slicer
now let's add a region slicer I'll click
on OK
and let's stick it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slices are nothing but filters
which have advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment
so I'll go to slicer
I'll choose segment here and click on OK
so you can see I have my segment slicer
here let me just reduce the size
and
let's drag it here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline suppose I want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015 so the
way to do is you can select one of the
years so I'll click on 2014
and now I'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if I go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15. similarly
if you Mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say I want to
have 2016 year included as well I can
just drag it to the right you can see
the charts will change
I'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to see the sales
and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and let's say you want to know the sales
and profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
let me just cancel this
now you might be wondering when we
selected the different regions only the
pie chart changed but the rest of the
charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click and go to
report connections
here I'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
and click on OK all right now let me
just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
seals and the profits and the quantities
sold for let's say south region
if I select this you can see it shows
only for the south region let's see you
also want to know for the central region
now we have selected both Central and
South you can see the variations in the
graph
and we cancel this
similarly we have or another slicer
which is the segment
I'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on OK
I'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say I want
to know the seals the unit sold and the
profit for home office segment so I'll
only select home office
you can see the variations here
now the slicers actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to know for the
corporate segment you can select
corporate or if you want to select for
multiple segments you can do that as
well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email IDs in the comment section our
team will send you the files over email
we'll compare the two most popular job
roles in the field of Information
Technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst business analyst is
a professional who Bridges the gap
between the it and the business teams in
an organization they use data analytics
and modern Technologies to assess
processes and deliver data-driven
solutions they understand and solve a
business problem and validate business
requirements a business analyst
generates reports for executives and
stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered they also
assist in the integration and testing of
new Solutions now let's talk about the
job description of a data analyst
with a rapid increase in data generation
today the term data analyst has found
its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce Transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and Reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our Focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues they thoroughly understand
the requirements from the clients and
assign the right resources
BS communicate and work closely with the
development team to design the solution
for a problem they ensure that the
development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations
bases the functional and non-functional
requirements a business analyst
documents the project findings and
results they present the project
conclusions to the stakeholders and
clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions now
let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst first
and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process data analysts collect
data from various heterogeneous sources
they assist the available resources
comprehend the business problem and
gather the right data for analysis they
work closely with different team members
like programmers business analysts and
data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis they use a variety of
analytical statistical and business
intelligence tools to spot Trends and
patterns in complex data sets discover
hidden insights and prepare summary
reports for the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba a business analyst
should have a graduation degree in any
relevant field such as business
accounting Information Systems human
resources or engineering you can apply
for entry-level business analyst
positions or with professional
experience Excel is a powerful analytics
and reporting tool for working with data
Bas use Excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
BS use SQL to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases critical thinking skills are
important to understand customers
business needs it allows them to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a lower priority Bas
should find different ways to address
each challenge data visualization is a
key skill for Bas to build interactive
dashboards and reports to convey the
outcomes of a project
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view is required to make different types
of reports depending on the business
requirements business analysts should
have a good Hands-On programming
experience to solve complex tasks and
perform faster analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as R and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicate it in front
of the stakeholders and clients
let's Now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess you must
have a bachelor's degree in any relevant
field or be a graduate in statistics
economics or science you're eligible to
become a data analyst being a fresher or
as an experienced professional you
should have domain knowledge in the
field you are working in once again
knowledge of excel is another basic
requirement for a data analyst data
analysts often work with structured data
so they should be proficient in writing
SQL queries using data manipulation and
data definition commands they should
know how to create stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python R
SAS and JavaScript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions data analysts create data
visualizations using libraries such as
matplotlib c-bond ggplot and plotly this
helps them to perform exploratory data
analysis
knowledge of Tableau and power bi is
required to create different business
reports with the help of graphs and
charts data analysts should have
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
to build sophisticated models and make
future predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
Vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
finally data analysts should also
possess good communication and
presentation skills now let's discuss a
salary structure for both of these job
roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the United States earns an
average salary of sixty nine thousand
dollars while in India you can earn
nearly 6 lakh rupees per annum now
talking about the salary of a data
analyst according to pay scale in the US
a data analyst earns an average salary
of sixty thousand seven hundred and ten
dollars per annum and in India you can
earn around 4 lakhs 24 000 rupees per
annum let's now move on and look at the
different companies hiring for business
analyst roles here we have Oracle the
search engine giant Google the American
MNC cognizant and e-commerce company
Amazon in addition to that we have
Ernestine young technology giant IBM
Dell and Cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have Twitter Google the
social media leader Facebook and Amazon
we also have the American Oil Company
shell the electric vehicle company Tesla
apple and the American Credit Reporting
Agency Equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have then gauge your
interest to see what suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run now let me tell you how simply learn
can help you grow your career as a
business analyst and a data analyst
simply learn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with Purdue University the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding data visualization agile
scrum methodology scrum artifacts
statistical analysis using Excel and SQL
database
some of the tools covered in this course
are Microsoft Excel Tableau power bi
jira postgres SQL plan box and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive Purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from Purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get IM jobs
Pro membership for six months and obtain
35 iiba PDS cdus and 25 PMI pdus
you will get 170 Plus hours of Blended
learning along with Capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
Peugeot University and IBM the skills
that will be covered as a part of the
course are statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis in Python and our
data visualization using Tableau and
power bi linear and logistic regression
modules clustering using k-means
supervised learning and others the tools
that you will learn are numpy pandas
sci-fi scikit-learn Excel and others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get Purdue postgraduate
program certification industry
recognized IBM certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and master
classes from Purdue faculty you have 180
Plus hours of Blended learning 14 plus
Hands-On projects on integrated labs and
Capstone projects in three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
this
man we'll go over some beginner
intermediate and advanced level
questions to expect in interviews when
you're looking at business Analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question dealing with business because
in business they want to make money and
we really want to understand where the
split is on a lot of these things so
always ask yourself where is the bottom
dollar on this and what does this mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening so
risk is a potential problem that can be
predicted risk me or may not happen in
the future a proactive response plan is
formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there's no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company specific and so when you start
looking for work you start going in for
interviews you should start really
asking yourself what are these companies
looking for that I'm interested in
clearly if you work with IBM you want to
have your tools that are Central to IBM
and the IBM setup same thing with Google
with you know just across the whole
field some of the more basic ones
obviously an Excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list but your python your
SQL you should really know your SQL is
going to come up and no matter what
format you're in your Tableau your Azure
your balsamic all these are different
platforms there's a lot more out there
but you should be aware on which
platforms your proficiencies are on and
those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and a lot of
companies will pay for you to be
certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand any one of these in a little
bit more detail than just knowing the
list what is feasibility study a
feasibility study is a method of gauging
the success rate of proposed Business
Solution it enables business analysts to
discover new business opportunities
and really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at it for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up in
most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done what is business model
analysis business model analysis is a
technique that helps you analyze if a
business is financially economically and
socially viable or not
I know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in Colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that so it's a very high-end job
Niche we really need to know your stuff
and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs we look at requirements a
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set business
objectives business requirements are
data used for business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result business needs include
identifying and comprehending the
businesses goals and articulating its
strategic direction and you can think of
needs are what do we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip PIN codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using Excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes PIN codes of various cities from
the US and India here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing City from
the field list click on the insert data
option and select state from the field
list
really you do need to know your way
around Excel no matter what other
packages you're working with Excel is
such a base package in business analysis
so much people are given that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
Baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in India
you can use the sum IF function to find
the total revenue generated from India
you see here equals some f and then of
course B2 to B100 India L2 to l1001 and
that will give you the sum you can also
use a filter option to filter the data
only for India and use subtotal by
pressing alt plus equals nice short
hotkey to remember there
create a highlight table to visualize a
revenue generated from offline and
online sales for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies used to have blue
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use you
drag the region onto columns drag the
cells Channel and item type Fields onto
rows select the total revenue column and
drag it on to color and label cards
select Square as the mark type
drag the total revenue field onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows Place item type column onto
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select Asia
so one of the things about Tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop and so you should know your way
around about doing some very simple drag
and drops for doing your query and
summation and below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
uh differentiate between software
development lifecycle and Project Life
Cycle
which are looking a little bit more
hierarchical towards the top of the list
software development life cycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases here
phases include requirement Gathering
coding operations maintenance and
documentation
where the Project Life Cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business Project Life Cycle consists
of multiple software in one customer
scenario phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
Analysis how do you perform risk
management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull tables across we're going to
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced assessed
and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high risk avoidance whereas risk
avoidance is carried out to avoid the
risk from occurring meanwhile the
business impact here is zero and the
cost is fully eliminated and you could
think about a brick and mortar store and
they have shoplifting you want to
mitigate as you want to avoid as much
shoplifting as you can but you can only
Frisk people at the door and have
security so much before you start losing
customers and so when you mitigate it
you're going to have to pay for your
lost merchandise where you avoid it you
have your security cameras and people
watching to stop people from stealing
things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent badly spent on equipment
certifications there's all kinds of
areas where you want to mitigate and
avoid risk
what are project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our uh
when you sign a contract and you have
our online contracts cloud computing all
of that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model two of our biggest or
most basic models used today the agile
model which is slowly taken over
especially on software the agile model
is adaptable to requirement changes and
has an incremental approach
in the agile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
and requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
Final Phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall setup you're
not looking for fast changes you're
looking for a very solid it's going to
work no matter what kind of view this is
something that we can build it doesn't
have to make major changes but it better
work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like Moscow and SWAT
Moscow analysis it is a prioritization
technique that highlights a
requirement's significance question like
is it a must-have or a should have could
the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the SWOT analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
SWOT analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats and
you cannot kind of think of it as like
the SWAT team coming in
to you know you're worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in Moscow really what is
um what can we get out of this you know
is this do we have to have it to succeed
is it going to be useful in the future
so you're looking more for a general
value attached to it list various
components of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives Mission strategies action
plan what is benchmarking
benchmarking is a process of evaluating
an organization's measures like the
quality of policies programs Etc against
the standard criteria
it's so important to have that Baseline
of what are you measuring against the
Baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before I even jump into this I have a
friend who is working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
end location when he arrived they had
been in a fist fight while on their
private plane the stakeholders had so
much difficulty with some particular
aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
that work with anybody but you want to
listen patiently to the stakeholders
point of view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise comprehend their
worries and be transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and I'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
um one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore somebody who's being
difficult but the rest of it is stay
focused stay focused on what you're
trying to accomplish be goal driven this
is a great time to be goal driven not
driven by emotion or the problems that
arise or how the person communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum you'll get scrum certified
important thing to look into if you
haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming XP
feature driven development FDD Crystal
kanban Dynamic systems development
method dsdm if getting your learning
started it's half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
other ones are out there is important to
at least know what we're talking about
when someone comes up and talks about
agile
describe the Gap analysis Gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the Gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result Gap
analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities and
you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into Ms
Excel
and remember Excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of uh analysis that we do most
of our data starts in an Excel
spreadsheet it or comma separated
variable file that you then end up with
an Excel spreadsheet given below is the
employee text file it has information
about name agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into Excel go to the data tab click on
get data drop down under from file
select text CSV select where the text
file is located in your system and click
on import click on low data imported
into Excel
he had been given sales data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of Statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is go ahead and select a cell in
the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table drag region and item type onto
rows drag total profit onto values sort
the sum of the total profit column using
the sales table find the percentage
contribution of Cosmetics to the total
revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values right click
on the revenue value under show value as
select percentage of grand total right
click on a profit value under show value
as choose percentage of grand total
you can see here when we do that we end
up with Cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.94 contribution to the total
profit how do you create a dual axis
chart in Tableau drag the order data
onto columns and convert it into
continuous year drag total revenue onto
rows and total profit to the right
corner of the view until you see the
light green rectangle
synchronize the right Axis by right
clicking on the profit axes under the
marks card change sum total revenue to
bar and some total profit to line and
adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data Create A View to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has the least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an Excel file
data in Tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column under rows place the total
profit column under calor and choose the
desired color palette sort the unit sold
axes in descending order
you can see here it produces a very
quick
um bug figure shows a fruit sold and the
least and had the least amount of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
Middle East and North Africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select Middle East and North
Africa
Bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time Iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017. drag
the units sold filled on the columns
drag the region and item type Fields
onto rows under the color card place a
total revenue column drag item type onto
filters and choose clothes meat and baby
food drag the ordered date column onto
filters and select 2016 and 2017. meet
had the highest units sold it made the
maximum profit now with any of these
Tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
um so that's an important thing to note
we kind of zoomed in on Tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with Tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package uh that's a good thing so at
least you know what we're talking about
and you've had that Hands-On
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization we had Moscow
Technique we mentioned that earlier the
requirements are grouped based on must
mandatory should high priority could not
necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
um
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no uh notional 100 to
distribute among the requirements
so the 100 method is pretty similar to
what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements in this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
pick their top 10 requirements
very popular there's a lot of helpbooks
out there about getting things done they
say write everything that you want to
accomplish put them on three by five
cards and narrow it down to five do
those five because once you've conquered
those five then you can move on to the
next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
print burned down so the Sprint burn
down is the chart we use when you're
tracking usually it's in scrums where
that usually comes from the scrum uh
setup but it's a chart of the work to be
completed and what's still going on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness time coverage defect
resolution time explain B pmn
bpmn business process model and notation
Gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique Which models the
end-to-end business process step the
four essential elements of bpmn are flow
objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim Lanes pool or Lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about Gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews
don't how many times I've been on the
phone calling competition
potential clients to ask questions
so one of the elicitation techniques is
to ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions it can a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis Focus Group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important I just kind of
highlight a few of them that I tend to
get stuck in observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis and you're bringing
people into a workshop and do
observations in the workshop and working
specifically with these people they turn
into potential business growth I tell
you what if you're a shareholder and
someone's doing a business analysis and
they turn around and generate a thirty
thousand dollar sale for your company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
Survey questionnaire survey is my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
listed documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document project Vision
document use cases system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability Matrix
functional requirement document use case
specifications document gap analyst
document describe how you would approach
a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams tracking
the project documenting the progress
and really when you start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here is so important with the
shareholders if you I mean it's great if
you can identify your project goal
that's probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal you
might as well walk away
[Music]
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams that is such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors this
does not lead to achieving the required
goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following point should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis display
your analysis skills think critically
and I'm going to throw in here the term
from Big Data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes and you need to think critically
you need to really make it what is it
that the shareholders want that's going
to make them understand why this is
important to the business and what does
the business get out of it what is
kanban Ken band helps agile teams in
visually managing work through processes
it works as a scheduling system in agile
just in time production the kanban
methodology is all about real-time
communication of capacity and full
transparency of work the kanban board
describes a current development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you've got to be very careful
about
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micromanage
being set up where you want to you want
to watch out for that but you also need
to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow it has the to do in progress
and done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
any differences between BRD and SRS
BRD business requirements documents is a
high level functional specification of
software BRD is a formal document to
describe the requirement provided by the
client business analysts create this
post their interaction with the clients
SRS system requirement specification is
a high-level functional and Technical
specification of software SRS describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas SRS is
created by the systems architects
what is Pareto analysis the Pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal
is also known as the 80 20 rule as per
this rule 82 of the Project's benefit
arises from 20 percent of the work vice
versa eighty percent of the case problem
can be due to 20 percent of the causes
differentiate between the V model and
the fish model
we talk about the V model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a V shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step V model
consumes less time and cost
the fish model is similar to The V model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is compared to the very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage from
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each Region's country that made the
highest revenue create a pivot table by
dragging the region and Country onto
rows place the total revenue column
under values right click on the country
value select the filter options and
choose top 10. choose top 1 as shown
above and click on OK
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the sales data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand you need to use an advanced
filter option in Microsoft Excel to
solve this problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select Advanced filter option choose
copy to another location give your
criteria range and the copy to location
we'll click on OK
Here's the final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest amount profit create a pivot
table by dragging the region and the
country into rows Place The Profit
column under values right click on any
country value select the filter option
and choose top ten choose bottom one and
click on OK
and then let's create a filled map to
analyze the total revenue and profit
generated from beverages in North
America using Tableau drag country under
detail card place a total revenue column
under the text drag total profit under
calor and the filters card drag the
region column and select North America
in the filters card drag the item type
column and select beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that Greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America
who knew
using tablu how will you display the top
five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type field under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters in the total profit
onto color
the above graph depicts the Cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest and really when we're
talking about tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r or you're targeting companies
working in Python you should be able to
quickly do these kind of displays in any
of those packages that you're focused on
Tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also very robust and
easy to use and uses less programming on
the back end so just a quick side note
on there really just leads up if you if
this does not look right to you you're
not able to get through some of these
things make sure you are if that's what
you're targeting in a company for an
interview choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
before I start off with our top 5 bi
tools I'd like to talk a bit about
business intelligence
as you might be aware there are zillions
of companies across the world these
companies generate massive amounts of
data on a daily basis when I say data
here it simply refers to business
information both internal and external
customer feedback product Innovations
and profit loss reports to name a few
companies use all of this information to
make crucial decisions that can either
hamper or boost their business
you might have heard of the term data as
the new oil well it definitely is if
organizations analyze all the available
data very well then this soil is
definitely valuable
and to help organizations with this we
have business intelligence which is more
often termed as bi
we can Define bi as a technology driven
process which works on analyzing
unstructured data to derive meaningful
information from it basically it is a
set of architecture and processes that
convert raw data into useful information
that helps in achieving profit for a
business
so to achieve business intelligence
goals we use a set of tools these tools
are termed as bi tools they help
organizations acquire and analyze data
efficiently
some of the bi tools are seasonal but
some are evergreen we have a plethora of
these tools in the market which makes it
hard for businesses to select one single
tool here we have a recommendation list
of the top 5 bi tools of 2020 after
extensive research and an in-depth
evaluation we have come up with this
list
in addition to the top five we also have
a few other tools which look promising
for the year 2020.
so let us have a look at the top 5 bi
tools
at number five we have thoughtspot
thoughtspot is a us-based company that
provides its customers with business
intelligence software Cloud spot makes
analysis of data easy and it does so in
the matter of a few seconds
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
let's now have a look at the features of
hotspot
is a search driven solution that is the
users can find insights through an
interface known to everyone that is
search
this makes the tool more accessible the
sport IQ engine also uses artificial
intelligence in the form of algorithms
to identify and display insights like
Trends and causal relationships
instead of going through a number of
different procedures to create a chart
thoughtspots instant chart creation
ability lets users automatically view
data graphically with just a few Mouse
clicks you can generate a visually
appealing story
when a business grows so will its data
requirements hence it is crucial that
you have a tool that can be scaled up
easily thoughtspot has this feature and
it also performs automatic load
balancing across all its servers
hotspot is also now available for small
and medium instance Types on AWS
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
spot has a user-friendly interface even
users with absolutely no prior knowledge
or training can operate hotspot easily
so those were the features of
thoughtspot let us now have a look at
the companies using thoughtspot
as you can see on your screens we have
the American multinational retail
Corporation Walmart then we have the
Royal Bank of Canada RBC followed by
7-Eleven and Exxon Mobil let us now move
on to our next tool
so at number four we have SAS bi
the SAS business intelligence tool looks
into the analysis Data Mining and
Reporting with the help of powerful
visualizations and interactive
dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of SAS bi
first and foremost it is easy to use
irrespective of your skill level you
will be able to easily explore create
and share data there is no need for the
user to rely on the IT team
better analysis of data is achieved by
using automatic code generation and SAS
SQL
the next feature of SAS is that it
allows you to integrate with open source
software such as r r helps you to
connect to many databases and data types
SAS provides the best practices and
defines the guiding principles for a
secure product development lifecycle SAS
Bia ensures that the products meet the
business and security needs of the
customers
let us now have a look at the companies
using SAS bi we have companies like
Accenture genpact iqvr and IBM to name a
few
that was all about SAS bi let us now
move on to our next tool so at number
three we have click
the company was founded in Sweden back
in the 90s the company's first product
was click view it is a powerful tool
which visualizes and analyzes the
relationships between data qlik sense is
a self-service data Discovery and
analysis tool it provides a modern user
interface for data management click is
named a leader in the 2020 Gartner magic
quadrant for analytics and Pi platforms
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of click
click view can do everything that an
olab based solution will do and much
faster you can take advantage of click's
powerful Ai and machine learning to
accelerate discoveries boost data
literacy and derive insights
qlik sense Works without data filters
but while working with click view data
filters are required click allows
flexible deployment capabilities for
seamless end-user experiences and
management capabilities across
multi-cloud environments data
storytelling is an important part of bi
qlik sense provides this feature but it
is not available with click view with
the click data integration platform you
can do powerful data integration and
perform modern Analytics
as you can see on your screens these are
the companies using click we have
Mercedes-Benz cognizant Accenture and
cab Gemini so for all those who joined
it now let me just quickly repeat our
list at number five we have thoughtspot
then at number four we have SAS bi and
at number three we have click
so far do you all agree with this list
let us know in the comment section below
let us now move on to our next tool at
number two we have Tableau Tableau is
one of the most popular and fastest
growing business intelligence tools used
in companies these days Tableau is a
data visualization tool that was founded
in 2003 it manages the vast volumes of
data and its flow and turns data into
actionable information it allows you to
analyze and visualize data faster and
efficiently
the Tableau product Suite consists of
tablet desktop Tableau public Tableau
online Tableau server and Tableau reader
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of Tableau one
of the most important features of
Tableau is that it can connect to 40
different data sources and handle large
amounts of data easily some of the data
sources are local text files Microsoft
Excel PDFs Json or databases and servers
like MySQL server Microsoft SQL Server
Etc Tableau is an easy to use drag and
drop tool which allows its users to
create interactive visuals quickly you
can build different charts and graphs
dashboards and story lines with just a
few clicks in Tableau you can gain
insights that you never thought was
possible you can play with interactive
visualizations and explore various data
that is available and you don't need to
have any specific knowledge of the
insight you're looking for knowledge of
coding is not required to work on
Tableau as Tableau provides inbuilt
table calculations
so some of the companies that use
Tableau are the American e-commerce
giant Amazon the Italian luxury sports
car manufacturer Ferrari then we have
Walmart followed by cab Gemini and
Linkedin
before we move on to the number one bi
tool in our list let's have a quick look
at a few bi tools which didn't make it
to our list but which seemed to be very
promising in the year 2020.
so here we have Zoho analytics which is
a cloud-based self-service bi and data
analytics software that is used for data
visualization and for creating
dashboards up next we have Oracle bi it
is an oracle Corporation set of bi tools
used for reporting and analyzing data
built around tables graphs dashboards
Etc then we have pentaho which is a bi
software used for creating relational
and analytical reporting with the help
of pentaho we can transform complex data
into meaningful reports and draw
valuable insights out of them
and finally on the top of the hierarchy
we have power bi power bi is a business
intelligence tool that provides users
with features to analyze visualize
Aggregate and share insights from data
to make business decisions
it is provided by Microsoft power bi has
several components such as power query
power pivot Power view power map power
bi desktop and power q a each of these
components has its own features and
functionalities
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of power bi
firstly it provides easy drag and drop
functionality which makes data visually
appealing it allows you to copy all
formatting across similar visualizations
power bi transforms your Enterprise data
into Rich visuals and accurate reports
for enhanced decision making it can also
be used with Azure using power bi with
Azure allows you to analyze and share
large volumes of data it integrates
seamlessly with Advanced cloud services
like Azure and Cortana to provide
results for the verbal data queries
with power bi you can fetch data from
Factory sensors and social media sources
to get access to real-time Analytics
it provides a unified user experience
with customized dashboard and reports
that meet your exact needs power bi
ensures secure report publishing as it
sets up automatic data refresh and
rapidly publishes reports allowing all
the users to Avail the latest
information
the companies that use power bi on a
daily basis are Nestle capgemini
Accenture and entity data hi everyone
welcome to this tutorial on Microsoft
Excel so we will learn about functions
and formulas we will learn about
conditional formatting data validation
pivot chart and pivot table
now let's look at the scenario here so
one day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague response
well we can make use of Microsoft Excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and the suggestion is welcomed which
would make the job easier for them and
they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used so Excel or you might
have heard a spreadsheet can be
basically used for lot of different
tasks than just storing the information
in so-called tabular format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take a tour drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example I could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say I would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total there is also a
shortcut for this which you can always
do is we can first delete this and you
can just place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime expand or basically
collapse so I will basically select this
which says this function needs two
numbers which is number one and number
two and then you can hit on enter and
that gives you the total so similarly we
can be getting in the data here by
selecting all the fields so here it also
says that you can use a shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50 by selecting the yellow
cell here and then giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to D15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say I would be interested in
numbers only above 50 and we can select
this
close your codes and then just close
your paranthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum F Formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically select all the numbers which
are lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here that can be always a
shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at some easy options of
filling your cells or automatically
populating the values in your cells
within your Excel sheet now here we have
an option which says 100 now we can
click on this and that basically says it
is making a sum of column C4 to D4 so if
I click on this one I can check that
this is row number four which shows up
here and I also know this is column C I
also have D so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of C4 to D4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows so this is one
shortcut which we can do to get get the
total Excel will automatically give the
totals which we call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me this C11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from C11 so
column C and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what I can also do is
I can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right so the easiest option would be to
select this cell now what I can also do
is I can just select all of these fields
by just highlighting and selecting all
the fields once it is selected press on
Ctrl R and that gives you the total now
if we would be doing this stop down then
I could select all these rows for this
particular column and then I could do a
control D so that's your filling down
and this one was failing right so this
is an easier option of doing a fill when
you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields I could delete them and I have
here which says 130 I could just place
my cursor here and I could drag it all
the way up and that should also do the
same magic which we were seeing from top
down so this is a simple way wherein you
can fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs in
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say Nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in Andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name what
we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
data preview now I can basically select
this one I can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in in the columns appropriately
so this is how you can split your data
based on a delimiter and then organize
your data in a better way now there are
some Advanced options which we can learn
later but this basically tells about
using a formula so this is something if
say if we have some name in one cell and
if you would want to split it into first
name your helper column your middle name
last name so that can also be done using
formulas and this basically tells how
would you extract characters from your
left cell and how would you place them
in your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that you
can always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me this c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data and now
I can just do a control shift and enter
and now if you see all the values have
been populated now you can just place
your cursor in one of the cells but if
you see the address bar the formula
Remains the Same this is because this is
an array formula so we can read more
about an array formula here it's
basically something which performs
calculations and on more than one cell
in an array and in the example here the
array is the original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing the horizontal orientation to
the vertical orientation so this is a
very simple way in which you can
basically use the excels capability to
transpose your data and convert your
rows into columns and columns into rows
apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
so if we're going to sort and filter and
say this is the data I have say for
example I would want to sort the values
in the department column alphabetically
so what I can do is I can select
Department column and I'm already in the
Home tab I can straight away go here
which says sort and filter here I can
then say sort A to Z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column and once once I do
this you would see the data has been
sorted but it's not just this data we
can just do a control Z and check what
are the values we have so here we have
meet which is beef and ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values then you
have Bakery which should ideally be the
first row if we sort it in an
alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we we have
all the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20
000 and then what I can do is I can go
into sort filter and then I can say sort
largest to smallest so if you see Bakery
breads is the row which has the smallest
data or maybe you have Delhi sandwiches
so that one looks also smaller so let's
do a larger to smallest and if I do this
you would see the values have been
shifted now so it is no more based on
the department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the December
column and you see Bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is
its cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data data and it has
taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so I could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates I would be interested in looking
at I also have sort by color here I can
do a sort oldest newest or newest to
oldest so I could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if I would
want to basically select the color
columns or color cells I could select
this I can basically do a right click
here and when I go into sort I could
choose put selected color or cell color
on the top and that basically will make
sure that my data is sorted and it has
also sorted that in a descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data what we can also do is
we can add filters so sometimes we can
go for formulas which we would want to
use what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if I would
select a particular row I could select a
particular row and then I could decide
if I would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down and then you have something
like number filters so we can always go
here we can basically choose one of
these so we can basically choose above
average so I could select this and then
basically it shows me the values we
could also delete the filter by clicking
on this one and we could say well I'm
not interested in this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say
I'm interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost it is just
hidden or basically based on the filter
not shown so that's good enough for us
and in this way you can sort and filter
the data so for more details obviously
in all the sheets you have the links
which point to more information on the
web and you can always refer to these so
this is simple way in which you can sort
and filter any amount of data which has
been stored within your Excel within a
particular sheet now that we have
learned about add fill split transpose
sorting and filtering it will also be
good to learn how to work with tables or
basically converting your data into a
tabular format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here size 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this option
here in the top bottom right corner you
can just drag it towards the right and
that basically has automatically created
columns for my next months wherein I can
feed in the data so this is a simpler
way wherein you can keep adding more
rows and columns to your data if that
has been converted in a tabular format
now let me just do a control Z that
basically deletes the columns again Ctrl
Z deletes the last row which we added
and I can stop here or I can even remove
my values by doing multiple control Z
and removing my rows so this is how I
converted my data into a table and then
I can easily work on this what I can
also do is I can do some calculations so
what we can do we have a table here we
have a total field and what we can do is
we can just select one cell here now as
we have learned earlier we can do a alt
and then equals and that basically says
what is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of the last three
months and if that's what you would want
to do just hit on enter and it has
automatically calculated the totals for
all your rows for these three columns so
the sum formula is getting filled up now
I can select any particular cell and I
can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce say for
example meet and then say Bakery now
these are the values so we can click on
OK
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an
Excel sheet now I can click on data and
here I have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources so or you can click on
connections if you have already created
some so we can click on from other
sources so this is one option where you
can connect to your different data
sources and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is I
can click on connections now it says
there is none I can click on ADD it says
well show the connections where
connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will set comma as my
delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none now this is my data so my data
preview is already showing me the data
is what is the data in the CSV file you
can click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on draw and that basically gives
me the raw path where this particular
file is now you can select this copy
this particular path and here you can
come back to your Excel sheet we would
be interested in getting the data from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters or
let's go web and here I can given the
web path from where I would be
interested in getting the file let's
give the GitHub path which is publicly
available and then click on import now
once you click on import it tells me
that two Fields data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes it shows me data
preview click on next so you have the
general format it shows the destination
that's the column click on finish and
now your data has been split and you
have the data which you have imported
from web so this is the data which is
coming in from web this is the data
which came in from my local machine and
similarly we can even create connection
with an existing database so I can
basically click on connections if I
would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier I can click on
browse for more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new SQL Server Connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for and we can
basically connect to a database for
example if I have some database and say
for example access database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would mean a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area in descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying count D
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my G3 so here I basically have
my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically
have area field selected and I would
want to sort this particular data so I
have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon if this is
what you would want to use or we can
basically go for just cell values and
here we can say if I would be interested
in first getting my values for
South County so for example I can say
custom list and then I can basically
given the new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task where we what we have done where we
have sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and copy 2 I am
saying M8
to V8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay and now I have my data
which has been filtered and I have my
area which is South County that is
without Pool Central with pool again
South County without pool and then if
you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or in the same
sheet in different set of columns and
rows you can have your result let's look
at one more example of filtering where
you are trying to filter the data are
based on a and condition
being met in two different columns and
then you would want to filter out the
data for only specific columns so the
situation is the agents with a house in
North County that should be County area
having two and a single type family so
we are talking about two bedrooms and we
would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that if
we would want to only populate these
columns which is Agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as I
explained earlier that you can get your
result in the same sheet in a different
location so here I have created these
headers which says agent area bedrooms
and type now this is basically a copy of
all the columns what we have here agent
data listed area list price bedrooms
bath square feet feet and so on so you
can basically create a copy of the
headers here and this is where we will
give our Advanced criteria to filter the
data so the conditions which need to be
met is we need to look at North County
so for example here in area I can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values North County now the criteria is
having two bedrooms only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
P 7 now this is the area where I would
this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been asked that you would want
the agents with a house in North County
area having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do Advanced filtering get your data and
get it stored in the sheet anywhere at a
different location well I could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some Advanced filtering we can
also use Excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
000 to 600 000 or say for example we
would want to filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
I have I would want to filter out the
data between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can basically
update this say for example I am saying
I am interested in 300
to
400. 1000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways so there are two easier
ways to do it one is I would want to
look at the list price so I can select
this I can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so I
could basically select this I could say
I am looking for Value which is greater
than or equal to three hundred thousand
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if I just do this I have applied
my filter and I have my data which is
filtered based on my criteria right so
that's one easier way of doing it or let
me do a control Z
now let the filter be there which you
can anyways use but what we can also do
is as we have seen earlier methods so
get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which I have one two
three four and then you have 7 and 10
columns and if you see here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where I can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
or condition would lie in a different
line now here I can give this value so I
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so I am saying it should
be greater than or equal to 300
000 and then I can say less than or
equal to 400
000 now that's my criteria and then I
need my result here which is in M 7 so
what I can do is once I have given my
criteria which I will be using to filter
I can get into Data I can get into
advanced and then I can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
A1 to J 126 criteria area range is based
on M1 to
W2 and then I would want my result from
this particular column so let's say okay
and now you have your data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
Excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
data given to you and the question is
that you would want to find all the
houses in North County again that's a
spelling mistake but then they are North
County area with a list price greater
than 300 000 and having three or four
bedrooms so the bedroom has conditional
so it has R 3 and 4 and then basically
you have list price which is greater
than three hundred thousand now I could
have obviously selected The Columns and
then basically gone for a filter so I
can just do a filtering here and then
I'm looking for list price being greater
than 300 000 so which we can always give
a number filter and I can say greater
till then and then I can say greater
than or equal so I can say greater than
and then I can give 3030 300 000 and
that's basically the filter which we
would want and here I would want to
select the bedrooms which should be just
either three or four so if for example
here I go in here and I unselect this
and then I say three and four right so I
am getting my data which is greater than
300 000 and it should have the bettering
values which will be either 3 or 4
selected now that's one way of doing it
let's do a control Z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria
so for example I have my list price now
this is what I would want as a condition
so let's say greater than three hundred
thousand
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then I can say greater than 300 000
and then I can say 4 so this one
basically gives me a situation where
your list price has to be greater than
300 000 and bedroom should be either
three or four so we have given our
filtering criteria now to get the result
what we can do is we can go into Data we
can go into advanced and we can say copy
to another location so our list range is
selected which is columns a to J row
number 1 to 126 your criteria range is
given in M1 to V3 where we have
specified and we are saying the result
would be in M 7 to V7 so if I do this
now I have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier and here the bedroom
values are three or four and basically
the list price is greater than three
hundred thousand so this is a simpler
way in which you can create your filters
and all this Advanced filtering what we
are seeing it it will be saved with your
sheet you can always go back and change
this value or you could do filtering
where one person has to look into the
filter to see what values have been
selected
now that we have looked into some
operations which we can perform in Excel
using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also quickly
look at functions and formulas which can
be used for doing some easy calculations
or computations now Excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used and we can
always check for a particular function
so for example if I had if I wanted to
look at a particular function I could
just type in here something for example
is and then it shows me all the possible
functions and you can always have a look
at the detail of the function for
example you have is even which will
return true if the number is even if we
would say is logical so I could search
for is logical and that tells me whether
a value is logical value true or false
and returns your value true and false
now we can obviously
say subtotal so you can search for any
of these useful functions and that tells
me what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal list or a database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum average you may be
interested in working on truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root basically
getting a count or getting a max value
you can look for any particular
functions within your Excel sheet now
you also have other functions such as
now or time for example let's look at
Now function so I can search for
now
and here it is so this is Returns the
current date and time formatted as it
date and time so this is the function
which we would want to use and if I just
give the function it tells me what is
the current time let's first look at the
description of time here so say for
example I would want time it says
converts hours minutes and seconds given
as numbers to an Excel serial number
formatted with a time format so for
example if I would say two hours and
then 30 minutes and 30 seconds and if I
do this it has basically converted this
into your time format so you can always
use different inbuilt functions for your
work now we will also look at some
Advanced functions like sumf or some ifs
you have countif and countifs and you
can be working on various
functionalities of excel to easily help
you in doing some calculations
computations working with your data
working with your different cell values
so let's look at some example of using
functions like sum or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now I have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know that in region we have east
and
I have multiple regions I could
basically be saying unselect all and
select only East
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if I place
my cursor here and then if I did a
autosum so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on your rows which is
E2 to e44
and here we can just do this so that
gives me the total but this is this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sumif to do that so
here I am seeing this is the subtotal
where I am looking at the values and
basically what I have done is I have
filtered out the region
and then basically I am getting a count
but this does not give me clearly how a
sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed what we can also do is
let's do a control Z and let's get it
back so now we have our data and we
would want to get the total units that
were sold in the east region so what I
can do is I can start typing in my
formula and for that I'll use an inbuilt
function so for example I would be
interested in going for sumif now it
says sum if adds the cells specified by
a given condition or criteria when you
talk about some ifs this is when you
could give set of conditions or multiple
criteria so let's look at some if let's
do this now obviously this gives me an
error because the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here and let's start with sum if
now when I say sum if it shows me there
is a function with sum if which we would
want to use and here once I open up the
bracket it tells me okay what is the
range of data which you are interested
in so I am interested in all the units
that were sold in the east region so we
are interested in the region
which is here so I can basically be
selecting this and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say B2 and then we can go all the way to
the end so we can basically select this
way
that's the data we have select this and
hit enter so now here it has selected B2
to B4 but we need to basically now give
the criteria so the criteria is either a
value or you can point it to a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement we are looking
for the units which are sold in east
region so I can select the value East
here and then my sumif needs the range
on which you want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so I can basically type in
instead of selecting so I can say e and
I'm interested in e 2 2 e 44 so that
basically selects the area or all the
values and now let's do this so that
basically gives me the sum is 691 right
now this is the criteria where I have
pointed it to a cell and whatever value
that cell has well I could have done
something like this so I could have
selected East giving the value and then
doing it it still does the same thing
and in this way you have more clarity
that you are using sumif you are
filtering the data so you have given the
rows you are given the criteria and then
you have given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values now similarly if the question was
what was the total revenue generated
from binder
now we would want to find out what is
the total revenue generated from binders
that means my filtering criteria will be
binder
and then I want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here and we have we
don't have any region to be filtered we
are just looking for binder so let's
again start doing the same thing so we
can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range so we are
interested in revenue generated now
that's the summation we want and we
would want to
get the range of data so here we can
basically select
uh d
d
so that's the data selected now I would
want to give the filtering criteria so
let's say binder and then we need to
give the range on which the sum needs to
be calculated so that's my Revenue
column so that's G so I can say G to 2G
44 and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum so it tells me
what is the total revenue generated from
binder
now I could be doing this for other
things also so say for example if you
would want to filter out something else
you could basically just drag and drop
here and then I could come here and
change this to say instead of binder I
would be interested in say
pencil
if that's the criteria in you are
interested in remember to change this so
that you take all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data I am getting so I know
that this is the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if what if we would want to use some IFS
so some ifs let's have a look at how we
get to some ifs so sumif says where you
would want to work on
doing some calculation but then you
would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this so
here what I can do is let's work on this
problem statement which says what is the
total revenue generated from central
region
where the item is a pencil so that's
something which I would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated from central region so we need
the total revenue generated we know
there is a revenue column we are
interested in getting the total revenue
generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region and we say in that we
would be interested only in the item if
it is pencil how do I do it so I can use
sumifs where you can pass in multiple
criteria so let's start with some IFS
and when I start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria and you can give in any number
of criterias so for example we are
interested in total revenue generated
now that's my G column so let's follow
in the same order so let's say G
two
so that's my first value and then I know
there are 44 rows here so I can say G 44
and you can obviously check if that has
selected all the rows now that's my
total revenue generated so I would want
the total revenue generated so I'm
saying setting this some range
then I need to give the criteria range
so it says from central region so
central region comes into column two
that's B so let's say b 2 to B44 so
that's my criteria range then you have
to give your criteria but we need to
filter out the region being Central so
let's select this now either I could
point to a value in the cell or I can
just give the exact value here
we can also give a
wild card or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine we are
now also interested in finding the total
revenue generated when the region is
Central and the item is pencil how do we
do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
D2 so let's select d 2 2 D 44 so that
basically selects all the rows in the D
column and we need to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say pencil and then let's close your
bracket and that basically gives you the
result
so we need to just follow the order of
our question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says from the central region so
we need to select the region column and
give the filtering criteria Central or
point to a cell which contains that
value and then it says we would be
interested only in item being pencil so
then you select the column which has all
the items and provide you a filtering
criteria that is pencil so that's your
easy calculation of using some if which
we compare with sum if here so sum if
here was just having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative johns or
Jones where the cost of each item was
greater than 4. so how many units were
sold by sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
some ifs I would be interested in E
column
and let's give the range so it says sum
range so those are the number of units
on which we would want to find the sum
then it says you need to give the
criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
Jones so sales representative is in
sales rep column C so let's say C2 to
c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say Jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested about whom we are interested
in and then we the question says where
the cost of each item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say F2 to f44
and then you need to give your cost so
it says where each item is greater than
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me 3 0 1. now
similarly let's answer our third
question which is how many units did
Jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of units units
that were sold
and that units or that should not
include the pencil item how do we start
doing this so let's start with some IFS
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units so
let's basically go in and select our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e so I can say E2 to
e44 that's where I would want to perform
the sum now I am saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
zones so let's see let's select the
columns
C and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is zones and
then we are interested in the items but
excluding pencil so items is in column D
so let's say d to d44 and then we have
to give
our criteria so we can say well that
should exclude pencil
so I can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says that these are the number of
units which the sales representative
whose name is Jones had sold and that
does not include pencil as an item let's
also look at an example of using countif
or countifs now both of these can be
very useful when you would want to
calculate certain values so for example
if I would want to work on count if
let's try solving this problem now
remember you can answer these questions
using filters and that can be an easier
way but then sometimes you may want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic in nature and that will
basically depend on the values in the
columns or rows so for example if I have
find the total number of times Gill has
made a sale now if I look at my data
here it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value in
the sale and it says sales has greater
than 3 so for example Jones you have
sales greater than three or you have
Jardine which is sales greater than 3
and so on so what we are interested in
is doing a quick count and finding out
the total number of times Gill has made
a sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if I go into
countif it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is Gill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
Gill appears or kill has made a sale now
I could just say count if and then open
up a bracket I need to give a range so
let's say we are interested in looking
at the range so let's say we will choose
sales rep so I can say C and then I can
say c 2 2 C 44 now
that's my range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is Gill and then close this so
that basically tells me it is 5 times
kill appears here we can check this so I
can go in here I can add a filter and
then might be I would be interested in
looking at only Gill
and that basically gives me five right
so we can always do that and we can be
using formulas like this now what about
this question so which basically says
with sales representative made a sale
more than three times now we it might be
looking little confusing when I say for
example let me clear out this filter
now we have sales greater than 3 and we
would want to find out which sales
representative made a sale more than
three times now I could basically check
for every sales representative here if
they have made a sale more than three
times and what I can do is I can just
say equals I can start with count if
then I need my filtering criteria so
that's your range so first thing is we
will choose for example is choose C2 to
C 44 and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so I can choose the value here in C2
and then I can close this and then I can
say the sale has to be greater than 3
and let's check so it tells me the
Boolean value that yes this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just drag and drop
which basically gives me the value for
other sales rep you can always check the
value is automatically changing to this
value in cell and for example let's go
in here so this is obviously 2 so it
says me false right and you can
basically get the values for all your
values so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like sumifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically get
the count of number of orders which were
placed now I can in this case use count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start with an criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after particular date so date is in my
First Column so for example I could say
a
start with 2 and say for example let's
go a44 that should have selected all the
rows
and then I need to
once I have given the criteria range I
need to give the criteria so we are
saying
the date has to be greater than 10th Feb
so let's give it
to
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed
from the east region so when I would
want to look at the region that's your
column B so I can basically say B2 to P
and here
I would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is East
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this and if I do
this it tells me 13 now is that right so
we are looking for your date
your region being East and then getting
the total number of orders so here I can
just do account if I'm saying A2
to a44
wherein I have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th Feb because I do not want to count
10 Feb it says after 10 February and
then you are saying the region has to be
East so we would want to find out the
total number of orders so my region is
east and that gives me the result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times Gill
sold pencils so here we will have to
give the range so
let's start with count
ifs
now here I would want that items pencils
so we can as well select column D2
d44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then we are looking for sales rep
which is Gill so that is my column C so
let's say c 2 2 C 44 and the value
should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where Gill has sold pencils
so we can obviously check this by going
in here
choosing my filter and then let's search
for rep being just Gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil so I can say well
let's get to pencil only and that tells
me twice so you can obviously re-verify
using filters but using functions or
using formulas it is always good to
calculate and that can be making your
computation and calculation more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of Excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen conditional formatting has
different rules which can be applied on
your data and that allows you to
basically differentiate or easily
identify data values which are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you you can easily
manage these rules so conditional
formatting is very useful for people who
would want to work on huge amount of
data and easily perform some data
analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting you can
format cells based on a preset condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells you can highlight a
few significant cells and you can easily
perform conditional formatting
as shown on the left side now how do we
work with conditional formatting let's
have a quick look so say for example we
have our Excel sheet and if you see here
I am highlighting the sales person who
have generated Revenue greater than 10
000.
so we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color and how do we get here so for
example let's select this data
and what I could do is
I could go into conditional formatting
now I could basically highlight cell
rules
and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way I could also go
ahead and create a new rule but then I
can use one of this option I can say
greater than and let's give some value
might be we would be interested in
looking at any value greater than 12 000
so let's choose 12.
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example I would
say something like
yellow fill with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what I'm
doing is
I have all the values where the revenue
generated was greater than 10 000 but
then I have also selected all the sales
people who have made or who have
generated Revenue greater than 12 000.
so I can just do a Ctrl Z to see the
previous result now here I had the
values which were greater than 10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here I have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example I can go in here and I can go to
conditional formatting so I would want
to go for color scales and here you can
create different rules so we can set up
a two color scale so we can say format
only values that are above and below
average I can format only cells that
contain something I can get the top and
bottom value so these are different ways
in which I can have a three color based
scale now what I will do is I will
select this and let me show you the rule
with which I have so for example I can
go into manage rules and if you see here
there are certain rules which have been
specified now what does that mean so you
would want to specify a three grade
scale so for example if I would want to
look at my first rule it tells me that I
am choosing three color scale I can
choose lowest value percentile and
highest value and that basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is I can
basically
use one of these values I can delete
these rules which I have created so for
example I have all these rules but you
should always carefully remember that
the rules will be applied in the order
shown so for example if I just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now it does not have any
highlighting now I can go in here I can
say conditional sorry conditional
formatting I could go for color scale so
I could basically go into
new rule so I would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red I can say midpoint
is percentile 50 and then the highest
value is green and if that looks good
let's say okay and now if you see the
lowest values have been highlighted as
red you have mid values and then you
have the positive value so this is the
three color scale and that easily helps
me in identifying the data based on the
cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here is if the revenue
generated is greater than average then
that shows in green and if the revenue
generated is lesser than average that's
shows in Orange now how do we do that so
we can basically again manage some rules
so I can basically create a new rule now
here I can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option I would want to select now I can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so in our case we
had it in green so for example I'll say
above average and then here I can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size so
let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow
say okay now I'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here let's go and look
into manage rules so this is basically
the rule which we are applying now we
can also add a new rule
and I need to select the values so for
example I will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below we'll go for format we will
choose red we'll say okay we'll say
now these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if I select this and then I
could basically choose my area just hit
on enter and similarly you can go in
here and then select your area hit on
enter and say apply say okay and now if
you see I have really chosen bright
colors but then I have said wherever my
revenue generated is above average it
should be in yellow and
below average should be in Red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in Orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this and
then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items or
you can go in for more rules so you can
say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10 now you can
choose the color and for example I'll go
for blue
and
I'll say okay so now if you see my top
10 values are blue now similarly I can
add one more rule so I can say new rule
and I can say let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay say okay and that's it so now
you have your values which are top or
bottom 10 values so you are using
conditional formatting where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what we can do is we can
select our columns either you could
apply this to all the columns now here I
have applied this only to Jan and April
now I could apply this for June so let's
say June so you can go for gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select the color and that
takes care of the things you can say for
example select this and now this is
selected what I would want to might be
format this so I can go in here I can go
into manage rules now that will tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so I can just do a edit
Rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now I can go for something like gradient
fill
and I can say okay and now if I say
apply and okay so this basically is Like
Your First Column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be here the revenue is getting
generated or was getting generated but
did not grow Beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can also go
in for different options say for example
here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up for
this particular sales person so here we
are looking at Carol so in Jan the
revenue Generation by sales was very
high then in Feb it was falling down
in March it was kind of stable then in
April it went way below so we can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for highlighting the
cell values now you can go for color
scales you can go for Icon sets and this
is where you can choose your different
shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
I would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional I could go
using this three arrows I can go in for
this color I can choose directional and
then my values are
automatically using directional now what
we can also do is we can then go into
manage rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon set
which I have chosen it shows the
selected columns I can obviously do a
edit Rule and then I can choose so I'm
saying the format style is icon sets I'm
not using a data bar I'm not using color
scale now here I have chosen the style
of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green when the value is greater than or
equal to 67 percentage
when I say hyphen or minus it is less
than 67. it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily highlight your
cell values based on this icon set so I
can apply this and that's how I use
conditional formatting so conditional
formatting can be very useful if you
would want to use icon set if you want
to use your data bars if you would want
to highlight particular values if you
would want to color code based on some
calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts or people
who are working in business intelligence
teams or people who would want to use
Excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value or finding out less
significant or more significant cells to
then pull out values and carry out your
computations calculations or analysis
so let's continue learning on using
Excel for various things now we have
learned on conditional formatting and
seen how that can be very helpful let's
learn one more feature of Excel and
that's basically your data validation
now this can be very useful when you
would want to work on validating the
data which is being fed in the cells so
you could limit it to basically a number
between a particular value you could
also add some messages to it if you
would want or you could even
Circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in Excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a Cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict that the name should accept
only 15 characters now how do you do
that so you can basically select the
cells or you can just select a
particular cell and then we can later
drag the property to other fields now
here once the cell is selected so for
example let's try this out and let's see
if that works so for example people I
will say Peter Johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
Junior
and if I do this it says input length is
greater than 15 do you want to continue
if I say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that so for this we can basically select
the column and then we can search for
data Tab and get into Data validation so
this is where you can create or select
different kind of rules so for example I
can go into validation I can go into
settings and I can say the text length
and that should be less than 15 now this
is the maximum I'm giving and it says
apply these changes to all other cells
within the same settings so I can do
this or I can just drag and drop so I
can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
Control Data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters it will pop up a
message if the user really wants to go
beyond the particular limit now you also
have similarly date of birth so the
Restriction is date of birth should be
between 10 Jan 1990 to 30 December 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here I have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 Jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now I can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so I can say stop I can say
invalid entered
and this is how I have set a rule so for
example if I just do something like this
and that says invalidate entered I can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until I did not give the
right format the date will not be
accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well I
would want to apply this rule to all
these rows starting from C2 to c14 so
let's get into Data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom now within custom I am
choosing what is the formula so I'm
saying is number
and then I'm saying find
at the rate for
the rows C2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for error
alert so for example we can basically go
in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title I'm giving and we can
say email should contain
at the rate
so if I do this and if I say ok now you
can test it so you can say A B C D and
that says email should contain at the
rate and basically that will not allow
me to add the values so now you have the
field called salary it says salary
should be greater than 50 000 now we can
limit the values by choosing a whole
number so for example for salary I can
go into Data validation I can go into
settings so here I can say something
like decimal or I can go for whole
number so both of the things are fine it
depends on what kind of values get into
this particular field so if I say whole
number and if I say it has to be greater
than 50 000 so I'm saying the minimum is
50 000 or I could have given a decimal
and then I can say greater than less
than equal or anything or even between
so I can select greater than and then I
can just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here and in rank if you
click on data validation I have chosen
whole number
I have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends I can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see I have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city names and then you
have places within that particular City
so if I would want to implement a data
validation based on this so for example
if you see here City and that basically
shows me only the four values which can
be entered and if I go to place then it
tells me for Maharashtra I can only
enter Pune Mumbai nashik now how do I do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so I could select
data validation I could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then I can just
select these fields now if I do this and
if I say OK it has implemented a data
validation but if you look into this it
will show me the same thing but then it
shows me some empty cells which did not
have any value so this is fine but it
would be better if we do it in a
different way so I can select this and I
have already given my city names here so
I can just do a data validation and here
in the source let me get rid of this now
I can just have my cursor here I can
select these values and then if I say ok
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to these values and
that's how you can Implement your data
validation so I have this data
validation here but I will get rid of
this one by just doing a control Z now
I'll come here and say for example I
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in doing this for all my four cities now
if you see here I have data validation I
could choose Bangalore and if you come
and check here there is no data
validation but we have implemented data
validation here now how is that done so
I could select this or for example I can
go in here I can select data validation
I can select list and then here in the
source I will say for Bangalore the
value should be these and then if I
basically say okay
now if we see these are the values which
are fed into Bangalore so we could do
this or like what we have done here so
if you can check the data validation
rule I have used list and then I have
said indirect F2 so basically I'm giving
in a formula which relates to the value
which is in for the city Maharashtra so
we could do this or in a simpler way we
could do this and then just drag and
drop here so we could check for
Maharashtra what are the values let's
choose a different city so for example
Kolkata and here I will choose now since
we did a drag and drop it has basically
taken the values of Bangalore so that's
not right so we select this we go into
Data validation and here I can either
feed in the values that is such as
Bangalore I could basically say
something like this Kolkata and I could
say okay so now if you see it shows me
the places in Kolkata now here we have
let's choose a different city so for
example let's go for Delhi and here I
can go to data validation and I can just
say Delhi so this is an easier way of
doing it or if you remember the formula
then what you can do is you can just
give in
indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell for which you
would want to keep in the values so this
is how you can do list validation so you
can provide a list of values and then
you can restrict the values in a Cell
which should be belonging to a
particular list so this is how you do a
simple data validation by restricting
the data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of Excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis now pivot table is a summary of
your data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set and it allows you to group your data
in several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of items here it also tells me
the sum of sales and basically it gives
me per item what is the total sum of
sales which were made now how do I get
this here so for example if I would want
to delete this and I would be interested
in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the row end if I just do a
control and right arrow it tells me
what's my right last column and if I
just do a control and down arrow it
tells me there are
9994 rows now I can use this and what I
can do is I can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since I have chosen my first
row and First Column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
I'll say existing worksheet and I can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field and that
should be good enough so for example if
I close this or if I say ok so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table will be created now what are
the fields we are interested in so as
per the problem we need to find out what
the total sales for each category so
let's go in here and let's select the
field category now as soon as you do
that it shows that the rows
which are being selected are for this
column category and now we are
interested in getting the sales so we
would want the sales per category so
let's select this so you see some of
sales is selected now close this and
that's it that's that's your data so it
shows you row labels it tells you what
are the different categories
and it also gives you some of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have another data set so again you can
just check how many rows we have and it
is basically the same
9994 and if I look in columns it
basically shows me profit is the last
column
and here we would want to find out which
category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so we have some
categories here which says furniture and
it shows some sub categories and then it
shows me office supplies and then some
sub categories and same thing with
technology now we know how we got this
data but this is different than what we
were seeing here so here we were just
getting the categories what what we did
not have any breakdown of sub categories
within this particular category and here
you see there is a breakdown and then
basically you can also apply a filter
which basically says what is the data
you want and if you are interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this so for example let me get
rid of this now we know how we can find
out the category of items but we would
want to find out which sub category of
items sold the maximum under each
category so here we are not looking at
sales but we are looking at the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and First Column
click on insert click on pivot table
data is already selected let's choose
existing worksheet let's choose a
location in our worksheet where we would
want to have this so maybe I can select
this particular field and then just
close this so it says this is the
existing worksheet say okay and now you
need to select your columns so for
example
if I would want the data for categories
so I can select this now I know that
within category these are the options
which we have and then there is a
subcategory so let's select that and if
you see here now we have the data which
will be filtered So based on your
category and sub category and then we
will choose quantity so it automatically
understands that this is something on
which summation can be done so let's
select this and close on this now if you
see here we have got our items where we
can see
the subcategories within a particular
category now I can basically close this
and that just shows me high level
categories here so here I can again
select a particular
row and column I can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected existing worksheet is what I
want so now I will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier so we will select
category subcategory and quantity so the
data has already come in just select
this and now you already have all your
data but this is not what we want we
want to basically apply a filter to this
now how do we do that so we can go for
slicer so I can go for insert slicer and
then it tells what are the subcategories
which you are interested in so for
example if I go for something like
subcategory and say Okay so this tells
me what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has Furnishings with the
highest value so I can select say
furnishings and then I was interested in
office supplies So within office supply
I can basically
search for
here
binder so I can just do a control and
select binder
and then I can also know for technology
I can select phones so I'll say control
and select phones and now if you see the
filter has been applied and we have
these subcategories which are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so I can just delete
this and I have my data which shows me
Furniture being the main category and
that has only Furnishings office supply
having binders and Technology having
phones and that basically is a filter
applied on the result of your pivot so
this is how we are seeing which
subcategory of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region that made
the highest average profit now how do we
calculate that so for example this is
the data we have and as I've instructed
earlier you can select the first one
first column you can click on insert go
into pivot table and that basically
selects all your data we will choose the
result should be in this existing
worksheet so select this click here and
then basically let's select
this cell and I will say okay so now my
pivot table will be here so we are
interested in finding out top three
states within each region which have
made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select region so when we select region
it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state So within every region
you have multiple States so that's what
we are selecting and then we are
interested in looking at the profit so
let's select profit and that
automatically shows up here so we can
now say close this so basically we have
all the data but we are looking at the
sum of profit but that's not what we
want we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so here we have sum of profit so I can
do a right click and basically I can say
summarize values by average so now I'm
getting the average here and that
basically tells per region I have the
average profit but first is let's sort
this data so let's go into sort more
options and here I have average of
profit or for example as I said you can
select region say okay and now it is
basically having the
regions and then you have your state
value so again we can do a sorting here
and I can say
let's go for more sort options I'll say
descending the state values should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay and now if you see
in particular region we have the data
which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top now what we
can also do is we can basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but I am not interested in top 10 so I
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region you
have the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your West now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and Central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort Z
to A if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting more sort
options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now based
on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay and now you see the
data has been filtered so it says per
region now you can always select this
and you can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit now we
are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted within the region
and what is the average now we have one
more question what is the percentage
contribution of each subcategory of
products under each category to the
total sales so we know there are
different products there are different
categories and all the categories
contribute to the total sales so we
would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory
of products under each category so we
not only want the category percentage
but we would also want what is the
contribution of each subcategory
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and First Column click on your insert
click on your pivot table and now the
data is already selected existing
worksheet place your cursor here and
then let's select this cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category and then within
a category we will have subcategories
and we are interested in the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sump now we can click here
value field settings and it says if you
would want to summarize this it says
show value as and what are the values
you would want so you can straight away
go ahead here and say percentage of
grand total so we could do that because
we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now I could basically say
percentage of grand total say okay and
then just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many subcategories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the subcategory cells right click
now you have option filter and you have
sorting so we can say more sort options
now here I will say descending and you
want the descending to be sum of sales
which is already showing as percentage
click on OK and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales it shows the sub
categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales so technically speaking if
you look at all these values which are
subcategories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total so this is how we can solve a
simple problem like this what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory of products under each
category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment we are looking for customer
which made the lowest profit we are also
looking for the state as the main
criteria so in each state we would look
for home office segment and within that
we would look for customer which has
made the lowest profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into selecting our
row and column we will go into insert
I'll say pivot table I'll say existing
worksheet and let me get my result here
so let's say okay now that gives me the
PO table so the first thing is we are
looking at per state
and
I would be interested in
home office segment or I could first
start with segment now here we have
segment and in segment I can basically
select home office so I can just do a
uncheck and select home office only
and now I can select
state so that will be my
subcategory within segment and then
within State we would want to find out
the customer so let's get the customer
name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit and
here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this and now
you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this and
we have state entries also so that's
fine so what I can do is here I can
basically say sorting go to more sort
options I can say I want to do it
descending or I want to do an ascending
an ascending based on sum of profit so
let's do that now you see the top most
value is the lowest value per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state so how do we do that so we can
just go for filtering go for top 10
values I am interested in bottom value
and in that also I am looking for only
the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table now say for
example we have a question which says
find the sales made in each quarter of
2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order here as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that so for example I will
get rid of this
I will get rid of
this my Pivot chart which we can
recreate so find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions so
this is what we want now how do we do
this so for example let's select this we
will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet and
then I can select this particular cell
I'll say OK and now I am interested in
data quarterly so first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if I say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected now we could be selecting
these fields which says
quarters years and if I would want data
to be filtered based on years I could do
that or I could get rid of here so I
have quarters I have ordered date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region and we can also add region as a
column here so that will basically give
me all the regions as different columns
and then finally we want the sales so
let's select this
and now let's look what we have so if
you see here
we have our data which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels so let's
click on this so we have date filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016 and the value has to be 1 and then
let's select this and let's change this
to 2016.
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31
so we are saying the date has to be
2016.
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this and let's make it
date and say okay and now we have our
data which is
foreign
2016. so for example I could basically
select this and here I could be looking
at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data so we have
applied the filter on order date and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 or this is wrong so this one has
to be changed to 2016. so select this
and now we have our data for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value or for individual
months in a particular quarter and we
have sliced the data now we could have
also introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if I would select a
particular field and then I could click
on slicer I could choose I would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to plot
a graph for this and that's very easy so
you just need to select the complete
pivot data and here you have the chart
options so let's go for line chart and
that basically shows me the line chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here and then we can
basically check if that is showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors so we have all the
regions we could filter out in pivot
chart a particular region we have the
quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is
2016. in quarters it tells me it is 16.
so we have our data we have created a
pivot chart and basically we have sliced
the data for 2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram for
the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what I can do is I can
basically
select my row ID here and now I'll do a
pivot table so the data is already
selected I'll choose existing worksheet
let's select this particular cell say
okay now what are we interested in now
if you look at the fields we don't see
any years or quarters and so on so for
example here I can just choose order
date
and then basically
I can choose say for example years or
quarters the data which is coming out
from my order date so here I will just
select years
now
then I have my order date so
we are interested in the Years orders
and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select profit so that basically
says sum of profit but then I'm also
interested in
for all the categories of products so
what I can do is here I have my field
which is category and that I'll add to
the columns so that shows me what are
the different categories
and this looks fine now I'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is I'll click on region
and here it says select all I'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered based on the
region so here we have region so you can
always look at the filter it is east and
west and we have our year data per year
we have different categories you can
always look at what are these column
labels so this is my different
categories and this is the profit per
category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this so we have our data for all
these years different categories the
profits made per year and if I would
want I could go into an year and I could
look into different months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so I can just place my cursor here
I can select this and then I can go into
insert and here I have different options
so we can go for bar chart we can go for
insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional let's select this and
here you see you can obviously select
different regions
you have your ears which shows up you
have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way so what is
Excel power query
power query is an advanced feature of
Microsoft Excel that allows you to
prepare your data for analysis you can
perform numerous text computations and
numerical analysis to make your data
more powerful and informative Excel
power query is a data preparation and
transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in Excel there was difficulty in
data connections Now using power query
you can connect to a broad range of data
sources such as relational databases web
files text CSV Json files and even fetch
data in the cloud
volume variety and velocity are the
characteristics that define Big Data it
was a major problem to handle such data
Now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query reputable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in Excel it was not so easy to reshape
transform and manipulate data but using
power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from Excel 2016 onwards power query on
Windows has been fully integrated into
Excel but in Excel 2010 and 2013 for
windows power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the Excel ribbon now
coming to the features of power query so
Excel power query allows you to clean
transform manipulate and process your
data for analysis it helps you to
automate repetitive tasks that you want
to do it over and over again you can
search for data sources and make
connections as and when you want Power
query helps you to prepare and shape the
data in the right format for performing
analysis
and finally once your data is ready you
can share your findings or use your
query to create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on Wikipedia Pages then
you'll learn how to sort and filter data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns and then pivot and unpivot your
table
then you are going to work on date
columns and make some transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open MS Excel and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here I have my Excel file opened and
in the middle you can see I have my
employee txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
The Columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now this text file has information about
the name each company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
EMP text file into Ms Excel
here I am using Excel 365 or Office 365
where power query on Windows has been
fully integrated into this version of
excel
so what I'll do is first
let's go to the data Tab and
you have this section called get and
transform data so I'll click on get data
under get data I'll go to from file
and select from Text slash CSV
once I click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there so my file is on desktop I'll
click on power query files and here you
can see I have my employee txt file you
can see the type here it says text
document
click on EMP
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto Excel
it's establishing a connection you can
see there you go so here you can see the
file name emp.txt you can see the file
origin as I said the delimiter is comma
and we have the data type detection
and here you can see
we have a text file so Excel power query
feature has automatically detected the
column names so we have name age company
and city as our columns and these are
the values
now let's hit load
so this will load all the rows and the
columns onto Excel
there you go it was really quick
Excel has automatically loaded our text
file
now you can see here we have another tab
called queries and connections so we
have made one query and have loaded the
employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it so let's
first select the data and we'll go to
the insert tab under insert tab I'll
click on recommended charts
let's say I want to know how many
employees belong to a particular City
so I'll click on the second chart which
says the count of Name by City And I'll
click on OK
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart and
you can see in Bangalore there were five
employees in Hyderabad we had two and in
nashik we had one you can see the count
here this is a pivot table
if you go back to our actual data here
you can see
in Bangalore we had Vidya Sonam Avinash
Varun and himani
and there were
two more people from Hyderabad and one
from nasik so you can use the Excel
power query feature to import data onto
Excel and make some visualizations
now if you want to fetch some data that
is present on the web or on the Internet
Excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here I'll be using a Wikipedia article
on the list of European Cup and UEFA
Champions League finals let me show you
the page first
so this is my Wikipedia page on the list
of European Cup and UEFA Champions
League finals if I scroll down you can
see all the details here
and I would like to import this table
which has the list of all the finals so
we have columns like season winners
score Line run us up venue and
attendance
let's import this table onto Excel
so I'll copy this URL first
now let me open a new sheet I'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
I'll go to from other sources and here I
have from web which allows me to import
data from the web either you can follow
this path or if you see here there's an
option to get data from the web if I
click on this
it is asking me to enter the URL so I'll
paste the URL of the Wikipedia page here
and let's click on OK
now it's navigating and okay
you can see
power query feature in Excel has given
us a list of tables which you can see
here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which was extracted
from the Wikipedia page and the table
which I am interested in is this table
which has the list of European Cup
finals you can see it here
Excel power query feature has
automatically detected these rows and it
has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the per query
now if I click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just click on refresh now this is
the most important section
Now using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a Home tab that has
a query section you can see you can
reduce rows manage columns sort the data
transform the data combine different
tables
now there is another tab called
transform which allows you to select
your data type transpose your rows and
columns
columns and here you can see you can
find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows the values
are the same you can see season season
these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if I scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these rows do not add up any
value or do not add any value to our
data so we'll clean this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table what you can do is
go to the Home tab and under reduce rows
click on remove rows
and then choose remove top rows
if I select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here I'll give I want to
remove the top two rows
now let's click on OK
you will see
that the Excel power query editor has
removed the first two rows and on the
right you can see the steps that were
applied
you can see it here previously we had
these two rows which were redundant and
once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly let's go down and remove the
last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again I'll go to reduce rows and
click on remove rows now this time I'll
select remove bottom rows
and here I'll choose
I want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
I click on OK
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
let me show you the last row which is
this one
so the last season of
UEFA Champions League was held in 2020
which is this year
and Bayern Munich won the Champions
League against
a French team that was Paris Saint
Germans by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
you can see the value is 0 which means
there were no Spectators in the stadium
it was because of the covet conditions
and let's do some more manipulation to
our data suppose this time I want to add
a new column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column so the first
value is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there
and finally we have the
country name
so I want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like Santiago bernabeau
this Wembley San Siro
another stadium so I want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
I'll click on the menu column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have extract now if I click on this drop
down there is an option to select
text before delimiter so if I choose
text before delimiter here
I'll give my delimiter as comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on OK
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if I scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has our stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now I want to add a new column called
Stadium City
so if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city so for example
Santiago bernabao is in Madrid similarly
Wembley Stadium is in London San Siro is
in Milan so these middle values I want
to extract into a new column called as
Stadium City
so let's see how to do it
so I'll click on the menu column and go
to extract
and again I'll select
the extract tab
and here now I'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter algorithm is a
comma
and a space you can see here all the
values
have a comma and a space
and my ND limiter will be another comma
then I'll click on OK this will add a
new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters and it has extracted the
stadium city
let me go ahead and rename this
column as Stadium
City
and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
I want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team and the right value presents the
number of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here I'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what I'll do is
select this column and go to the Home
tab under the Home tab we have split
column
I'll select split column and then choose
by delimiter
so automatically Excel power query
detects that this Dash is my delimiter
and I'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on OK
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score.1 and
score.2
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and
we'll rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to Loser score
I'll hit enter
and I have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the windows team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose I want to change all the
values or the club names of the winners
team to upper case so what I can do is
I'll select this column and go to the
transform tab under transform tab I have
this option called
format
so here
I'll click on format and then
you can see I can change the keys to
lowercase uppercase capitalize each word
so here I want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase I'll select uppercase
there you go we have successfully
converted all the winner team names to
upper case
similarly let's do it for the runners of
team as well
so here I have my Runner sub team
I'll go to the transform tab click on
format and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this I have to go to the
Home tab and then click on close and
load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this Excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time there you
go
Excel power query feature has
successfully
perform some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has saved the final version and
loaded it on to excel Now using this
clean data we can do some analysis let's
say I want to find the seasons in which
the winners team scored more than three
goals so we have a problem statement at
hand we want to find the seasons in
which the winner team had more than
three goals scored
so what you can do is select any cell in
this data and go to the insert tab and
click on pivot table
here I'll click on existing worksheet
and then I'll give my location
I'll place my
pivot table somewhere here and click on
OK
all right now
since I want to know the seasons I'll
drag season onto row
and I'll also drag
the winners team
column onto rows
then I'll choose my winner score under
values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what I'll do is
I'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see I have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and I'll select multiple items
from this multiple items I'll choose 4 5
and 7 because these values are greater
than 3 and click on OK
here you can see I have filtered my
pivot table and
to the left you can see the season
and the winner team that had scored more
than three goals in the finals
all right
similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose I want to know how many times
Real Madrid won the championship so
let's see
I'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert Tab and click on pivot
table
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say I want to place my pivot table
here
I click on OK
all right so the question we have is how
many times have Real Madrid won the
championship so I'll choose
the Winner's team column and place it
under rows
and
let's see
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on OK
and
since I want to check only for Real
Madrid
so what I'll do is I'll go to
the insert tab and I'll insert a slicer
here I'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
OK
and out of this I want to choose only
Real Madrid so I'll select Real Madrid
you can see it here Real Madrid have won
the championship 13 times
okay let's say you want to compress your
data and remove unnecessary columns
without losing any information you can
do that using a feature in the power
query editor called unpivot
to perform this task we'll use a census
data of India from Wikipedia so let me
first show you the Wikipedia page
so this is my Wikipedia article which
says list of states in India bypassed
population
and if I scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or Union territory and we
have population starting from 1951 till
2011 which was our last census
here you can see if I scroll further
there are
nearly 29 States and we have seven union
territories so we will extract this
table and load into Excel first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and we'll follow the same drill I'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data under get data
I'll go to from other sources and click
on from web
here it will ask me to provide the URL
link of the Wikipedia page so I'll paste
the URL here and click on OK
now once I have done that
it will load a few tables
onto Excel you can see there are a few
tables here I'll click on the first one
so we have our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay I'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data clearly
the first row in this table is not
necessary at all because these are our
column names so we also have our column
headers already present so let's go
ahead and delete the first row so we'll
go to the Home tab under remove rows
I'll click on remove top rows
now I'll give my
number of rows as 1 so we want to remove
the first row only I'll click on OK
you can see the first two has been
deleted
if I scroll further
I actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom
so I'll
select one
click on OK
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that I want to do here is
I want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so I'll
select my
state or Union territory column
and go to the transform Tab and here I
have the option to unpivot columns so
I'll click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted if you want you
can go ahead and
rename these columns let's say I'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
I'll rename it to total population value
all right
now we are done with our preparation of
data let's go to the Home tab and click
on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto Excel
all right so we have our Census Data
here so first you can see
rank 1 is uttar Pradesh and we have the
population starting from 1951 till 2011
then we have for Maharashtra
if I scroll down you can see the other
states we have Tamil Nadu Rajasthan this
Karnataka if I scroll further
you have odisha this Telangana Kerala
now if you see here the population
values from 1951 till 2011 for the
Telangana state are all n a which means
there was no data available
now this is because Telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more features and
functionalities of our query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure Works customer table
now this data set is provided by
Microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi Excel or similar
Technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import
the adventureworks customer data set
it's a CSV file onto Excel first so I'll
go to my data tab
and click on get data from here I'll go
to
from file and choose
from Text slash CSV
you can see it here in my power query
files folder I have my Adventure Works
customer table
I'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if I go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of our query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor so first what I'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column 2
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all in
uppercase now if you want to change the
values to proper case
just
hit Ctrl and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab under transform
tab you have format
so if you click on format here you can
see we have lowercase uppercase now
proper case is to capitalize each word
so I'll click on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop keys The Next Step I'm going
to show you is let's merge all the three
columns the prefix column the first name
column and the last name column into one
full name column so
what I'll do is I'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column
and under add column we have this option
called merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator I'll select my separator as a
space
and click on OK
so before click on OK I want to change
my
new column name from merge to let's say
full name
and now let's click on OK
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if I go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and keep on dragging to the
left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so I want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually I don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this and I'll right click
I click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the other
two columns you can either right click
and do or go to the Home tab and then
select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from AWS customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate
and.com
so actually I'm talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate
and.com
so let's see how to do it
I'll select the email address column and
then I'll go to add column under add
column I'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract between
two delimiters also I'll select
text between delimiters and I'll give my
starting delimiter as at the rate
and my end delimiter would be.com
now let's click on OK
so this will insert a new column to the
extreme right you can see we have our
domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right you can see the step has been
applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customer stable let's
just go to the Home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay
Now using the power query editor you can
perform some
statistical analysis
now let's explore those statistical
features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventurebox product data set
again this data set is also provided by
Microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
I'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files I click on Text slash
CSV here you can see we have Adventure
Works products I click on import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded on to the power query editor
the data is mostly clean so let's not
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's see
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab now in the transform tab
you have an option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293.
now to move back to the query editor we
have to cancel this step here so let's
just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table so if I move to the right
you have a column called Product price
so let's see what is the average product
price from the product table so I'll
select this product price column go to
the transform tab under statistics I'll
select average so this will give me the
average product price which is
714.4373 you can consider any unit you
want let's say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well so let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab under the transform tab
we'll click on this statistic drop down
and let's say I'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go to the transform Tab and then
choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places so if I show you both the columns
you have your product cost and you have
the product price column you can see the
floating values or the decimal points
are not constant it's varying so let's
limit it to two decimal places what you
can do is Select both the columns and
then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
I'll click on this drop down and select
round
now here I'll give my decimal places as
2.
if I click on OK
you can see here both the columns the
product cost and the product price
column have been rounded up to two
decimal places
I can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column by
multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column and let's say you also want to
round that new column to two decimal
places so how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so I'll select this product
price column
go to add column and then I'll choose
custom column
here we'll write a formula
so I'll give my new column name as
discount price
and my formula would be
I'll select product price
I'll click on insert
and then I'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on OK
you see here we have a new column added
which is Discount price
so
If the product price is 34.99 if you
give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
around the decimal places to 2
so go to the transform tab under
rounding I'll click on round
let's see I'll give two and click on OK
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to two decimal places
now we are done with our mathematical
operation on this product data set
so we saw how to find some average count
how to round up values how to add a new
custom column
so let's go ahead and
close it
and load it onto Excel
you see here we have our
new product table
added here and
the last column if you see it's the
discount column that we added
okay now it's time for us to explore
another feature so we'll use a table
called adventureworks calendar table
which has basically a date column and
let's see how using power query you can
prepare that data as well and make some
manipulation some calculations
so let me go ahead and import
adventureworks calendars table again
this data set is provided by Microsoft
so I'll
go to my new sheet
and I'll go to the data tab
click on get data and from here I'll
click on from Text slash CSV and you can
see I have my calendar table here I
click on import
now this will open in the query editor
you see here this data set has only one
column which is a date column so let's
click on
transform data
okay
now if you see here
the first row is actually the column
name
so
let's do the transformation here let's
push this as the column name so I'll go
to the Home tab and on the Home tab you
have this option called use first row as
headers I'll select this
you see here we have the column name as
date
now
before making any
operation let's see
if all the fields are available
you see here if I click on
the date drop down
the year month quarter weekday day
everything has been shaded out and I
can't access this the reason is
the date settings are not correct
so we'll change the regional settings
let me show you how to do it
so we'll go to file and I'll select
options and settings and go to query
options
under query options we have something
called as Regional settings
here under Regional settings we'll
select English United States instead of
English India
so I'll just scroll down
and here we have English United States
and I click on OK
now once this is done I'll go to my data
type and I'll select
date as my data type
I'll choose replace current
okay now you can see my date column has
been formatted if I go to
the date tab you can see I have access
to all this
now let's do some operations on this
date column
let's say you want to find the earliest
and the latest date from aw calendars
table or the adventure box calendar
table
so what you can do is Select this column
go to date drop down under transform and
here we have the option of earliest and
latest so if I click on earliest
this will show you the last date which
was 1st of January 2015
let me close this
similarly you can see the most recent
date
I'll go to the date
drop down and click on latest and you
have 30 June 2017 as the latest date
and close this
now let's add a new column
c d name start of the week and others so
I'll select my date column
go to add column
here under add column I have
my option to
select the D name the week name and
others so I'll click on this date drop
down and under day
let's say I want to choose
name of d
this Returns the D name
similarly
let's say
I want to find out
the start of the week
you can see we have the start of the
week column or start of V column now one
thing to notice here is
in this power query editor the week
starts on a Sunday
now suppose we want to start your week
on a Monday you can do some
Transformations on this formula tab so
here in the formula bar you can add
a 1 here to make sure your week starts
on a Monday so if I hit enter you will
see all this values will change you can
see it's 28 4 and 11 this will become 29
5 and 12. let's hit enter
you can see it here
your start of the week is on a Monday
now there's another method to make sure
your week starts on a Monday let's
cancel this step
okay I have to insert it once again so
I'll go to date
and here I'll choose
start of week
now the week starts on a Sunday
so one more method is to
add day dot
Monday you can see automatically
per query is giving me a suggestion so
I'll hit tab to finish it and I'll hit
enter
now you can see the values have changed
and our week starts on a Monday
now let's see we want to add a few more
columns like start of month name of
month start of year
and the year value so you can just click
on the date column or select the date
column go to the transform tab
okay not the transform tab let's go to
the add column Tab and here let's say
I'll choose here
so we have all the year values and
similarly
let's see I want to know the start of
the year
now you can do a few more
Transformations let's say I want to know
the month
now here it gives us 1 which means
January that's February March and so on
and so forth
let's say we'll do one more
I click on this
go to my
date
drop down and here I'll choose let's say
I want to know
the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing your data
on a date field so let me just go to the
Home tab I'll click on close and load
now this will load the
data set on to excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do a whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
I have my data present in a CSV folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my CSV folder let me open it
and I have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five let
me open just one of the project files it
has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project 4.
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into Excel let's see how to
do it so I'll open a new sheet
and I'll go to my data Tab and click on
get data
then I'll go to from file and this time
I'll choose from folder
now this will ask me to give the folder
location of the path location where my
CSV files are
so I'll choose
browse
and here you can see I have my CSV file
I'll just double click on it
and click on open
now it has selected my
file path
or the folder path
then I'll click on OK
you can see these are the files you have
projectmon.xls
project 2.xls and so on
I'll
click on this combine drop down and I'll
hit combine and transform
now this will give you the preview of
one of the data files
you will see it now
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the data files
present in that CSV folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been combined vertically
here you can see the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column and to the extreme left we have
the source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is Project one then we have
project two if I scroll down we have
project three files project four and
similarly we have project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically so we are
done with it let's just go to the Home
tab and click on close and load
all the Transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five Excel files
again you can also join your data
horizontally this would be like an SQL
join where the data is present in
multiple files or sheets based on a
common key column you can join the
tables so you can perform a left join a
right join an inner join based on the
problem that you are trying to solve so
let's merge two tables based on a column
I'll show the data set first it's an
Excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my Excel file which we'll be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name the gender of
the student and the course the student
had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name gender
as well as the course
and finally we have a courses table or a
courses sheet which has all the details
regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type now we'll use this data sets
to load it onto Excel using power query
so I am on my Excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet I'll go to the data Tab
and here I'll click on get data and this
time I'll choose
from Excel workbook
and I'll select my file which is
students and courses I click on import
so we will just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select the courses sheet
and I'll click on transform data
now this has loaded the courses table
onto power query editor the table looks
fine we have the course column teacher
everything is fine now let's load one
more table and then we'll merge it so
here under the Home tab you have
a section called new source
I'll click on file
I'll again select my students and
courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
I click on OK
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so I'll go to the Home tab
and select use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name the gender column and the course
column
now let's merge it so if you see here in
the Home tab we have a section called
merge queries
let's click on this drop down and select
here I have my table which is year 11
and let's choose one more table that is
courses
now the kind of join
I'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the rows from the
first table and matching records from
the second table
here I need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so I'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on OK
let's just expand this
and click on OK
if I scroll to the right you can see I
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see I
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also I
have
the course column now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns I'll just select this column
I'll go to
remove columns and I'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close And load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto Excel you can see it here we
have successfully loaded it onto Excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see what all we have done
in our demo so I'll
go to my first sheet here you can see
we had
imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we imported
a UFO Champions League table which was
present on Wikipedia and then we plotted
some
graphs and charts you can see we made
some analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from Adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables business intelligence is
a set of processes and techniques to
analyze raw data and extract information
that helps Drive business decisions it
helps you keep track of business data
and draw valuable insights there are
several tools that play a key role in
business intelligence some of the
popular tools are power bi Tableau and
click view hi guys welcome to this
tutorial on what is power bi in this
video you will learn why power bi is
needed what is power bi the various
features of power bi and the different
components of power bi later you will
look at the architecture of power bi for
power bi services and how to create a
power bi dashboard finally you will
understand a case study on Meyer and do
a demo using power bi now let's
understand why power bi is needed first
Power Pi has the ability to access vast
volumes of data from multiple sources it
allows you to view analyze and visualize
huge quantities of data that cannot be
opened in Excel some of the important
data sources available in power bi are
Excel CSV XML Json PDF Etc second power
bi provides an easy to use drag and drop
tool with features and functionalities
that allow you to copy all formatting
across similar visualizations power bi
has exceptional integration with Excel
it helps you gather analyze publish and
share Excel business data power bi helps
to accelerate Big Data preparation with
Azure using power bi with Azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data as your data leak can reduce the
time it takes to get insights and
increase collaboration between business
analysts data engineers and data
scientists power bi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into actions to take data-driven
business decisions finally power bi
allows you to perform real-time stream
analytics it fetches data from multiple
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real-time analytics so you are
always ready to make business decisions
now let's see what power bi is power bi
is a business analytics service provided
by my Microsoft that lets you visualize
your data and share insights it converts
data from different sources to build
interactive dashboards and bi reports as
you can see we have an Excel data about
sales using this data power bi helps you
build different charts and graphs to
visualize the data now that we have
understood what power bi is let us look
at the important features of power bi
first is power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a free software that you can
download and it allows you to build
reports by accessing data easily for
using power bi desktop you do not need
Advanced report designing or query
skills to build a report second as
already discussed power bi supports
stream analytics from Factory sensors to
social media sources power bi assists in
real-time analytics to make timely
decisions third support for multiple
data sources is one of the major
features of power bi you can access
various sources of data such as Excel
CSV SQL Server web files Etc to create
interactive visualizations and finally
custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs let
us jump into discussing the various
components of power bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mashup engine it
enables you to discover connect combine
and refine data sources to meet your
analysis need it can be downloaded as an
add-in for Excel or can be used as part
of power bi desktop second we have power
pivot power pivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or Dax to model simple and complex data
third we have power view Power view is a
technology that is available in Excel
SharePoint SQL server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to Life Next we have
power map Microsoft's power map for
Excel and power bi is a 3D data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on Bing maps in 3D
format from an Excel table or data model
in Excel then we have power bi desktop
power bi desktop is a development tool
for power query power pivot and Power
view with power bi desktop you have
everything under the same solution and
it is easier to develop bin data
analysis experience finally we have
power Q and A the Q a feature in power
bi lets you explore your data in your
own words it is the fastest way to get
an answer from your data using natural
language an example could be what was
the total sales last year once you have
built your data model and deployed that
into Power bi website then you can ask
questions and get answers easily now
let's see what power bi services
power bi service is the software as a
service part of power bi it is also
referred as power bi online to access
power bi service you need to log into
app.powerbi.com now let me show you that
I'll go to Google
open a new tab and search for app dot
power bi
.com
it's loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like I have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.power bi service you can
see I'm logged in now under my workspace
if I go to dashboard here I've created a
finance dashboard you can see the
different charts and graphs I have
prepared and pinned it to the dashboard
so power bi service allows you to
connect to your data create reports and
dashboards and you can also ask
questions to your data as you can see in
this dashboard we have created some
charts and graphs so this is a tree map
there's a pie chart there's a bar graph
below you can see the line charts and
donut charts it tells you the total
sales that were made the total number of
units solds the sales by product sales
by country sales by segment and lots
more one of the key features of power bi
is creating dashboards from multiple
reports and data sets power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story The visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from multiple reports and
each report is based on one data set a
single page dashboard is known as a
canvas the visualizations you see on the
dashboard are called tiles these tiles
are pinned to the dashboard by report
designers now let me go back to my
dashboard so this is called a canvas and
each of these are called tiles so on the
top you can see we have three tiles now
let's understand how to create and
publish reports in power bi dashboards
power bi allows you to create different
reports on power bi desktop these
reports can be published on the power bi
dashboard using power bi service here
you can see there is a power bi report
created on power bi desktop if you click
on publish it will take you to the power
bi service where you can build a
dashboard here is the button for power
bi publish once you click on power bi
publish it will take you to the
dashboard so this is a single page power
bi dashboard on power bi service now
let's understand the power bi
architecture power bi architecture is a
service built on top of azure there are
multiple data sources that power bi can
connect to power bi desktop allows you
to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set Power bi
Gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for Windows
IOS and Android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how Meyer which is
one of United States largest Supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially Meyer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
Meyer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what Maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises SQL Server analysis Services
Cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near Real Time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real-time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside Meyer used
power API to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
Meyer was behind the regional Trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 Maya Business
Leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and Empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track their data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical Hands-On demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data View and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables on the right you can
see the different visualizations that
you can build we'll quickly run through
all of these in our demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data Tab and choose Excel as my data
source I click on Excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if I go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has Fields
such as segment country in which the
Salesforce made the name of the product
the unit sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building a report
now I'll go to my report view so first
let me create a text box
let me decided
let me name it as
Finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use Font Consolers
Center it will also add a background to
this we use blue color change it to
White
and
increase the size now let me first show
you how you can create a matrix I'll go
to visualizations and click on Matrix
let me resize it
from the datasheet tab I'll select sales
and drag on to values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so I'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to 20. similarly under values
we'll increase the size of the text to
20 as well we can also click on border
and choose the color of the Border may
take as Let It Be black so this is a
simple Matrix that we created which
shows the total number of seats that
were made similarly let me choose Matrix
once again now we'll drag on the unit
sold onto values we'll continue with the
same drill under column headers We'll
add a background this time let's choose
some other color and under values let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
again we will switch on Border let me
resize a bit
so here we have two Matrix created for
our report the first Matrix shows us the
total sales that were made the second
Matrix shows you the total units that
were sold now let's move ahead and
create a simple bar chart so under
visualization I click on clustered
column chart
under this we'll drag the date column
onto access and the sales onto value let
me expand it so it shows you the sales
per year this is the sales that were
made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014. now
there's a drill down option which gives
you more granularity
this depicts the sales per quarter if I
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like sort by and sort
by sales so you can see October month
made the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments under visualization
I'll click on pie chart let me first
resize it
here
I'll drag the segment column onto the
legend and the sales column onto the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments government
segment made the highest number of sales
with 44.22 percent now let me add a
border to both the visualization I'll
click on the pie chart and go to the
format tab I'll switch on the border
similarly for the clustered column chart
I'll go to the format Tab and click on
Border let me resize a bit alright next
we'll create a very simple table that
will depict the total sales made by each
product so under visualizations I click
on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet I'll first drag
product onto values you can see the
different products and then sales just
below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here now let's do some formatting
under format tab I'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15. I'm expand
it also under column headers I'll
increase the text size to 15. then let
me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization I'll click
on map now I'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if I move the
map you can see the sales made in the
Europe region
let me resize it I'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations I'll
click on donut chart
and move this to the top now from the
data sheet I'll add profit onto the
values and segment
onto the legend
if I expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent let me resize
this and we'll add a border
okay in the final visualization I'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations I'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
I'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have a report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data now if you want to
change the color of these parts you can
simply go to the format Tab and under
data colors you can choose whichever
color you want in power bi desktop you
have an option to switch your theme
this will make your dashboard or the
report look more attractive so now we
are under the default mode Let's try out
different themes let's Frontier
its temperature solar which is a little
yellowish the one which I like is tidal
I hope this was helpful in making you
understand the basics of power bi and
how it works you learn the various
features and the components of power bi
and looked at the architecture of RBI
finally you saw a demo to create a
report using Finance data set so what
are the benefits of power bi here are
some of the benefits so extract
intelligence rapidly accurately so
that's basically transforming your
Enterprise data into Rich visuals and
accurate reports for enhanced decision
making now one thing we already know
that when we talk about data data in raw
format might have a lot of hidden
information if we look at different data
sets which I'll show you in the process
it might have a lot of meaning but then
the real meaning comes out of the data
if we can create visualizations if we
can create relationships between
different data sets and thus that can
help us in enhanced decision making
Now power bi supports Advanced Data
Services it integrates seamlessly with
Advanced cloud services like Cortana to
provide results for the verbal data
queries as well
when you talk about
seamlessly integrating with existing
applications that's one more benefit of
power bi so it adopts analytics and
Reporting capabilities easily to embed
interactive visuals quickly in your
applications you can build Rich
personalized dashboards so it basically
provides a unified user experience with
customized dashboard and reports that
meet your exact needs it also has a way
where you can have secure way of
publishing your reports so you can set
up automatic data refresh and rapidly
publish reports allowing multiple users
to Avail the latest information across
your organization or across your working
community
so power bi can connect to different
sources we'll see that in a while so
basically you have an option which says
get data and that basically opens up a
window where you can find different type
of data sources such as Excel your CSV
or text Json PDF getting data from
databases or directly accessing data
from databases now before we get further
into understanding how power bi looks
like it would be good idea to share
information in how you can set that up
on your machine so when it comes to your
power bi and let me open up a notepad
here
so for example I bring up a notepad
let's say when you talk about your power
bi components
so you basically have
power bi desktop
and that's mainly your playground or
that's mainly used for any kind of
development activities
you have your power bi server
or you can say service so now this one
is where you would make reports
online
and
share
or make them available
to different views
now that's one more component of power
bi and then you also have your power bi
mobile which is mainly for viewing the
information I would say viewing reports
so these are the three main components
we can also look at the licensing
information of these so these are the
mains so power bi desktop is something
which you can set up on your laptop or
on your machine power bi server is where
you can log in with your user ID and
password and power bi mobile is mainly
to view your reports now how do you set
this up before you can explore or start
working on power bi so here is a link
which you can basically use so if you
look into this so this one basically
says Service cell service sign up for
power bi it says sign up of power bi
Service as an individual normally when
you would want to use power bi you can
use a website called stdp and then you
have basically
app
and let's say
I think it's called app powerbi.com now
this is the place where you can
basically log in now if you see here I
have created an account and if you look
at my account it says
auatl dot on microsoft.com now how do
you get this kind of email because when
you talk about power bi it will expect
you to have a official ID and it does
not take IDs which are from common
domains such as Google or Yahoo and so
on so this particular link gives you an
idea how you can do that so basically
you have what is power bi basic
explanation on that it says signing up
for power bi service so power bi desktop
it's a totally free download and then
you have mobile apps also a totally free
download and here it says
that what kind of email addresses it
supports and if we look into this you
have to either sign up because that does
not accept your private email IDs or you
can go for this one which says enroll US
government organization and this is
where you can basically sign up for
power bi so it basically says try free
if you go to the website say power
bi.microsoft.com or you could go into
this one which I was saying HTTP slash
slash app Dot
your powerbi.com and this is what you
can use or as mentioned you can go to
powerbi.microsoft.com for example if I
open this in a different tab
it takes me to about via Microsoft I can
say start free I can click on this
it says strive free but then when it
asks you to sign in this is where some
of us face problem because it does not
take your private email ID now how do
you tackle that what you can do here is
on this page which says learn about
alternate ways to sign up you can
basically open up this link and in this
link it says sign up for power bi with a
new Microsoft 365 trial account and what
you can do is you can basically click on
this link which takes you to The Office
365 and what you can do here is you can
search for something which says say 365
E3 and here you have tried for free
so in my case it is translating okay so
here you have an option which says try
it for free click on this one and then
basically go ahead with your sign up
process now once you do that you can
basically create an account or give a
email ID so it asks you to give an email
ID to check if you already have an
account and once you do that it will
guide you through the process where you
can create an account like I have done
now once you have done that so for
example we can go into my this page
which I said HTTP slash slash app
powerbi.com
now once you have created an account you
would be asked to log in now I can click
and log in here and then basically given
my password and once I do that it takes
me to the power bi server or service now
on the top right it might say that go
for a trial version I have already
selected that and this is a Pro trial
which is giving me validity for 60 days
so this is the service which I can use
now what it means is I can be using my
power bi desktop which would be also
installed so once you log into this page
you can basically click on apps you can
basically search for something like
power bi and that will show up in the
app and you can install and download on
your machine now once that is there you
can basically bring it up so for example
in my case I can just say power bi
desktop and that's the app which I have
installed on my machine and basically
that comes up so that's your power bi
desktop which is coming up and it will
still ask you to sign in so that you can
share your information through Power bi
so you see here on the top I'm already
signed in and here it also shows you
some tutorials and videos which
basically helps you in getting to know
something more or what's new so you can
always browse that so you would have
your power bi desktop which would be set
up
you would also have your power bi
service which would be running and then
basically whatever you have developed on
your power bi desktop you can share that
through the power bi service now usually
when you talk about licensing I can give
you brief insights here so you basically
have your power bi Service as I said
licensing so you have the pro version
which is basically
uh your 9.9 dollars
per user per month
and basically it has some kind of
limitation so it has say Max 10 gigabyte
you can work on uh some features like
incremental refresh is not allowed you
can always look onto the Microsoft
website for more details and in those
kind of cases you usually go for the
premium account if you are a extensive
user and premium account basically is
conditional based so it depends on your
requirements and then basically you pay
for the service what you use so that's
mainly about your servicing now when you
talk about your server and Service as I
said it is basically making your reports
online and sharing and making them
available to different bus so that is
the Highlight so when you talk about
sharing reports that's one of the things
you have and normally detection
that's also possible here you can talk
about automation of reports you have
security that is you can go for role
based or row level based kind of
security implementation and all those
are some of the features of your power
bi server and service so it is good to
know and basically have your desktop and
power bi service set up now once you
have that then you basically have your
power bi now when you talk about your
power bi it basically helps you with
various things so this is how easily you
can have it set up and then basically
you can explore this so for example as I
was saying power bi can connect to
different data sources now I do have an
option here which says get data I can
click on this and that shows me all the
different data sources I can even click
on more if I'm interested in looking
what more power bi desktop tool helps me
to do so it shows me all the different
ways in which you can get the data you
see here the servers so the database
Services your folders your different
formats you can click on file formats or
databases you can look at Power Platform
so if basically you are connecting to a
platform and getting some Services you
can connect to the cloud that is azure
you have online services and then you
have other options so these are all the
ways in which you can get your data when
you talk about visualizations you see a
lot of visualization options here which
can be used once your data is loaded and
I will explore and explain more about
this so you have something called as
insert wherein you can go in for
different visuals or different types you
can also get into say transform the data
now that basically is going to pop up
and bring a power query editor now
that's where a lot of your ETL Works
happen so when you when you do a
transform data it opens a power query
editor which we can use to transform the
data or change the data or modify the
data as per our requirement before
loading all of it into our power bi so
you also have option here which says
modeling wherein we can create new
tables or we can work on our data where
we can manage relationships so as of now
we don't have any data so it does not
show this one is activated but that can
be activated this is where you can view
your reports so this is in short
exploring your power bi we'll see what
are the different options which we can
use here so it basically supports
different kind of data so when we look
at the visualization pane that
basically allows us to create different
kind of visualizations here and we will
understand that so you can basically
visualize on your different data and
create different kind of charts graphs
maps and basically derive insights from
your data now when you talk about data
models that's where you can basically
establish relationships so when you talk
about data models it is basically used
to connect multiple data sources to
build a relationship now we might have
different data sets or we might have
data coming in from different tables
where we may want to basically
get insights or get data from multiple
data sources
for our purpose now in that case data
models to help us so for example if you
have two tables let's look at the
standard tables so you have products
lookup table and you also have the sales
table now usually what you have in any
kind of scenario is if we basically say
you have your data tables so that's
basically where your data resides and
then you have series of your lookup
tables so usually you might have say
your data tables here
and this is what I am talking about
which might have some data for example
let's say sales is one of them you might
have some other data table which might
be for example let's say budget table
or might be something else and these are
your data tables now at the other end
you might have your lookup tables so
basically you have various lookup tables
and these lookup tables for example
let's say this one is customer
this one is territory
let's say this is product
and let's say this one is a calendar
so these are basically my lookup tables
so we can basically as I said your data
might be coming in from different
sources let's say database or let's say
some kind of files or let's say some
kind of systems what you have so your
data might be coming in from different
places now you might want to transform
the data so this is where I could say
there is your query editor which I was
explaining so you have your query editor
which basically allows you to edit the
data table or basically allows you to
edit the data before it is loaded right
you can hide a column you can add a new
column you can modify your column so
your query editors would be basically
used to work on the data which goes into
your data tables now you might have
a lot of lookup tables as I said so
let's say these are my lookup tables
and these are my data tables so what we
need is sometimes we need information
based on our lookup tables and data
tables now that's where data modeling
comes into picture so basically if I
would want to extract information from
here so I can notice that there is a
product key here and there is a product
key here now this is where we are
already talking about say foreign keys
or we are talking about your
relationships right now when you talk
about relational databases you have
something called as foreign key
constraints which is in in power bi
terms I would say it's not exactly a
constraint but it is more of a filter
propagation instead which is used to
basically connect your different data
sources and you could have basically
cross filter directions you can go for
single or one to one or one to many or
many too many kind of relationships
which basically allows you to work on
the data so we will learn more about
data models when we are doing a quick
demo there where we can talk a little
bit about
normalization and denormalization the
way the data exists right and then you
basically would want to gather insights
from your data so when you talk about
your
two data sources as I said so you have a
products lookup table you have a sales
table now if you would want to calculate
the total order quantity of each product
name which is we are talking about the
order quantity as a information here and
you have product name here now how do
you get that information what we see
here is we would want something like
this or we would want more information
so how do we do that so what we can do
is the order quantity for each product
is basically showing us the same value
now this is because the product and
sales tables are not connected and there
is no relationship between them even if
you would want to take two sources and
just get information out of them
probably I would complain that there is
no relationship established between them
so what we do is we create a data model
so what we do is we build a relationship
between both both the tables using a
common key column which exists in both
cases as I said there is a product key
here there is a product key here so that
basically allows us to have a
relationship between these two now that
could be one to one this could also be
related to other tables so it could be
one to many you could have many to one
so all those relationships are possible
so product key is basically used to
create a relationship you see the arrow
Mark and then there is also the star
which can basically mean one to many now
when the product key is used to join
these two tables or from a relationship
then we can look at the product names
and the order quantities which basically
gives me a total now that's the basic
use of your data models now what about
this Dax so basically data analysis
Expressions now that's a library of
functions and operators that can be
combined to build formulas and
expressions in power bi desktop usually
when we work on our data sources when we
would want to connect them it
automatically shows us these data
analysis Expressions however this gives
us extension it basically gives us more
power to work on our data now sometimes
instead of working on Dax or Dax
Expressions it would be good to go for
better data modeling and have the
relationships established better and
sometimes when the relationships are
established you could use your Dax which
basically gives you more power on
working on your data so your values are
calculated based on information from
each row of a table it appends values to
each row in a table and stores them in
the model it increases the file size so
that's what happens now you can right
click on any column to add a new column
and for example in this one it shows
that there was a quantity type
calculated column which was based on the
calculation what we see here on the top
in the in the expression bar which says
what kind of calculation was performed
and that basically gives us the value
for quantity type and that is basically
added here to are existing data
so that's the power of Dax and power bi
so you also have something called as
measures so Dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures so
basically here if you see we are working
on AW underscore sales and then we have
selected quantities sold and what we are
looking at in the report is we can
basically right click on any table name
to add a new measure here so we have
added what we call as quantity sold as
the measure so values are calculated
based on information from any filters in
the report we will see this how this can
be done and that basically here the
measure does not increase the file size
it does not create new data in the table
themselves in comparison to what we were
seeing earlier that is your calculated
columns so these are your type of Dax
functions so Dax allows you to create
new calculated columns and measures so
you have date and time which basically
allows you to work on date and time data
or Fields you have logical functions
which allow us to create new filters or
add more filters to our data you have
text functions which basically allows us
to say transform the data into a lower
case or an upper case or basically get
the length of a string or concatenate
two fields or basically do a filtering
based on some criterias or replacing
some content you also have statistical
functions which can be used you have
information functions which can be used
so these are different types of Dax
functions which we can use in power bi
so we will learn more on power bi
through a quick demo where we can use
some data sets and those data sets could
be found on internet although I can also
upload that on a GitHub link and you
will have access to those data sets so
let's learn about power bi through a
quick demo by uploading some data sets
and playing with those data sets let's
look at a sample data set and let's
upload it
and as I explained while uploading let's
also transform the data so that we can
have selective Fields so selected data
loaded here instead of loading the
complete data set and then let's see how
we can visualize this or how we can use
the information in this data set now
what we can do here is we can click on
get data and then we can choose one of
the data formats which we would be
looking for so for example I can go for
excel and basically
click on this now here are some of my
data sets so let's look into the folder
here and these data sets are also
available on my GitHub link which I'll
share with you later so here we have
something called a super store let's
click on this and here I already have a
data set which is global Superstore or I
also have selective data so let's select
this one click on open
now that's basically connecting to my
data source and that will show me what
does that Excel sheet have so it has
different tabs which is orders people
and returns so let's select orders
and that basically gives me a preview of
the data which I have and if you scroll
all the way to write it shows me city
state and then country and if you see
here we do see information of all the
countries now this can be huge amount of
data which may which we would want look
into but say for example my use case is
that I am interested in looking for the
data for United States and as a country
and all it states so we will do that
when we do a transform now we can also
select the returns Tab and that shows me
these three Fields however the first row
should have been the heading of this
particular data set and we will
transform that now I can go ahead and
click on load but that will load all the
data so instead of that let's go for
transforming so let's click on transform
data now once you do that it brings you
your toolkit that brings you your power
query editor which allows you to
transform your data so for example we
have data from returns tab or return
status source as you see here so we see
column one column two and column three
and that also shows the type of the data
here it also gives me a quick small
option here let's select this and then I
can say use first row as header now
there are various other options which
you can do you can add a custom column
you can add column with examples you can
keep the top rows you can remove the top
rows you can keep errors keep duplicates
so there are different ways and you can
also do a merge query or a pen query so
as of now let's just say use first row
as headers and that basically shows that
now my first row has become the header
you also see in the applied steps it
basically tells me if I have changed the
type of the data if I have made any
other changes those steps will get added
here so it basically shows me the name
as it returns it shows me applied steps
where I have changed the type and now I
basically have this information now this
is something where you can change the
type or you can basically set it to a
particular format however we are not
doing anything of that sort right now so
we can do that for any of these columns
so this looks good when it comes to
orders let's click on this and as I said
and I would be interested in selecting
for country as United States only and
let me just work on that data however we
can work on all the data so let me
scroll all the way to right and here I
have the country now there are these
filters which we can use so basically I
can click on this and that shows me all
the countries are selected now there is
also something called as text filters
which we will see how we can use to
select particular data I basically have
other ways of filtering the data so for
example now I will just uncheck this
select all and what I would be
interested is in United States so let's
type it here that shows me has an option
here select this and then basically say
okay
so that should basically now filter out
and it shows me the data is United
States only and then you have different
states and rest of the data remains so
if you look at the applied steps it
tells me that there are filtered rows
now we have done the basic
transformation for this data set on
these two data sources that is orders
and returns so here you have an option
which says close and apply so close the
query editor window and apply any
pending changes you can click on this
and it says apply so for example I can
just say apply for now and that should
basically apply the changes
which I have performed using my query
editor that is I have transformed the
data so that I can have selective data
uploaded in my power bi now it's showing
that it shows me it is working on both
of these data sources that is orders and
returns so that's done and now basically
if there are any other pending changes
we can just do a close and apply so that
basically has closed and now you would
see the data appearing here so I have
uploaded the data as per my preferences
now if you click on the data tab here so
it basically shows you your data fields
it might take some time to populate but
if you see in the country field now if
even if I click on the filter it just
shows me United States now that's what
we wanted so we have already uploaded
this data in orders you can always
expand the option here which shows me
all the fields which are there in this
might be this is an aggregation might be
that's an ordered date so this is again
some kind of aggregation we can change
the data types so we are looking at all
the fields in my order stable or
basically coming from the orders data
source I also have returns which shows
me three fields and that shows me the
data which is returned order ID and
region so the column names are applied
correctly as we want and that basically
looks fine now we can also look at your
model so when you click on model it
shows me these two however there is no
as of now relationship established
between them so it says under property
select one or more model objects to set
their properties so right now these are
not related there is no relationship
established between them so if I would
want some data which relates to orders
and returns then that would fail because
it would say there is no relationship
now I can go to the first option which
says report and we have not created any
report here although we can create a
simple report we can look at the data so
we have our orders field now we can
basically pull out some information from
here we can choose what kind of report
we may want to create so for example
let's go for the table option from
visualizations you have various options
here which we can use this is where you
can do a formatting this is where you
can select the fields this is where you
can search and filter out the data you
can also add data fields here so first
let's click on table
and that basically gives me a table now
this table as of now does not have
anything so you can use the filter and
slices
option here which will affect the
visualization or basically what you can
do is now since we have orders here so
this is my orders and I would like to
work on this so let's say for example
country is I can select country as a
field and if you say it shows me country
is all as of now and it says the value
is United States what I can also do is
I'm interested in the states so I have
state now I can basically drag and drop
it here and then the state gets added
here so I can basically say select all
and that should basically take care of
my State field being added here so state
is all country is all now we can
basically look at something else so
might be let's choose sales and I can
just drag and drop sales here here so
that basically says if you would want to
have any kind of advanced filtering
which says filter type so go for
advanced filtering is less than or equal
or you can also go for advanced filters
so that's fine as of now so we have
added some Fields here and that's
basically
my data here so let's go for filters
here
which basically should select all my
fields
now if you see the visualization shows
my country sales and state which we had
either by selecting the fields and
dropping them here or you can in this
section where it says field so you can
for example let me show it again so I
can just delete this I can click on the
table option I can just drag it here I
can basically make it bigger and I need
to add data to this one so it says add
data fields here so now let's say
country is what we are interested in we
are also interested in States
so let's drop that here and let's say
sales so this is also what I'm
interested so I'm looking at one
specific country I'm looking at sales
per state and when we look at sales it
basically tells me that this is
summation so you will basically get the
total sales which have happened now we
are looking at this data here we can
always go to formatting we can click on
grid we can basically increase the font
here we can change the grid color so for
example let's make it for example blue
so I can just select this
and it should basically
allow me to have the grid color as blue
now I can go in for the grid thickness I
can go for row padding outline color so
we can basically make it a little bit
more readable and then we can basically
increase the font size here
to look at the information
and you have other options here so what
would you want to do with column headers
so I can basically have the font color
background color is fine do you want to
have an outline do you want to have a
change in font what is the text size
might be we can make the heading a
little bigger and then basically you
also have the field formatting so all
those could be done you could go for
background and all these things can be
done in formatting so now we already
have our data here and this basically
looks good and this is basically one of
my visuals which I have here and this
has given me some information for sales
and basically I can scroll this I can
also make it bigger
so I could select a particular field if
I'm more interested in looking at the
information for a particular State now I
can add more fields to this
so this is my one of the reports which I
have created now what I can do with this
report is I can basically have more data
fields I can add filters to this I can
basically look into all the data here by
just clicking somewhere in the grid but
somewhere outside if you select a
particular row then that data shows up
here you have an option of focus mode
which you can go for you can look at the
other options which says export data now
if this is the data which you are
interested in you can export it you can
always to show as a table if you are
interested in you can do a sort by
country sales or state so for example
let's do a sorting by state
and that basically gives me the data
which has been sorted by state
information now we could obviously have
the information here so I can then
change the order so it shows me
alphabetically this is the information
which I have so I've created a simple
visualization using the data which I
have and what I can do is I can click on
save so that basically asks me to save
this as a power bi file which has an
extension of pbix and I can basically
call it my report so let's say first
report and here I can say country or I
can say state
wise sales in USA
let's say
USA and that basically is my first
report
now
once you have saved this report you can
always look on your machine for example
if I go in here and if I go into this
folder might be I should look on desktop
and this is where I should have saved it
so it shows me first report statewise
that will open up in power bi and we
have created a simple report which we
have basically used by taking our data
now I can also do is I can publish this
if I would want to share this
information so publish this report
online in power bi service you can
basically select
your report what we have here and I
clicked on publish so it says what's the
destination so you can have different
workspaces I will choose the default
that's my workspace I can click on
select now it says publishing first
report Statewide sales in USA to power
bi you can create a portrait view of
your report and you can do all that
stuff so let it publish and then we can
basically look into our power bi server
that's our service where the information
is already shared
or published I would say which can then
be shared with different resources so we
can come here and basically I can look
into the power bi and this is where I
will be able to look into my workspaces
and let's look in my workspace so it
says this is the place where I had
initially downloaded power bi data set
it says your data set is ready let power
bi help you explore your data right so
you can always do this you can click on
view data set
which basically allows you to bring out
your workspace and first report State
why sales now that's the report which we
have published so let's first check in
our desktop if that's done so it says
success open first report in power bi
now I can click on this one straight
away and that takes me to my service now
once it takes me to the service it shows
me the report which we created which we
published and it basically has the
option where I can save it
as a a different copy or give a
different name I can embed this in the
in a website or a portal like in publish
to web
embed this report for Public Access by
anyone on the internet we can do that we
can export it to PowerPoint so we can do
all these options you also have an
option of view where you can change the
view you can basically also edit a
report here so you can do that if you
are interested in something specific
you can do a sharing to teams so if you
have your teams or group set up you can
share it with them you have an option of
common pains you can basically view
usage metrics report now that can be
sometimes helpful you can basically go
ahead and go and subscribe a particular
report so if there are new changes made
you will be the one who will be informed
you can click on share now if I click on
share here from my service it says only
users with power bi Pro will have access
to the support recipients will have the
same access as you unless row level
security on the data set further
restricts them so I can grant access and
this is where I will have to give the
email IDs of the people with a message
that I would want to have them
look at this report
right you can also allow recipients to
build new content using the underlying
data sets and you can send an email
notification to the users as of now I
don't have any other groups so I'll not
be sharing it but I have created a
simple report now let's also look at
edit report let's just to see what it
helps us and when you click on edit
report it basically brings up this one
which says your file view it gives you
the filters it basically
allows you to add data fields to this so
it is basically giving access to these
data sets which were in my desktop
it is basically allowing you to give or
create different visualizations now here
we have the data which we are looking at
and if say for example somebody is
interested in filtering the data so you
could do that so you could click on
filter here and that basically applies
this is the filter we have now country
is fine sales might be I can click on
sales and I would say okay let's look at
sales which is more than a particular
amount so we can say is greater than and
might be I can give a number here so I
can say 30
000.
and basically
I can say apply filter
so right now I'm applying filter and I
would look at the values which also
shows me the total value is changed so
you have not only created a report you
have published it and now
from the service you can edit it so I'm
looking at particular data here and then
basically I can click on file and I can
save it or I can say save a copy of the
report and let's say I will call it the
same name so I'll say first
report underscore
state wise sales and I will say modified
so let's do a save
and the report has been saved
so now you're looking at the data here
so that is basically giving you
information so when I click on my
workspace here
I can click on reports and that does
show me my previous report it shows me
the modified report it gives me an
option of looking at the usage metrics
report so say for example you want to
click on this one and it will basically
give you the usage metrics so let's
click on this one and that basically
shows me the report usage metrics which
is generated so views per day unique
viewers per day you would want to look
at the different platforms who was using
it views by user and this can be
sometimes useful if we would want to
look into this one now I can go back to
my workspace I can click on reports
and that basically took me to usage
metrics I could be sharing it I can
analyze in Excel I can look for quick
insights based on this data what we have
you can basically look at the related
information you can also look at the
settings of this one and basically this
is how you have your data report here
now that also shows me the data sets
option so which basically gives me
the data sets which can be used to
create further reports and we have our
data here
so
for example if I click on create report
it basically gives me these data sets
and we can continue working on this so
this is how I have a simple report
created without basically working on two
different data sources but I have
selected some data here and then I can
basically add details to this so for
example now if we look at orders and say
for example this is the data I have
and say you would want to add some
Fields so let's go to returns and say
for example I would be interested in
looking at the the products so might be
what I should do is I should replace the
report here instead of country it would
be interesting to look at the product
which we have or basically customer ID
so we can look at customer ID we can
look at the order ID which would be
interesting to see if there is a
particular order what was the sales
which was generated and if there were
any returns which were happening on that
so for example here when I have these
let me cut out country as a field and I
will basically take order ID and place
it here so now if you see my data has
been easily modified so I have my order
ID I have sales and I have statewise
information so you have basically all
the information but this is now order ID
State and so on now what if I would want
to also see
based on the order ID if I say I would
want the returned field
so for example I would want to take this
one and let's drag and drop it here now
that says cannot display the visual now
why is that so if you click on see
details that says cannot determine
relationships between the fields so it
cannot display the data because power bi
cannot determine the relationship
between two or more fields and how do we
fix that so for example if I click on
fix this now it says there is a missing
relationship between these fields use
Auto detect to search for relationships
or create them manually now I can click
on auto detect which will try to search
for fields which exist in both the data
sets or basically I can create
relationships so let's click on create
relationships and that basically takes
me to this page which says there are no
relationships defined
from table to table and so on so I can
click on new
now here it says select the tables and
the columns that are related now I can
say orders now those are my Fields where
you have order IDs and it automatically
shows that returns also has an order ID
field although all the values might not
be same but this is how you can create a
relationship and it says the cardinality
says many to one so you can have
basically many to one relationship you
are saying cross filter Direction is
single so make this relationship active
and it has already helped us basically
identifying the field so I can say okay
so it says now these two tables should
be related or should be connected based
on order ID so
here we have this and let's basically
say close
now once that is done if you see
I have order ID I have returned
I have sales column and I have state and
if you see in return I do have a value
of yes which shows this particular order
ID had generated some sales and it was
for state Alabama and it was returned
and the value is yes so if you scroll
down you basically see all the values
now we can add different filters where
we can say I would want only yes and no
now this is again an interesting report
so let's go in also into the formatting
and what we can do is we can look at say
the grid option if we would want to
basically say vertical grid and let's
say
on and it says vertical grid color so
let's select this might be I can try
doing a black here it puts it in the
right nice table format and that
basically looks good so you have sales
returned and so on and this is basically
the order which I am seeing here so for
example if I would want to change the
order and if I'm saying okay I would
like to look at sales and returned and
so on so we can be doing that we can
come here and say for example I have
sales and returned let's try moving the
sales column over here might be state is
uh and information which we would want
in the beginning so let me also move the
states all the way here so it gives me
state it gives me the order ID sales and
if there was a return which was
happening on that particular product so
easily I've modified my report now what
I can do is I can just save it
and I can do the same thing so I can
publish it I can basically continue
using it or I can work on a new report
so let's continue learning and now here
we will also see how you can load some
data and perform some Transformations
and basically get multiple results or
multiple tables or multiple data sets
which can be then further used for
reporting so power bi does give you a
lot of options now here you have an
option as we saw earlier that is get
data or what you can do is you have an
option where you can create new data
also which says enter data now this is
something which can be easily used if
you have relatively less number of
fields so you can basically add more
columns here and you can basically add
values so for example if I would just
call it something like
um scientist ID
okay and then I can say scientist name
and then basically I can say uh domain
and then I can say for example let's say
year of joining and and I can keep
adding the number of columns here I can
delete the columns right and I can give
this and I can say country
so that's it and now we have created
these five countries sorry five columns
which we have given some names and we
can start entering some values so I can
basically say let this scientist ID be
2234 I can give some name so let's give
Peter let's say domain and I can say
biotechnology
I can give year of joining 2011 and I
can say Germany as the country
and I really don't want this particular
column so I can go ahead and delete this
now I can come here and then I can give
something else so I can say this is
scientist ID I can give John let's say
the scientist is mainly working in
physics
and then I can say 2018 and let's say
France
and go back here and let's say
four five six seven and let's say Marie
and let's say she does her research in
uh molecules and let's call it 2001 and
let's say
Italy
okay and you can continue adding data in
this way now you can
say if the data is already here so I can
say for example no I do not want this
particular row
I do not want this particular row
so you can basically keep adding values
here now you can say edit so here we
have to give some name so let's say
scientists
okay and then if you choose edit
it basically brings up your power bi
editor which allows you to work on these
fields if you would want to make some
changes now we can make some changes
here we can see what are the number of
rows we can basically perform any kind
of transactions here so this one
basically tells me what is the data type
so here we see scientist ID and this
clearly tells me this is an integer
however we will not want to do any kind
of computations here so we can as well
change this so I can just do a right
click and I can work on this particular
column what I can also do is I can just
click on this and this tells me that you
would want to change it to date time or
you want to change it to some number so
I can just say string because we are not
going to perform any computation here so
on the ID column so let let's see text
and I'm changing it so it says replace
current add a new Step so selected
column has an existing type conversion
would you like to replace the existing
conversion or preserve the existing so I
will say replace current and now the
data type has been changed it is of a
string and if you see this step has got
added here so it says that the change
type
is the kind of transformation we did
here so that's fine now what we can also
do is we have the scientist name but we
don't like the column name here so it
would be good to change this
so there is something called as remove
or remove columns and so on so when you
do a right click it gives you a lot of
options in applying filters or doing
some transformation if I just click on
this one so what I can do is I can look
at the date time
and let's go here so we have an option
which says do you want to change the
type now we could have done that here or
like I said you could choose the time
and do it you can just say transform and
how do you want to change it so do you
want to change it to uppercase well you
can do that and changes all the values
of this one
what I can do is I can again do a right
click and I can choose basically if you
would want to clean up the data or if
you would want to convert to lowercase
you want to capitalize each word so
let's choose that and if you see here
the steps are getting added now to undo
any particular step if I just cancel
this then I'm back to this if I cancel
this I'm back to my original form so you
can anytime undo your changes and you
can basically work on this so we are
working on this particular column now
there are various other options that you
can look at so for example these are
this is some of my data but it does not
have much information it would be good
to load some bigger data set and then
use these Transformations or basically
working on changing the data types as I
mentioned or if you would want to do a
filtering and remove certain fields and
only select particular Fields if that's
what you're interested doing a right
click where I want to create a copy of
this and then basically I can
use that particular copy now what I can
also do is I can add column from
examples I can duplicate column and then
I can make some changes to that so this
is my duplicate column and say for
example you would want
this one to be changed so we can say
remove duplicates we can basically if
you are doing some kind of change you
want to change the format here you can
do that you can use for other things
like filling up and all that now I can
just call it rename and let's say
um Alias scientist name right and I can
continue adding columns or I can do some
Transformations and once you have done
with these transactions now this one if
you see it shows as integer but is it an
integer no this is an date format so I
can go for modeling and change the
formats what I can also do is I can
select this and it says it's not a
decimal it's not a fixed decimal it is
date time it is date it is date time and
time zone
right and you can select any one of
these so for example let's make it date
which makes it more meaningful but then
what happens is when you do this it is
going for the default dates or the older
dates so I don't like that so what we
will have to do is we will have to
basically transform this and here we
have transform you have change type so
you have date and time you have date you
have time so let's choose date and time
and if you see here it gives me some
default timing based on these values
which we do not like so again filter it
out but what we can do is we can just
make sure that this is changed or you
want to make it a string because we are
not going to do any computation here so
I can keep it as date but then if I have
more Fields like month and days and so
on then you can do that so here it also
has
the option so when you have selected
this you have an option called transform
and transpose sorry transform also has
various options which allow you to work
on these do you want to do some
scientific calculations do you want to
work on the date field so as of now it
is just integer so we can use one of
these we can do a group by but obviously
we don't have much data here so as of
now let us retain this I can just change
this to text and that's okay because we
are going to look at this later we can
add more data and work on it so as of
now once we have done all these changes
you can go back to say home and here you
have close and apply and I can basically
say close and apply so the changes will
be applied and then my new table which
we just created by entering some random
data performing some basic
transformations
will be available so if you look into
this one
so that's where my data is it shows me
the columns but there is no aggregated
column as such here you don't see any
summation Mark you just see the field
names or the column names you see the
values now obviously if you go into
modeling there is no
or there is no existence of a different
table which you can join these tables or
you can perform some transactions come
back to the data set so this looks good
and we have it here now obviously we
have not created any visualization based
on this which we can and we can continue
working on it so here this is my data
set which is a small table where we have
created some data and we can use it
anytime now let's work on a bigger data
set and see what kind of Transformations
we can do we can then also see on
modeling or basically using some smarter
ways of working with the data
so what we would want to do is we would
want to load some data here so let's go
into
sorry let's go into home let's go to get
data let's use our old store data and
I'm going to take the global Superstore
which is huge data set with all the
countries and the products and the sales
which have happened and we can take this
data but before loading it as I
suggested earlier we should basically
transform the data we should basically
transform the data so that you don't end
up loading everything and you don't work
on all the data I mean unless you really
want to so here I will this Excel sheet
which I'm talking about has two
different tabs we have used it before so
let's use orders let's use returns and
that basically shows me the data what we
have so I can do a load but that's not
what we would want to do so you can do a
load and you can get all the data but
let's go to transform
make some basic Transformations before
we load the data so our power bi editor
allows us to work on this now here we
have
it says this preview may be up to nine
days old so I can do a refresh I can
select this and I say first thing is use
first row as header because that's what
I want so it is basically setting the
first row as header which looks good and
we have some order IDs we have the
returned If the product was returned so
let's look at the filter here so it just
has yes values which we are looking at
so
it says list may be incomplete let's say
load more
and let's see what are the filters here
so either there might be a product which
is returned or it might be blank field
so that is chosen so that's fine we have
order ID we have region which is
basically showing me different regions
here let's look at orders and orders is
again having your row ID order ID order
date ship date ship mode so you have
quite large amount of data here for your
different countries now in earlier
example I chose United States and then I
was only focusing on the states and city
in United States so we can do that now
I can basically work on refresh so
whatever preview was stored in the
memory we are just refreshing it now
here we have this row ID and if you see
the row ID is an integer obviously we
will not be performing any kind of
computation here so here
you don't have any row ID but here we
have row ID so let's make it uh from
integer let's make it string and I'll
say replace current so that's that looks
fine it's a row ID which we will use to
search but we are not going to perform
any computations unless you want to find
on an average on row ID or anything else
now you have order IDs so what we can do
is we can filter some values
we can rename the field as we desired
right so for example let's go in here
and what we can do is let's go into
a customer ID ship
okay and here you have say State you
have region
okay now at any point of time if I would
want to filter out the values the easier
option is that you can select on this
one and here you can do some text
filtering okay or you can basically
select the values from here so for
example if I say let's get rid of select
all what we will be interested in say
United States and UK that's the data we
want and then I can basically say okay
so it is basically going to filter out
the data which is for United States and
UK as of now now what we can also do is
how about doing some more filtering
before we basically work on this so
let's go in here and we are looking at
United States and UK related data and
let's look at
it is sometimes good that you can
basically
uh work on the data here so for example
I go into orders now what I would want
to do is I would want to look at
the fields okay and we want to we have
not yet loaded the data so if you look
in the background I just have my
scientists because we have not applied
these changes we have not loaded we are
still in the transformation stage right
now what we can do is let's go for so we
can do segment and all these kind of
fields
can be used for grouping the data so we
will see that whenever you have a data
set you would already know there are
certain fields which have repeated
values which can be used to group the
data and we can do that we can change
any kind of values which are not
going to be computed on so for example I
have postal code I can use this but
again we are not going to find a postal
code which is greater than something
right so integer is not the valid type
let's change it to text okay and if for
example I would want to look at this so
I have done some
changes here
okay and this shows me null so for
example let me just revert this back and
let's make it
a whole number
okay so there are certain columns or
rows which do not have some values and
we can basically get rid of those values
so as of now we can do a filtering here
so let's keep the postal code AS integer
or let's
change it to text do a replace
content and now what we will do is we'll
scroll all the way right might be I'm
interested in technology category so
that's what I'm interested in so what I
can do is here I can do some filtering
so I can basically choose
technology now the easier way would be
since these are categories and there are
only three categories we really don't
want to go and apply text filters here
but if you had something like an office
supply and Office Inventory then you
could have done some text filters so
let's not do some text filtering here
what we can do is I would be interested
in technology so that's the field I'm
interested in so now you are only having
data which is related to technology
okay and you have some product names so
this is where we want to do some kind of
filtering so
we can rename the field we can select
some Fields so let's for example let's
go for
um
any of the field which I think might
have more entries here so for example
let's go for
Canon Wireless or Canon Image right so
let's go for product names and I will
say let's
go here
now I could have done a transformation
but that's not what we want we want to
do some filtering so let's go to text
filter and here I can say begins with I
can say ends with I can say contains so
let's go for contains
and it says enter the value here so you
would want to keep the rows where the
product name contains something and it
gives you some suggestion
right so where you are seeing in some
values here so for example if I would
have selected this then it applies the
complete thing but that's not what I
want so I will get rid of all this and I
will say it contains Canon now I can go
for advanced filtering also okay wherein
you can select Advanced and then you can
give different columns and
what do they contain
what kind of values you are looking for
so you can do that but we will not go
for advanced in one step let's go for
basic and let's say okay
and now I should get all the products
which are Canon and you have different
products so this is one kind of
filtering I've done it tells me what is
the category of this it is machines it
is copiers it is obviously belonging to
the technology category we are looking
at uh the market which is for this
particular data when you look at the
country we are still focusing on United
States and United Kingdom that kind of
data right so we have filtered the data
we have done some uh selection based on
the data here and what I can do is I can
then
basically rename a particular field so I
can do that I can say I'm interested in
uh
um sales which is the data here we can
basically look into the quantity so
sales is something which we are
interested in but might be we are
interested in sales which are more than
a particular value I'm not interested in
lower amount of sales I would want to
look into United States and UK data but
I am interested in sales or I am looking
at if the discount percentage was
something or if the profit was more
right so we can apply different kind of
values here but what we can do is with
these changes because you don't want to
transform and make changes all here you
want to make the changes once the data
set is uploaded so we have selected some
data we have create done some
Transformations we can basically break a
particular column into multiple columns
if that's what we want if we see that we
will do an aggregation based on year or
we will do a aggregation based on the
country or year and Order ID right so we
can break this data into multiple
columns so we can do that but for now
let's do a close and apply
and
let's apply this so that's going to
apply all these changes it's going to
load my data but remember now we are
having selective or selected data which
gets loaded so that should get be
available here so it takes time
sometimes so you have to wait and then
you can go ahead and check here so for
example now I'm looking in tables let's
basically minimize this let's go for
orders and this is the data I have which
obviously row ID if you see so you have
all the row IDs and again again you can
do filtering here but this is where you
have already loaded the data the data is
available and then you can start working
on the columns here so we have this if
you closely see we see this summation
Mark and this basically means that these
are my aggregated columns or these
values are measures which can be used
for calculations so we can see that we
can create on our own aggregations so we
can do that we can rename the field as
we have seen
we can filter out the data so we have
all the fields showing up from orders
and let's also look at the returns
which basically has the columns the
order ID and your region so it basically
shows the region here where was the
product returned from and we have this
information so what we are doing is we
when we were doing a text filter in the
previous example
remember it was case sensitive okay and
you have to take care of when you're
doing a text filter you have to give a
field which exactly matches as it exists
in the content now okay this is the data
we have and let's look at the order
column right now what we can do is we
can do some quick Transformations here
and we can basically look for
more data here so
let's say we have uh some filtering to
be done now I can do a filtering based
on my
uh products
so we had all these products but now
let's do a filtering on product and then
products you have copiers you have
machines so you have mainly two
categories right and when you look at
machines it basically talks about your
PC
uh something so let's look for machines
and here we have basically The copier
fields which are more
so I can basically
go for filtering here
and that's the data we have so we don't
want to really unselect any of these
here but what I'm doing is I'm saying
text filter and let's go into this one
now and let's say contains
okay so I'm saying contains and then I
can basically say let's say copier
now that's what I'm interested in
and
show rows where product name contains
copier
okay now you can give a and condition
here so if you would want a specific
copier if you are interested in okay
let's also say uh contains and let's go
for laser also
laser and let's say okay
so you see the data gets filtered out
here and we have the sales which we are
seeing here so let's go to sales and we
will be interested in anything above 500
so let's go to sales
let's go for number filters let's say
greater than
and I will say for example 500 oh sorry
okay and
let's say okay so that basically filters
out the data and then I am also
interested in quantity Where I would
want the quantity to be
more than one or more than two so for
example so let's go in
here and you can basically choose what
is the filter you want so you can apply
any number of filters now you have the
filtering here you can always click on
the filter and if you want you can just
do a clear filter and the filtering will
be gone so you have all the data right
and
this is the particular data we have and
here I have say for example
product name now I can keep the filter
because I am interested only in these
values or I can filter out so this tells
me that when we did a and it is
basically going for laser and copier
right so let's say for example clear all
filters the thing is gone what we can do
is let's go here go for text filters say
contains and here I will say it can be a
copier okay or
so last time we did an end and I'll do
it contains laser
so
let's choose this that gives me more
entries so either the product name has
copier or it has laser it has the
quantity it has the product name and we
have all this detail here now what we
can also do is we can do some
transformation on the product ID so for
example you have product ID or order ID
so order ID shows up as looks like the
country name uh the year and then the
order ID so we can basically split it up
so I can select this and here I have
option of
let's go to home so when you have you
have selected this column so you have an
option of transform data here so use the
power query Editor to connect prepare
and transform the data so if you really
want to transform the data here if I
basically select this
if I just right click here
now here it just tells me do you want a
new column do you want to create a copy
of this column okay you want to create
copy table so this is your transformed
data what you have and for example let's
create a copy table
and let's come in here
so you should be able to see your
copy table now so let's go in
and select this one
and what you need to do here is creating
a copy of this or copy table would not
be the right option what we can do is we
can work on transforming this rather
than doing it from here so you have this
option of adding a new column going for
a new measure renaming it right so
that's okay but what we can do is Select
this particular column let's do a home
and first thing is let's go to transform
so I want to transform the data now
let's select this one and it brings up
your power editor again here we were
interested in orders so we are looking
at our data here
now if you see my country's United
States and UK so you can confirm that if
you look at category it is technology
product name has copier and Laser as we
selected so those things are retained so
you have not lost any changes as of now
so this order ID column what we have now
as I said you can be doing a filtering
okay you can select this particular
column and then you have other things
which can be used to transform here like
you want to change the data type you
want to use first row as header you want
to replace some values okay you want to
run some merge queries you want to do
some analytics so all these options are
here now what we can do is while this
column is selected I can do it right
click now there is an option called
transform which is basically going to
help me in changing the data here okay
now I can basically duplicate the column
so I really don't want to work on this
column itself but it would be good to
have
a duplicate column on which we can work
on so I can do a split column here if I
would want to but let's create a
duplicate column so let's say duplicate
column
now that gives me a duplicate column so
we can rename it later so now I will not
work on my original column but I'll work
on a duplicate column and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to basically
transform or split this so again where I
click now you have a split by so we can
say split by by delimiter or by number
or by characters or by position so by
lowercase and upper case so you can do
all of this so let's go for by delimiter
now if you see it basically identifies
the delimiter which is hyphen or Dash
now you can go for split at left most
identify right sorry left most delimiter
right most each occurrence of delimiter
and that's what we want to do you can
look into advanced options where it says
split into columns
so do you want to split that into
columns do you want to split that into
rows because that's more or less like
doing a group by and you can say number
of columns to split into so we have here
one two three four values so that looks
good to me and let's do say for example
if I choose three
so eigen joules 3 and then split using
special characters so you could do that
so let's for example let's say okay
and let's look at the data how it looks
like we can anytime delete the data we
can keep it the way we want right so
what we did was
we created a copy of the column then we
did a split
and what we have seen is we just have
three columns now if you see the fourth
bit is gone fourth bit doesn't show up
right because I just did a 3 as the
resulting column so I have the order ID
okay and we can check if there is
already an order ID column so we have
order ID but that has the complete order
ID year and the relatively product ID so
you can see the customer ID you can look
at this one so it basically has your
order ID and then let's look at the
fields here so we have the product ID
which says t e c m a I'm looking at the
first one three seven zero zero and
that has in no relation to the order ID
right so we can make sure that there is
nothing which is conflicting with our
entries now once that is done so we have
order ID which can be used to categorize
the data you have order ID which is
basically the year okay and you have
order ID which is basically having some
more value now I can keep this data as I
want so I can basically click on this I
can go for renaming and I can say let's
say let's call it
order
ID
and let's say
IDs so let us in case there is a
particular column and you would want to
look at so
just give the name correctly now order
IDs is find so here we will also rename
this one so let's call it
uh order
here
and that's going to be ordered here so
we can again change this to string okay
and here you have the order ID so let's
rename this one
and I have my
let's call order
number
right so we have we are seeing all the
steps which we have added here we just
split the data based on the delimiter
and we have now three new columns which
have got added to our existing data
which was already filtered and we have
done some
splitting up of data by creating a
duplicate and then renaming it right so
if you
go and look at your Transformations now
if I would have done a split here
straight away then my original column
would be gone but probably we want the
original column because sometimes you
may want to search order ID with a
Consolidated information sometimes you
may want to segregate it based on ear
right now we have the ear field or order
date field here you have the ship date
right but then might be you want to just
aggregate based on air you don't want to
really spend time in aggregating or
extracting the month and day and so on
so my these three columns can be useful
now what I can also do is I can merge
The Columns if I want so we have split
the columns but what I can do is I can
say select select select
so using your control and now do a right
click so you should have an option
called merge columns right now this is
something which is we would want to
merge so let's say merge columns and
let's say do you want to keep a
separator so yes I want to keep a
separator but might be this time I will
give my separator is a uh colon and then
what is the merge column name you want
to create so let's call it something
like
um
order
okay
uh year and then let's call it num right
so sometimes renaming the fields to a
name which makes more sense or based on
your naming convention is good so let's
do a merge and now what I have done is I
have done merging of those columns so
I split the data I merge The Columns and
now if you see my
The Columns which I had created those
columns are gone because you did a merge
you did a merge and now you have the
fields which are either
uh earlier you had
something which is separated by a
hyphen and here you have something which
is separated by colon right now anytime
if you want you can
unmerge this by removing the step right
and you can get rid of this merge column
so if for example I would do that
so
I have my data back right I have my data
back so what we could have done is we
can select this
okay and then what we can do is like
what we did earlier so you can
basically go for
removing the columns okay you can do a
merge column okay you can select one by
one and create duplicate of those and
then you can merge them right so all the
possible options are there so you can
the best option would be to create a
duplicate of these columns and then
basically merge them as per your
convenience so maybe you can say order
IDs and order number is the pairing what
you want here is something which you
don't want right because we already have
the date field so I can basically say
remove
foreign
and this one is gone now I will select
this and this and let's go for merge
columns and I want to give a separator
which is
might be without the ear and you have
space or you can go for custom like
earlier we had give a symbol and then
what do you want to call it so let's say
order
specs
okay
right so this makes more meanings
because we already have the date field
so why do I want the year into my order
ID so I can always be doing a
segregation now based on order specs
right now this is some simple
Transformations what we are doing here
we are seeing the data which we have
okay now what I can do is I can
basically first apply these changes
so that all my changes what I have done
are applied right now once these changes
are done we can basically go ahead and
save this file so I can just say save I
can go for save as I have different
other options so
if you would want to perform keep
performing your transformation then you
can just do this you can add a column
you can view the data so for now our
Transformations are good enough and what
we can do is we can basically
go back to home we can do a close and
apply and we will be back to
our data set which has been modified so
we can see if the data what we have has
been transformed
so we have ordered specs here that's
good we did not do any filtering or
we have the filter left here which
basically tells me that there are these
different fields we have not removed
them but what we are doing is we are
just applying a filter to choose copiers
and Laser Printers
so that's what we have here and this is
good enough now what I can do is once
this is done I can basically save it
so I would want to call it some kind of
report if you would want to create okay
so let's call it
as uh
let's say second
report
and here I will say
country
and Technology
specific info
let's save it
and now basically I have saved my data
so what you can do is you can go for
creating other report or basically
having this information published if
that's what you want to do if you want
to go for visualization because right
now what we are seeing is we have a lot
of data here we have a lot of data here
it shows me there are these
tables or data sets which we have worked
on that shows me
here in the models but there is no
relationship with them if you're going
to visualization then you don't have any
option or you have not created any
visualizations based on this data but if
you go here now based on the data what
we transformed if you see we have order
specs
right now that's what we chose we
basically have other fields so you have
ship date you have aggregated columns
which can be used for visualizing and we
can work on this so I can come back here
and what I would be interested in is
this data set is fine but I want to do
some grouping I want to basically have
some selective data in this and for that
what I can do is let's go for ship mode
now this is something what we have so we
are in this data field
now we have this transform so let's go
back to transform again
and let's choose our orders so that's
the data we have and now if you see here
this is
you know huge amount of data what we
want is we want to group them based on
the shipping mode
so here you have an option called Group
by so I can select this I can go in here
I can basically work on okay get rid of
duplicate values but that's not what we
want to do you want to do a group by so
as I said you can do a group by from
here or you can choose from the
transform option above and you can do a
group by so let's do a group by
now
how do you want to group the data so I'm
saying I want to group the data here
based on shipping mode
or
which is the other column you want to
use to do a group by so let's go for
shipping mode and what is the new column
name right so we want to basically find
out
that you want to go for ship mode but
that's not enough I mean I can do a ship
mode and I can do a grouping by but you
want to just count the rows no that's
not what we want to do so let's go to
Advanced so ship mode is fine so that's
your grouping right but then what we
also want to do is we want to do a
grouping based on
say sales so here for example let's go
for sales
okay and what should we call this so
maybe we can say uh shipment
wise sales whatever you would want to
call so you can basically get the
operation do you want to really count
the rows no we want to basically do a
summing or we want to might be find out
an average price right so let's do a sum
okay and here I would want to do a
summing based on
say for example sales so this is what
I'm going to use for getting a count of
the sales now grouping by might be we
will change this instead of uh
instead of sales we are using a ship
mode what we can also do is let's go for
a segment
and that would be valid grouping so it
will take a combination of ship mode
segmenting group the data based on that
and then get me the sales which is
which is basically let's call it
shipment wise sales
so it gets a sum so let's do a okay
and that's my more relevant data which
I'm looking at so I'm looking at the
ship mode I'm looking at what is the
segment and then I'm looking at what is
the total sales there I'm looking at
again the ship mode standard and home
office so always remember when you are
choosing multiple fields or multiple
columns for grouping by you are
basically having
a combination of two Fields so that has
to be unique and your grouping is done
based on that so now you are looking at
the sales wise and this is something as
an important information what we have so
we have done some transformation and
what you can do is
you can use other ways like you can use
pivot to get individual values from it
you can run on merge queries which is
basically running some merge queries and
merge the query with another query in
this workbook if you have so you can go
for this now I can basically go for
apply and close so just to add to the
group by step what we did was if you see
here I have removed the group by filter
which we just did couple of minutes back
and what I have done is instead of
transforming your complete data set you
can basically create a copy of it so for
example I can just do a copy and then I
can come here and do a paste and I have
done that and I'm calling it order
summarized but this is my complete data
now what we will do here is we will
basically go ahead and do a grouping by
again like what we did earlier based on
your shipment based on your segment and
based on the sales so that's what we are
looking for so let's go for the ship
mode and
we go for group by
and here you would want to go for
advanced the ship mode and this one I
will go for Segment so that's fine now
we want the new column name so let's say
shipment
wise sales
so I want to do a summing not the
counting of rows and I want to do a
summation based on sales like what we
did earlier and then you say okay
and that basically gives you the data
here now
what we have is we have the resultant
data based on the data which is coming
in from here we did the same thing just
one minute back but we worked on the
original data set so what I did was I
created a copy and now I'm working on
this one so I'll say close and apply
and now we are back to our desktop so it
is applying these changes where we have
done some Transformations we have done
some grouping by and what we can do is
once we have the data here we get
anytime look at our data sets or tables
so this is my original one if you see
now I have order summarized I can just
pull out this information I basically
have my returns which we have not really
touched and we have the scientists so we
have all the four data sets here now
what we can also do is let's look into
order summarized and we just have this
data here so this is fine and you can
continue working on this you can
basically
merge columns from two different data
sets and then you can get the merged
column
and you can rename it so you can
obviously do that you can basically do a
uncheck
whenever you are working on these data
sets so what you can do is
if you would want to work on
transforming for example let's go back
here
and say I want to do some transformation
on it so how did we do it we just did a
transform
and you can go back to transform so you
have this data here and
the data what you have you might be
interested in transforming this into
something else and then
you don't want to maybe load this data
so you have this option where you are
selecting orders and then you have
something called as enable load which
can be unchecked so when you do a
uncheck what will happen is whatever
changes you perform only those changes
related data set will be loaded and they
will still be available but this will
not affect your
it will not affect your original one so
for example let's say cop p and let's go
in here I will do a paste let's say
orders
oh I did a paste I need to
rename this
so let's do renaming let's say orders
and here I will say summarized
and I will say us
so I'm renaming it now let that get
loaded we can perform some
Transformations on it so I have here
where's my country so let's look for
country
yeah and let's look for Country so here
I will go for only United States
okay that's what I'm interested in and
then I can choose well I am interested
in just Central us so I can basically go
for just the central U.S and I can get
rid of all of these
so now I should have only Central us
data and this is fine and this is the
data might be we are focusing on right
now for doing some visualization might
be looking at sales might be looking at
the product name so you have the product
name now remember you don't see any
filters here right because the filters
are coming from the resultant set and
your transformation so if you have any
filters you would be seeing in the top
row now this is the data we have let's
uh let's not restrict it to region
region would then reduce my data but
that's good enough for us I can just say
no I'm clearing off this filter I'm
still looking at United States but I
want to look at all the regions yeah
whatever we would be interested in
category and that's anyways chosen as
technology which we had chosen when we
were loading the data we have copies and
machines right and we can basically keep
this now this is fine I can apply the
changes
I can apply the changes based on this
one
and what I can do is I can just say for
now apply
so that's going to apply all the changes
which you have done in orders or summary
or the new one right and what I can do
is now I can choose order and I can say
don't enable this in load
so it says disabling load will remove
the table from the report and any
visuals that use its columns will be
broken we are not creating any visuals
as of now the table will be removed so
that's fine
and now I will say close and apply
so what happens is you are loading the
data based on the changes okay now you
have your
order summarized you have returns you
have scientists but you basically do not
have orders anymore so that was not
loaded so I only have this one I only
have this one and
you have returns you have scientists you
don't have the orders column right now
that particular data set was not loaded
at all because we did not choose that to
be loaded right now while I'm in this
orders which is
let's see here and actually you can drag
in yeah so you have order summary and
this has basically kind of data which
I'm looking for so I really don't need
the orders table so you can do it in
steps and you can aggregate this you can
have aggregated data you can have all
the data which is filtered transformed
grouped by and then basically just load
it and the original data set which you
used that's no more being loaded here
now at any point of time if I really
want
I can go back to transform data and
remember it is still here it is still
here it's not gone right so you can
basically select this and you can say
enable load and you will have the data
back which you can continue working on
right so these are some quick
Transformations which really help us in
working on the data now obviously if you
have data you want to perform some left
joins right joins you have inner joints
outer joints so you can always do that
you can take two different data sets
might be I'm interested in taking the
orders summarized which talks about
standard class consumer shipment wise
sales and here if I look at order
summary I have other details but the
thing is we need to make sure that these
have the values
these have the values say for example
the segment column here and the segment
column here can really be used to join
these two tables so if I create a
relationship or if I create a join I can
basically merge the data so this is how
you work on data we will also see some
more examples on might be modeling the
data using some Expressions to work on
the data so we already looked at
creating a report
selecting particular fields and then
publishing the report onto your power bi
service now this is the report which we
had created which says State order ID
sales and then I also added this
returned field and that was basically by
creating a relationship between order
and returns which we can also have a
look in model so this is the
relationship which is created if you
just place your cursor here it tells me
that we have a relationship between
order ID of returns and Order ID of
orders and that basically allows me to
join the data bring it in my one report
now this is basically your data sources
you can look at and if you click on your
visualization so that shows you your
report now what we can also do is we can
make it interesting now we would not
want to scroll through the fields to see
wherever or what was the order or what
was the order I ID which was returned
now I can do a sorting I can filter out
what I can also do is I can use this
option which shows slicer here and that
basically allows me to work with this
data so we have this report here and
basically as I said you can click in
here it shows the data now what I can do
is I would want to filter out
information or slice the information
using your returned either being yes or
having a field which has no value how do
we do that so basically I can drag and
drop the returned
here as a field which comes from returns
now that basically shows me only the
value as yes but I do know that there is
there are some fields which are blank
now how do I add filter to this so I can
click on this one and then I can click
on slicer now once that does so it
basically pulls out all the different
values so you have either yes or you
have the blank field for returned so
what we can do is we can select yes you
will see only
the orders and their IDs and sales where
the products were returned so that gives
me hundred eight thousand one one eight
and I can select blank so that will
basically get me all the orders or
products which were not returned now
this is a simple way wherein I can add a
filter to or a slicer to my report to
basically give viewers a choice of uh
selecting different fields and you can
add any number of slicers you can
basically say I would want particular
kind of information so for example if I
go into orders and we know we have the
state now I do have the state
information here and basically I can if
I would be interested I could filter
this out in my report itself I can sort
it I can look it in a different order
what I can also do is how about bringing
in state here and basically dragging it
here so that gives me the state option
it is giving me a visual which is
basically giving me a geographic
location of all these points so yes that
can be good what I can also do is I can
keep this which basically shows me the
state map might be it can be useful you
can zoom in you can zoom out you can
look at specific information here you
can drag and drop here so that's fine
what I can also do is I can again take
the state and bring it here
and that basically can be instead of my
map I can go for slicer so that gives me
all the values here and which basically
allows users to choose the fields or the
states which you would be interested in
looking at so for example if somebody is
interested in looking at the data for
Georgia just select this one and you see
the map automatically shows you where in
the map that's the place and it shows me
all the sales for Georgia State now I
can also basically select yes and that
shows me which were the orders which
were basically returned so that gives me
a quick overview of statewise what is
the geographical location if the orders
were returned or maybe I can just click
on blank and it shows me the
non-returned orders I can again go here
and uncheck the Georgie option and that
shows me all the states now once you
have done this this looks like a
comprehensive report which can be useful
for the viewers for your management team
and so on so we can just do a save and
that basically is saving my report so I
have this report now what if I publish
this report so I can just do a publish
and when I publish it says okay
workspace so let's say select
and then it says replacing this data set
may impact two reports you already have
a data set named by this one view the
impact I would say replace or I will say
view impact so that basically takes me
to the power bi service because
sometimes we may have some reports which
we have already uploaded and updating an
existing report might basically affect
my existing report so it basically shows
me the impact analysis it shows me one
workspace there are two reports they are
they have not been added to dashboard
but these are the ones which will get
modified so let's for example as of now
go ahead here and let's look into my
power bi so go back to your desktop and
I'll say no I don't want to replace so
click on cancel so I do not want to
publish it or it might be what I can do
is I can try saving it as a different
report so let's say save as
and now I will basically say
additional
filters
okay let's save it
so now you see the name on the top
changes to additional filters and now
it's saved to publish this and now I can
go ahead and publish it select your
workspace
and basically it says this is the report
being published with our additional
filters with a map which gives a
geographical uh area showing us the
information and then basically what I
can do is once it is done I can look
into my power bi service like we did
earlier you can do a filtering we can
basically query this data we can share
it with other users who might be
interested in looking at this particular
data now this says it is done so it says
get quick insights and maybe it's a good
an option to look into what kind of
insights it's it gives you so click on
that see the beauty of power bi where it
tries to search for any kind of insights
which it can gather from the kind of
report which you have built
now once the insights are ready it will
let you know what we can also do is we
can come in here click on
view data set
so you see now it shows your additional
filters and here you have option where
it should be showing your report so
let's say View and view is fine so
and if it doesn't show up sometimes it
might breaking taking time for
refreshing so you can always go here and
then you can click on your report
and that should get populated
so this is the report these are the
filters which I have gives me an option
of choosing all the states and basically
allows me to edit the report and look at
all the information here meanwhile we
can see here it is still trying to
gather some insights from the data and
now you see there are some insights here
so it says sales which is coming up and
a subset of your data was analyzed and
the following insights were found so
you're looking at sales by ship mode so
it says standard class second class
first class and same day so there were
different shipping modes in our data and
that's what it shows me the sales which
one had the majority it shows me the
profit so which city or state had more
profit so New York City has noticeable
more profits here average by shipping
cost by sub categories so there are
these different subcategories which we
can look at such as copiers and machines
have noticeably more shipping cost
profit by product name
and you can basically look at the row ID
and quantity so this is where you're
looking at a regression analysis you're
looking at row ID and quantity so there
is a correlation between row ID and
quantity so these are two different
variables or fields which are related
you're looking row ID by category
row ID so it says California has
noticeably more row IDs sales your
profit count of region and count of
returns so there is a correlation again
between two different variables average
of shipping costs now we would have
taken a lot of time building all these
visualizations but Power bi has already
helped you in gathering all these
insights and then you can basically
select which one of these is what you
are interested in you can focus and look
for more information based on all the
fields it has given you good amount of
insights which will help anyone who is
looking at this particular report so
that's your quick insights here and we
have this information
now once you have this information this
is basically where you have your focus
mode so it says subset of your data was
analyzed following insights were found
you can
basically say download
and here you have other options which
allow you to work with your power bi so
let's look at this one so this is where
we have our report and we can continue
exploring it more
one more interesting feature which power
bi has other than having your insights
ready to use which is basically in your
workspace and you can basically use
these insights what we are looking at
various options here
and basically you have this option where
it says spin the visual if you are
interested in a particular Insight you
can always pin it which you can always
go back and look into what you can also
do is you can also click on edit report
here now that's a report which has
already been published
to your power bi service not yet shared
but that can be shared or that can be
subscribed now once you click on edit
report it has option of reading View
mobile layout you have basically an
option which says basically options for
navigating through the data set you can
go for how visuals on the canvas
interact with each other
you have all these options and one of
the good options is ask a question so
you can always click on ask a question
and that basically says
some suggestions now you can open this
and it says okay ask a question about
your data try one of these to get
started what is the average sale sort
orders by order date sort orders by
product ID how many ship modes are there
compare quantity and discount so do not
worry that your report has
only four Fields so it has State order
ID sales and returned with some filters
but what about you looking at how many
ship modes are there so it is already
looking at your data so if you click on
this one here and you can see what are
the different fields what we have and
you have ship date and ship mode so this
is one of the fields which it is showing
you to ask a question now what you can
do is you can say how many ship modes
are there let's click on that let's ask
this question it says four ship modes
and do you want to add this to report
yes you can you can let it be as it is
so you can basically keep this question
here and here you have an option the
visual is showing number of ship modes
when you place your cursor here if you
see here turn this q a result into a
standard Visual and let's do that and
basically it is saying number of ship
modes
right so now that's the power of your bi
power bi which has basically allowed you
to ask a question and quickly add a
visual to your report now what we can do
is we can basically save this or you can
say save as and give any different name
so might be I'll just say save because I
would want to have this information and
the report is saved so in this way you
can basically not only create smart
visuals you can not only relate
different data sources using data models
or relationships you can add maps you
can add filters you can add quick
questions you can basically just go here
and say for example you would want to
ask a different question now we see the
fields here how about looking at the
shipping cost right so here I can say
[Music]
um
but what is the
highest shipping
cost and that shows me some suggestions
let's select that and that shows me the
value
which is great and I can keep it as it
is I can basically convert this to a
visual I may want to keep the question
because might be this question was asked
and you would want to see the result
here might be you can move this
somewhere here
and that gives me some kind of question
which was asked and we can do a save
and that's my report which has been
saved in my bi service the data set is
still there you can basically go ahead
and share this
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
um let's take a look at some of the
benefits of Tableau as your business
intelligence tool so why would we use
Tableau it can be connected to 40
different data sources the more data
sources it can connect to it means that
you are more likely to get direct access
to your data it can build interactive
dashboards with just a few clicks which
can help you quickly understand your
data and it lets you see your outliers
there's also simple analytics build
right into Tableau such as Trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level Tableau has
been a leader in the Gartner magic
quadrant for the last six years and that
includes 2018. here we will take a look
at an overview of the products offered
by Tableau so we have Tableau desktop
which is where you do all of your
development this is where you connect to
and build visualizations and dashboards
today we'll be using Tableau public
which is a free version of Tableau
desktop but with some limitations such
as having no R integration and it can
only support up to a million in rows of
data also any data published here is
made public so you can't use this for
private company information then there's
a new tool called Tableau prep where you
can prepare your data by seeing it
visually before you connect and build
reports there's also Tableau online
which is a cloud hosted version of
Tableau server a place where you can
publish your dashboards and it enables
you to share your dashboards in a secure
way Tableau server has an option to be
on premises so let's just do a quick
comparison between building a
visualization in Excel and building one
in Tableau okay so here we have an Excel
file full of data that we will soon
connect to and use for some of our
demonstration purposes and you can see
that we have information about orders if
we wanted to find out the quantity sold
and the sum of sales for each region we
could do that by creating a pivot table
so we'll make it I selected my cells
we'll make it in the new worksheet and
here we have the beginnings of a pivot
chart and we can grab region and pull it
into our columns and then we'll grab
sales and put it into values
um and then we also want to look at
quantity and put that into values and
it's automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be some or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see sales and quantity one on top of
the other and that's the basics of a
pivot chart now let's do a similar thing
in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and Tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns and we get a similar
thing maybe a little nicer formatted and
then we can come and put quantity there
and we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity down in that box we
also have this show me dialog box which
allows you to see what visualizations
you could build using what's already on
the screen or the things that you have
selected so right now we could quickly
switch it to bar charts and now we can
see quantity and sales across our region
with bar charts or we could switch it to
Stacked bars and we can see our quantity
across the regions if you close that we
can see our Legend over here and then
our sales across the region
so in Tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization so in summary we can see
a side by side of what we made using
pivot tables in Excel and what we made
in a similar amount of time in Tableau
let's get started with the Tableau
installation as for requirements you
need Windows 7 or later or you need your
Mac operating system to be 10.11 or
later here are some of the browsers you
can use to install Tableau we will be
installing Tableau public today and to
do that you just Google Tableau public
download and click on that first link
and then you put in your email address
and click download the app so let's just
look up Tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now it takes you to the Tableau
public page where you can click sign in
and create an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on Tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open Tableau public so let's go
take a look at the Tableau public
opening page
so this is what Tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to this is more limited in
Tableau public than it is in Tableau
desktop so if you invest in Tableau
desktop you have many many things you
can connect to you can also connect to
data by clicking this drop down connect
data piece that's especially useful when
you've already started your
visualization then we have the central
portion called open this is where
anything that you have opened up
previously will show up you can also
click open from Tableau public and when
you have my connections timed out so I
need to log in but when you log in it
says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published Tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos
visualization of the day which is where
people who have made Tableau public
visualizations get recognized for their
skill and you get some pretty pretty
cool ideas when you look there so let's
get started by connecting to a data
source we'll click Microsoft Excel and
we'll choose our Excel file and open it
up and this is our data source page this
shows you the sheets on the Excel file
and allows you to drag them in so that
you can see the data show up this gives
you a preview of what your data will
look like
you can see the Tableau is starting to
classify our Fields so anything that has
ABC on it shows that that's a column
that has strings in it we also have a
globe which was where Tableau has
recognized these values to be
geographical
so we have
um State and it's recognized that it
contains States it bases it on the
keywords that it stores to identify if
it's geographical and so it takes a look
and you've named it City and it knows
that city is geographical we also have
the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row ID that shows up with the
hashtag and I recognize that it's a
number so now that we have our data
source pulled in we can come here and
hit sheet which is where you start to
build your visualization let's take a
look at all the different pieces of this
before we go any further we have the
data that we're connected to up here is
our orders sheet from the sample
Superstore Excel sheet we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the row
shelf where you can drag things in to
make changes happen in the visualization
Center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here a neat thing about show me is that
when you hover it'll tell you what types
of fields you need to build it so for a
symbol map try one geographical field
zero or more Dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map and when you're
done with show me you just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet 1 and Sheet two a sheet is
basically just one visualization at a
time let's get rid of the extra sheet we
have a dashboard which is where you can
pull multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have What's called the story
which allows you to show a sequence of
visualizations so that you can tell a
story
perfect okay so we saw that Tableau is
categorizing our different fields and it
is also giving it a role so we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
Dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use Dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view Tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's some by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see it's four distinct values as a
dimension and then we'll double click on
quantity and we can see the numbers here
the measures and you can see here that
it is the sum of quantity and now we can
also double click on sales and we can
see quantity and sales to discuss a
little bit more about dimensions and
measures you can see that in general
measures are numbers and dimensions are
not but sometimes like row ID it is a
number now why would we have a number up
here instead of in the measures so you
can tell the difference between number
whether it should be in measures or it
should be in Dimensions based on whether
you'll need to do any calculations on it
or if you would want to be able to
aggregate it at some time so for sales
if you have
several orders in a day you might want
to know what the sum of those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they are on rows two three four and
five you might not want to know the sum
of the rows so Tableau is smart enough
that when it sees ID it knows that it
belongs up in the dimensions now you can
switch so if row ID was actually
something you would want to aggregate
for some reason you can drag it down to
the measures and add it down there
but in our case row ID isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's Dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green a little bit
different than what you might expect and
then we'll do sales so now we can see
over the different quantities what our
sales was it has been for this last this
period of time that we're looking at I
believe it's four years so for when
people bought three items the total
sales was that number and you can see
that this is an axis so it's from 1 to
15. now if we change it from continuous
to discrete you can see that one is a
label two is a label and it's not an
axis ranging from one to it doesn't even
have 15 because there are no values
under 15. these are just individual
labels so we go back it's green again
and you can see that it's an axis so we
have two greens on here so we have two
axes and change it back to discrete and
now we have one axes and one set of
individual labels so let's go back to
our sheet three we have all of these
different sales by the different
quantity numbers and up here we have our
sorting when you hover it tells you what
kind of sorting is going to happen so we
can sort quantity descending by sales so
we can see that when they buy three
things we have the highest sales
you could do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right-clicking sort so we
could just sort
by descending or ascending or by sales
or
alphabetic which is not what we want you
can choose the field or you can manually
change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how Tableau Works let's go into a
little more detail Tableau is very much
built on the premise of drag and drop
so let's build a simple visualization
and talk about what each of these
shelves and marks cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region so we
know we want sales
on
let's do sales on Rose now for rows and
for metrics since this is continuous
like we talked about before it's making
an axis
for our sales
um we also can drag region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
Dimensions if you
um pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying I want one blank per column I
want one region per column so if you
wanted to do it by instead of region if
you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control Z Tableau
has the benefit of having unlimited
undos so let's say we wanted to bring on
City let's say we want one column per
City and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
City back off I want one column per
region and for sales
I want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great now
let's say we want to adjust the color of
These Bars you can click on color and
you can select any of them so let's pick
this nice blue or we can pick an orange
and that's how you can determine the
color but if you want something else to
determine the color you can take region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale so if I want them to be
a different color based on sales and I
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous from light to dark but
for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great
um let's say we want to sort this
biggest smallest and we can look at size
here so if we want to adjust the size
manually we can click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else you choose a measure for
the size so if we want it to be
wider
based on sales we will drag sales onto
size and we can see that it gets bigger
with bigger sales you do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures for label let's say we
want the sales onto label now we can see
the exact sales number for each region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales from
the west region you can adjust which one
goes on top see how we have two T's here
those are both labels great uh two of
tip let me click on tool tip it'll show
us what's going to happen when we hover
so as I hover here on East it says
region East sales and that shows the
sales amount
um now we talked about
I'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average of sales so
we will right click on our sum of sales
here in the rows hover over measure um
which right now is sum and change it to
average and we have a different result
here so let's sort again and we can see
that the South Region actually has the
highest average of sales which was not
the case for the sum now let's say we
want our sum I mean our sales to be on
the label but look it's giving us the
sum of sales label so we just do the
same thing
and change it to average now we can see
our average on the label
the label has some interesting options
like you can format this and we could
say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue and that happens
right there you can also choose to only
show the minimum and the maximum this
becomes handy on a line chart where you
don't want all marks labeled because it
gets very messy but you want the tallest
and the shortest part to be labeled and
maybe you just want the tallest so we'll
click label minimum value and remove
that checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so we could allow
people to look at this but only certain
regions so what we can do is we can come
over to region and right click on it and
click show filter and it will add it to
that filters card and now we can remove
Central from the mix and just look at
those ones you see if we remove South
the new highest East now has the label
but if we put it back in South we'll
have the label again if we don't want to
have these filters we can pull it off
there or if we wanted to filter out
by country oh we just have United States
so let's not filter by country
um but we could pull in category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the South still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that I can mention
here is that you can change the type of
Mark manually so you saw when we pulled
on region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there you
can change it to be a lot of different
type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay now let's look at building a
scatter plot so scatter plot is when you
have a bunch of shapes and points on a
visualization with two axes that are
both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount and if we wanted to see this
per order we'll take order ID and put it
onto detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order ID and putting onto
detail gives us all of these little
points so for each order what was our
sales and what was our discount so we
have
now here are some outliers that you can
find very quickly let's actually do
product ID instead so I'll put it right
over top of order ID and it will replace
it
now we see all of our products anything
that has high sales is up here anything
that has high discount is over here you
can see that it sort of has a trend
where things with high sales do not have
high discounts which makes sense if we
wanted to know what category these
products I'll show up in we could take
category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories Tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show just the dimension
that you want to see but it leaves the
other ones in place so for example if we
click on furniture
first we have to turn on the Highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization I
know how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology we can see their
pattern which is a little bit different
so we have them by shape with category
let's drag category onto color as well
if you remember category will determine
the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items they're all over here and most of
the things that are getting
High discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product ID
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product ID with
product name
and we see that that is a Canon Image
class Advanced copier so this copier is
our big sales person and office supplies
binders do not give us very many sales
and we're highly discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so let's say we wanted to know by
subcategory what our profit is like we
could grab subcategory and pull it onto
columns and we would say we want one
column per subcategory
and then let's grab profit and pull it
onto rows and you can quickly see which
categories are profitable and which ones
are not so we can also take profit and
put it onto color
so that you can see that even more
clearly right now it is going from
Orange to Blue which is Tableau default
if we wanted to change from what color
to what color it was going we have a lot
of options in here when you go to edit
colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here our subcategories here
but let's separate it out by category so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
subcategory off
I'm going to put on category and that's
my category and then I'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in Tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcut category so
Furniture is all here and then there's
our subcategories under Furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking it up by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category and we can click sort
subcategory descending by profit and now
what it does is within the highest group
within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so what we have here is a quick view by
category by subcategory how we're doing
on profit we can see that tables is our
biggest drain on profit and so if we
wanted to improve the profitability of
furniture maybe we would not sell tables
anymore it's just not working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it is you
can see that there's some of these words
are getting cut off so we can right
click on this axis and click rotate
label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to profit by
sub category then it names the title up
here so it's making it look a little bit
better and then here we have profit and
it shows it but without any like dollar
signs so let's come up here to profit
and click format and you can see that we
can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and we can do a currency by the
thousands and we can get rid of these
decimal places and now you can see it's
just a little bit nicer a little bit
more clear maybe we don't have to have
the label here that says category slash
subcategory so we can hide field labels
for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in Tableau is one of
those things where there are just a lot
of different ways you could change
things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from Simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are building these
visualizations if you want to have
access to this data set so that you can
build along with me just make a comment
in the comments below and it's a simply
learned team will send you this data set
now we're going to take a look at
creating a hierarchy in tableau
so I'll make a new tab and we're going
to make a sheet called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at sales as a
number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this and I click add all
members and now we can see all of our
products and their sales overall time so
if we sort this we can see our highest
selling item which we discovered earlier
as the advanced copier and we scroll
down to the bottom our lowest selling
items
so we have our products and we can group
that by sub category and you can see I
need to put it in the front again
and by category
all right I'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so a product rolls up into a
subcategory which rolls up into a
category you can create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory let's do the same
thing by grabbing the product name and
putting it underneath subcategory so now
it knows categories the parent then
their subcategory and then there's
product name this allows you to instead
of pulling this off or putting it back
on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales by category by
subcategory by product name this is
really useful when you're creating a
details section for your users and so
when somebody wants to know let's say
you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
chill filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like I see technology has the
highest sales and I just want to see
technology so I'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so I
just have technology well I want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it oh phones
phones does so I just actually want to
look at phones so I'm going to remove
accessories copiers and machines and
what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now I can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first I'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of Tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly so what we can do is take sales
and drag it onto color let's change our
marks to a square and now it's going to
color each of these it colors every one
of these cells based on its Darkness for
sales this is a little bit heavy of a
color you can click color here and
change the opacity to give it a little
bit of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the West seems to have the highest
sails and that technology in the East is
the very highest so now when we drill
into subcategory it keeps that coloring
and we can see more in depth and quicker
that phones has the highest across most
of them it's not quite the highest in
the west because chairs is the highest
in the west there's one place in Tableau
where hierarchies are built in and
that's in dates so dates in Tableau can
be very complex because they allow very
complex visualizations so we will not go
into depth about dates at this time but
let's take a look at how they work for
hierarchies so we have order date that
we can pull onto columns here and you
can see that it's blue meaning that it's
discrete so each one of these is a
header instead of it being an axis
across the top now let's drag profit
onto rows so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and Tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when I click this
Plus on columns it'll split it out into
quarters so this is a header and these
are all subheaders underneath that
header because it is distinct
um and discrete right now instead of
continuous so it's split out year year
year and quarters quarters quarters
quarters this allows you to quickly
compare quarter one across all of the
years and Quarter Two across all the
years and quarter four across all the
years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out to color and
now we have one line for each category
and we can see that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarterback off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when I change
it to a bottom one year same thing same
year it changes it to be green and now
it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when I
press the plus and it changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going and drill down to
month
you can go pretty far now when we add
category as color we get our three lines
for the three categories and we also
have highlighting turned on here still
so when we click on technology we can
highlight technology with the others in
the background so we don't lose the
context of the other categories
let's take that back off next let us
talk about calculated Fields so we'll
make a new sheet and we're going to
create our first calculated field we can
create a calculated field by clicking
this Arrow which gives us some options
and clicking create calculated field or
we can come and click in the white space
below Dimensions or below measures and
we right click and click create
calculated field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start Auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or values you can use or
you can come and drag it in so if we
want profit and we want sales if we do
profit divided by sales that is a profit
ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate and that will duplicate our
field but I just want to start over
again so I'll click create calculated
field and I will call it profit
ratio aggregated
and in this one we're going to do some
click of profit
click divided by sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio aggregated and
profit ratio unaggregated how will those
behave differently in Tableau let's look
at this by looking at a single order so
first let's bring on all the orders and
all the products under that order and
let's look at this order so I want to
filter this whole dashboard to only this
order so I can right click on it and
click keep only that creates a filter up
here
that only has that box checked
and if I want to get rid of this later I
can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but I want
it so keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated I double clicked on it
and I added it here and profit ratio
unaggregated again double clicking
another side by side let's give us a
little bit of more room
so when I dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side in the entire titles okay so I
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that Tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and I brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now so when we're looking at it without
any aggregation these two calculations
are the same profit ratio aggregated
let's look at that again we'll click
edit and that's the one where we sum
profit and some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that I use when I'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what I expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at 0.5 or 50 and
that's because profit is eight in sales
is 16. for Adam's telephone messaging
now let's take off project name when we
take off product name we can see that
they start to vary they've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller so if we
take profit at
219.1 and divided by sales at
508.6 we get 0.4 not 1.8 so where does
this 1.8 come from well let's put a
product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however does the
calculation profit divided by sales and
then sums it afterwards you can see it
right here it's the sum of profit ratio
on aggregated so it makes this
calculation and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5 and that's where we get our 1.8
which is what we see when we pull off
product name 1.8 so for most
calculations you want to do profit ratio
aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board Tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on Windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
Region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region now
let's say we also wanted to see each
region by sales per customer so let's
create some calculated fields that will
help us do that let's create our first
calculated field that's going to get us
a count of customers
let's call it total number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer ID let's do count distinct of
customer ID and that gives us the total
number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it sales per customer
we're going to do our sum of sales which
we can drag in and divide that by total
number of customers now you see that
calculated field we just made pops up
inside of our calculation dialog box and
we hit apply and it shows up so we hit
OK and let's replace total number of
customers with sales per customer and
now we can see our sales per customer
ratio and which ones have the highest or
for this next part I'm going to make a
couple of visualizations in a row that
I'll apply to the same information using
a couple of different tactics so first
let's use show me so I want to look at
Region and sales for this visualization
so I'm going to control click region
after I clicked sales so one more time
I'm going to click on sales and I'm
going to control click region and I'm
going to click show me and it's going to
give me all of the different
visualizations I could make with region
and sales let's pick
remap
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales by region and we have
the size and the color of the box is
both sales so let's say we wanted the
size to be sales but the color to be
profit so let's grab profit and drag
that on to sales so now we can see our
most profitable to our least profitable
let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to Advanced and
make the center number
zero this means that it will never be
red unless it's less than zero so let's
hit apply so it's all blue and if
anything ever goes negative then it will
be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales
profit by region
perfect now we're going to start using
our geographical Fields so we have state
city country and postal code let's
double click on State and see what
happens awesome so it is generated these
two Fields Tableau has generated
longitude and latitude for us and it's
been able to recognize the states in the
United States and where they're located
and given it a longitude and latitude so
next we will look at sales by state by
double clicking on sales and what it's
done was change the size of the dot
based on sales now I think I'm going to
move sales from size to color and it has
automatically changed it to a filled map
instead of dots on a map perfect so now
we can see the states
with the biggest amount of sales let's
put it back on to size and we have our
circles again
let's put sales on the size not State
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the Tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the Builder okay
so we have size for sales again and for
profit onto color again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker anything that is less profitable
or less than zero in this case is Orange
Let's do what we did with color before
change it to red blue diverging and set
our Center Point to zero okay so now we
know that if anything is red it was
negative in profit perfect let's name
this sheet
sales profit by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so this is when we
drag something to the columns shelf just
remember we want one column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what I want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have a one bar
with the axis of sales for furniture
office supplies and Technology now let's
take profit and also put it on rows so
now we have two bar charts one for sales
and one for profit we can change which
one is a bar and which one is maybe a
bubble chart by clicking on its
appropriate marks card so if we want to
change them both we can click on all and
change them both to maybe circles and
you can see how they go up and down but
if we want to just change one of them
let's put those back to automatic we'll
go to profit and change that one to the
circles so now we can see those profit
numbers and if we want them to be
overlaid on the same area we would right
click on profit the second measure on
the rows and click dual axis so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space one of them is a bar chart
and one of them is a bubble chart and we
can see our sales versus our profit at
least they're not the same amount of
dollars obviously but we can see a
higher sales and a higher profit we also
have medium sales and a medium profit we
have a medium sales but a really low
profit and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet as
sales
profit
by category
and finally we're going to make our
details sheet so we're going to go down
to subcategory level and bring it onto
rows and remember subcategory can expand
out to the actual products let's bring
that back in and we're going to bring
sales onto columns which makes this a
sales bar chart and profit onto columns
column which makes this a profit bar
chart now let's color them by their
appropriate individual color so we'll go
to the sales marks card and drag sales
onto color now sales is colored by sales
we'll do the same thing here we did
before we'll go red blue diverging
and make the center zero we actually
don't have to do that for sales because
sales will never be negative but it's
pretty important for profit so we'll go
to the profit marks card and take profit
onto color
and do the same thing there we have red
blue diverging
Advanced Center is zero great so now if
it's negative it will be there so let's
sort this by profit and so both of them
have sorted with profit in mind and we
can easily see our subcategories that
have a negative process
rename this and we'll call it our
details sheet so now we have these four
visualizations that all have to do with
similar information
I think I want these bigger on the
states so I'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have information over here that shows
you what sheets you can bring on these
get a little bit more complex so they'll
be covered in more in-depth type of
videos and then we have our size so we
could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size and we're going to make it 1400 by
a thousand and this is our dashboard
size so let's bring on sales profit by
region sales and profit by state now a
map needs a little bit more horizontal
space than region does let's bring sales
and profit by category underneath the
region and the tail underneath the stage
give our map more space again perfect
now Tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if I click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
I just want to look at the South and I
click on South it zooms in to all my
South States now my categories have
updated to be just the South ones and my
details have updated as well so we could
see that Central has pretty big sales
you know bigger than the South but the
profit is lower than the South so we can
click on Central and focus on Central
let's use that uses filter on all three
of these dashboards that lead us up to
the detail so building a quick dashboard
like this let's make this taller would
allow you to do some sort of analysis
such as let's take a look at Central
because they have relatively High
profits but low sales so we click on
Central and then we see oh man Texas is
having a really hard time so let's click
on Texas and now we're seeing in Texas
that we have negative profit in these
categories so we can control click on
furniture and office supplies and we can
see all of our products that are really
just killing us in Texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for Texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you back out of that
subcategory section you can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
Click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet and
let's make a quick visualization that
will apply our parameters and our sets
to
so let's take a look at all of our
customers by their sales and let's sort
customer name descending by sales great
so now we're going to make a parameter
that will allow the user of the
dashboard to choose how many customers
they want to see how many of our top
customers that they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make an integer and
we're going to give them the option to
choose the number of customers within a
range our low is going to be 5 so we'll
let them see five
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of five let's start the
current value right in the middle with
10. okay so now if you want to see how
this parameter looks you can come down
to parameters before we only had
dimensions and measures on the left side
of our Tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that it's appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
that parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allowed them to go down to five
and up to 20 with steps of five great
now we're going to create a set a set is
a custom field that defines a subset of
data based on some conditions so the set
we're going to build is going to be
based on customer name so when you right
click on customer name you can come down
and click create hover on Create and
create a set with so far when we created
a parameter and a calculated field you
clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on Create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
Define by the parameter
Buy sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10. we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here for it to be defined
by and it's sales and we want it to be
by sum of sales if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers by average profit but we want
sales and some
Okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it onto rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15.
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10 and let's grab the
set and drag it onto our filters so now
we have filtered the data down to our
top ten if this were applied to a
dashboard this would allow the end user
to see the top 10 quickly and then maybe
expand it out to the top 20 if they're
interested in that information now let's
move on to creating a donut chart so a
donut chart is basically a pie chart
with a white center so let's start by
building a pie chart which in Tableau is
pretty easy especially if you use show
me so let's create a pie chart for each
category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're gonna control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click pi and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one Pi for each region we can take
region and drag that onto columns so we
have one column for each region and then
one Pi for each of them you can see that
the pi varies in size based on sales as
well as the angle is for sales so East
has more sales in general than South and
this helps you to see that technology
has smaller sales in the South than it
does in the East so I recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of size and
now we have all of our pie charts the
same size now we're going to make what's
called a dual axis chart and to make a
dual axis chart we have to have two axes
so let's grab number of records and
we'll grab it and drag it to rows and we
will change it from sum to minimum and
that's because every record will have a
minimum number of rows of one and then
they all end up on the same axis great
and now we're going to make a second
number of Records by minimum and we can
do that by doing those steps Again by by
dragging number of Records up here and
changing it to minimum again or a quick
trick that I can show you is if you want
to duplicate anything you have on the
chart here you can just hit control and
then click and drag it and it will
duplicate it so if you wanted your
number of Records to also be down here
onto your details or on your labels you
can control click it and then leave it
there great so now we have our two axes
and we have our two marked cards that
each affect their own set of
visualizations so let's go to this top
one affects these so let's show that by
changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these then we'll do
that by changing it to Circle so now
each of these are a circle let's take
category off of color and we can take
some of sales off of detail and let's
change the color to white and now we're
going to put this white circle on top of
our pie chart by clicking here on our
second measure and clicking dual axis
and now it's got them lined up one on
top of the other and we have our donut
chart so we want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our Inner Circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one donut chart for each
region and if we wanted to take this
header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here you can come
and edit that by clicking on label and
changing its alignment so let's put it
in the middle
perfect so now we can see our header
here so we don't need it down here
anymore you can right click and click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies so to get how the number of
sales here for each of them let's go to
remember our PI marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie can tell
you how much sales they have if you take
the sales here that's on label right
click and click format we can change
that to currency and let's get rid of
our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with Central so we
go back to affecting our Circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four donut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers for each segment and also
for the donut as a whole you can also
change the colors the Tableau selects
for each slice by coming to the marks
card that has color for the pie so
category color and clicking edit colors
and you could change it to any of these
automatic ones or if you double click on
one it gives you all of the options for
colors that you could possibly want
there's also several different palettes
you could choose from so let's say we
like this one and you can just click
assign palette and it will grab those
off of there those look very similar to
what we have already so I'm going to
pick a different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes you can fit your business a
little bit more specifically perfect
let's say we make our pies bigger
crease that size and we'll also increase
the center size oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show two pie charts at
the same time or a pie chart that's kind
of split up by different categories this
has been available in some other tools
and Tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our generic category
by sales so with control click sales we
come over to show me and click pi and it
makes our pie for us it remembers the
colors that you have determined in other
pages so that's a nice feature again
let's make it entire view so we can see
our pie nice and big and now we're going
to create our dual axis again so we grab
number of Records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of Records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes let's come to our
top one and make it bigger that affected
both of them because we still have sales
on size
for both of them so sales is affecting
the size of the pie chart as well as the
size of the angles so let's take sales
off of size for both of them and make
the second pie chart a little smaller
perfect now let's also affect our second
pie chart by having the color defined by
region instead of defined by sales let's
talk about how I'm replacing it with
region so you could change the color by
dragging region onto color and that
replaces it or let's go back and we can
drag region right on top of the thing
we're trying to replace and it will
replace it there
great so now we have the smaller Circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the categories on the top one with
being able defined by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to I'm just going to keep following
this right down apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner Pi
separate from the outer pie Maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look and we can make them both
bigger like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our line
change that zero line To None perfect
get rid of some of the Clutter on this
visualization I still feel like this
outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have Min number of Records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come to Tool tip right
as you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase mid number of
Records I erased too much you need to
leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
Min number of Records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when Tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen these visualizations are a little
bit more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so I recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below in
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have at this point in the
presentation we're going to put together
some dashboards so first let's build our
worksheets for this dashboard we're
going to build a worksheet called sales
by year which adds the name up here and
we're going to take our order date and
drag it onto columns and now we want
this to be a continuous axis so we're
going to change it to our continuous
year and now we have an axis and we're
going to look at sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto labels and if we want to
have different color lines for each
region for example we can drag region
onto color
and that splits our lines up into the
different regions and gives us a legend
over here perfect now we're going to
duplicate this sheet by right clicking
down here and clicking duplicate now we
have sales by year two let's rename it
to
profit by year and then let's drag
profit right over top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
sum of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our access
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like right click here go format and
we'll change our numbers to currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars one thing
you can do in Tableau is let's undo that
since sales is going to be dollars
pretty much everywhere we use it we can
Define our default property for these
numbers so when we right click on the
measure here you can go to default
properties and you have the options to
change the defaults for any of these
things and we're going to change our
number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit okay and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still Define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet let's do the
same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine I think it fits nicely on the
laptops that I use and that is used by
most of our customers and let's drag
sales by year now watch what happens
when I drag it on here it brings sales
by year but it also brings the legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same Legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second Legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts let me click on Central and
you see it highlights Central in both
charts that's great so now we have a
dashboard showing us profit by year and
sales by year but let's say we want to
be able to filter this dashboard to just
maybe one category so let's go back to
our sales by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit OK and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here and we're going to do a
similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here so now
we have a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
I don't feel when we go to overall we
can come to our drop down here more
options
hover over filters and you can see
category now here's an interesting thing
that we'll see even though we have a
category filter on both charts when I
take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be that's because we have
two different filters for category one
on the sales worksheet and one on the
profit by year worksheet I'll show that
by clicking here going to filters and
web category now we have category that
will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so let's back
it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year and we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to the profit
by year sheet you can see that it now
has category on there let's go to
overall let's come here filters category
and now we have a filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do a couple more filters so we can
do by category let them filter out
regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is apply to
worksheets selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them change their time
selection so this one's a little bit
different since we've already determined
that we wanted year and we wanted it to
be continuous filters for continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for these discrete fields and
that's because continuous fields are a
range instead of just a list so we don't
list out a continuous field we make a
range for it so we've already defined
that we want it to be continuous year
and if I come over here and click on
right click order date and click show
filter it's doing discrete year by
default
so remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at let's come up here to year
that's already marked as continuous and
click show filter and now it is year but
it's based on a range and we have this
slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization let me show you a
trick to make this apply to both not a
trick but just if you have not applied
it to both worksheets but you already
added it to the visualization see it's
here but it's only affecting one
worksheet you can change the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to the worksheet where the
filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by each of the
regions we can do that as well so let's
go back to our sales sheet as a quick
tip you can go to the sheet by clicking
this go to sheet button here or here in
the event that you want to go to a sheet
but you don't want to scroll back and
forth to find where it is so go to sheet
now we're going to do a dual access
chart again like we showed earlier and
I'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by if I change the
opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the row section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top I can see this
versus this this now if we wanted to un
hover show that this is overall sales we
can click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put oh we don't want it to be Orange
Let's Make It Black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it
um a little bit more of a color that'll
stand out just a little darker than the
others perhaps
so when we go back to our work or our
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for our profit by year go to sheet
and
control
drag release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not Orange
overall profit
okay and right click
dual axis there we go now I forgot to do
one thing on the last dashboard when you
make a dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
um sync up these axes and so this axis
over here is for the overall line and
this axis over here is for the region
line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should edit our axes and instead of
calling it just profit over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one or you can come here
and click synchronize access so it's
very clear that this is much bigger than
these and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him okay
synchronize the axis then we don't need
both of these headers so we can come
here and click show header and we just
have the one let's do the same thing on
sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind when we
do filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
have we filter to two
then it's only the sum of those two so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered
um why does this happen why doesn't this
line always show the total no matter
what you select here well that's because
this filter applies to the whole
dashboard so it filters this line to
those regions just as much as it filters
these lines
foreign
so I'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so let's do it using show me we'll
click on region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click Pi let's close it
again great so now we have the sales bar
region Pi we'll make it the entire View
and when you hover you can see that it's
showing us sales in dollar amounts now
it would be more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of Pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole at
100 so let's come here to our slice size
we'll right click on it and we're going
to use what's called a quick table
calculation and change it to percent of
total so now when you hover you can see
that the West is 31 of the pi
great let's also label each of these
slices so I'm going to control click and
drag region onto label and add region to
the labels I'm going to undo that and
show you what would happen if I just
dragged region onto labels without
copying it without holding Ctrl it will
move it and get rid of our colors and we
don't want that so we're going to
control and drag another way to do this
let's go back is by taking region and
dragging it onto label just straight
from over here but in this case for the
sum of sales where we've applied the
quick table calculation we want that
quick table calculation to also show up
in our label so I'm going to control and
drag and it brings that quick table
calculation along with it if I were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and I'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead control hold and
drag that's probably one of my very
favorite upload Turks great now let's
add a filter for region so I'm going to
right click here and click show filter
and we will make sure that this gets
added to all of our sheets once we've
made them all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet sales by state let's do a map
great so one way to get your map started
is to double click on any of these
Dimensions that have a globe next to
them so with this we want to go with
State we can double click on State and
it starts mapping out state so what it
does is it adds latitude and longitude
to our rows and columns that are
generated here and another way to get
going so let's go back is to click on
the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our Maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
going to do a fill map
click on that so now we have our filled
map based on State
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or Bluetooth
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label and you can see we
have the dollar sign and the money
formatting that we made earlier and
let's control and drag State onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here on the ellipses and edit it there
so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there I think I lost my
Center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think great okay
so now you can see that it puts the
state on top you can also see in some of
these places where they're super close
together that you can't see all of the
states labels and that's because
um this option here in labels is
unchecked allow labels to overlap other
marks so Tableau senses when the marks
are too close together and it's going to
become too hard to read and we'll hide
anything that overlaps with each other
if we click this option now you see
everything but it gets a little crowded
over here so let's unselect that and
you'll be able to see what the sales are
upon hover
great now we have our sales by state for
filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your Dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them and create your filters
um so now we could add the lowest amount
for a state is 920 for sales for this
time period and we could filter out ones
that have sales lower than that but I
think this isn't what I want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
State shell filter great so now we could
filter out a state we could just show
Arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization new sheet rename it to be
called sales by sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategory we could
either drag on subcategory here or
because of our hierarchy press plus now
we have sub category and category and
let's bring on sales it's defaulting to
this bar chart which is perfect that's
what I want and now we could color it by
subcategory and this is a discrete
coloring we could also color it by sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to add to the distinction
between the different categories so
that's very clear where they start and
stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for a subcategory so let's
bring on category as our filter so we'll
right click here click show filter
there's category and let's do a filter
for our date so we're going to come here
to order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit OK right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard our sales
dashboard and change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us but this time you can see
it added both the Legends and the filter
so last time we created the filters
after we built the dashboard but this
time you can see that the filter
um gets brought in when we brought in
the dashboard let's do our sales by
State Side by Side here and let's do
sales by subcategory underneath so I
dragged it you can see how I pull it
towards the bottom of the dashboard and
it kind of fills in the space where it's
going to be and then brings it in so now
it's brought in all our filters and all
of our Legends it defaults to putting
the filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
gonna make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in Tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and um a lot of resizing to get things
the way you want them to be give our map
more room
and we have a mixture over here of
Legends and filters let's move our
Legends out of there so we can grab this
Legend and come and put it on this side
and this Legend come put it over here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this Legend goes up here with this one
I'm going to actually click here and
change it from a tiled so right here it
says tiled object to a floating object
that lets it sit on top of a
visualization I'm going to put it on top
of this visualization right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one Circle there's no
size comparison so it's not like we have
several circles and we have to look and
see which one's the biggest so that we
can tell that the amount of sales so we
don't need this Legend and we can just
remove it from the dashboard let's clean
up some of these we have several
different versions of what your filters
could look like so my personal favorite
is multiple values drop down it gives
you some of the most flexibility but if
you wanted them to only be able to
select a single value you could turn it
into a radio button list so that it's
the selected all or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the Range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
Technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so let's do multiple value drop
downs for big ones like State there is
the option of searching so I know I want
Utah and I search and there's Utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard hit okay
we'll do this again
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe
um a total number up here at the top
that you just wanted to stay the same
all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters oh great great
so we can change what region we're
looking at by selecting Central here and
then we're just looking at Central
throughout all the visualizations I love
looking at it on a map and seeing just
one at a time it just really makes the
region name just stand out to you but if
we wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on Central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that Texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
Central the scaled updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and Texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when I filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at Texas we click this this updates to
just Central this updates to just Texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say let me scroll down a
bit storage now everything updates to
the storage it's interesting I wouldn't
have known very quickly that there are
some states that didn't have any storage
sales but now when we click on storage
we can tell I showed you before that you
can control click and look at binders
and storage and it puts those two
together also in Tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have our binders envelopes Fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
I don't know what's up with Wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and let's get started on our
next one our next dashboard is going to
be the profit version of this dashboard
so some of these visualizations we can
use again so let's go to sales by region
right click and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
I mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere that sales is used you have
to replace it with profit I'm also going
to drag this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall than the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
Circle and onto the text now when I
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total Again by region region
okay here's another thing since so you
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in a region filter
and this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what I want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier Tableau will
not allow you to make a worksheet that
has the same name as another worksheet
you can call it number one or since it
does put the title up here you can put
an extra space at the end or it does
detect that space it counts it as a
different title even though it's the
same title just with the space that does
cause some issues so like when we're
looking here and we're saying oh profit
by subcategory I want that oh this is
when we made it but you don't want this
one you want this one and it gets a
little confusing the nice thing is when
you're dragging things onto your
dashboard when you hover you should get
a little picture here of what dashboard
what visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all of these called sheet5 sheet
seven you won't know exactly what that
is right away and so that little preview
is very helpful great profit by
subcategory we'll do the same thing by
removing out all our filters so I just
click on it and hit delete you can also
control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on category as a filter
okay
shell filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you're making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you could make that happen
you could just collect furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this Interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so I'll rename this and call it profit
over time
by category
so we're going to bring on our order
date into columns and it goes to our
discrete value let's change it to our
continuous value so we get that axis
let's grab our profit onto rows and then
mix this align chart we're going to
change that to an area chart an area
chart is nice because when you split it
up by category by dragging category on
color you can now see what category is
responsible for how much profit like you
do with a line chart however its area is
what defines that so you can see that
area over time and do comparisons and
also it Stacks them on top of each other
so that you can tell that for 2013 our
profit was around fifty thousand dollars
really quickly otherwise we have to add
that line this line here and it makes
these lines smaller and lower more
difficult to see so back to our profit
over time by category so that's some of
the benefits of having an area chart and
if we wanted to go a little more
detailed then here you can hit this plus
and now we have over quarter we have
some negative profits that's interesting
but let's go back to over the Year great
and for this one we're gonna make one
more pie chart so we could start from
scratch or we could duplicate our profit
by region pie chart which I'm going to
do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on tool
tips will affect your level of detail in
the visualization here when it's on tool
tips sometimes it won't change the level
of detail but it could have an effect on
like so if we brought oh let's do this
right now so right now the level of
detail of this chart does not go to the
category by region like it did before
you can bring it onto detail here and it
won't affect color and it won't affect
labels but it will change the detail and
you see how it splits it out again this
is what it would look like if it's by
region by category and you have much
more slices to this pie we'll go back
but if we take region and put it onto
tooltip it's not at a low enough level
for that tool tip to make any sense so
it's going to put that star you see
region is star that's because this
section of the pie covers multiple
regions if we filtered the region to
just Central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when at all
levels it doesn't make any sense but we
won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines is a
big part of what determines how many
slices you get the level of detail for
the whole chart is a big factor as well
on how many slices you get great profit
by region profit by category by
subcategory and by a profit over time
and we have our category filter we don't
have our subcategory filter yet we
grabbed category but let's right click
on subcategory and click show filter
there we go now we have a filter for
category and subcategory
here's our region one we have region in
two places and we don't want that
we wanted to apply it to all of them
we'll do that when we get to the
dashboard
and and we have category year of order
date and subcategory great those are all
the filters I wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once I get it set
to the size I want
profit we'll start with profit by region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that some different space have this at
the bottom have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up next to it
so it's again drag it over to the side
it's always good to pay attention to the
highlighted section and it gives you
kind of an idea oh you see I
accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when I grabbed this I didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all of
these and they happen to be inside the
same section you can come and click
select the layout container and now I'm
grabbing all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what I'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area I'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category Legend applies to both
this chart and this chart so that's very
nice and this subcategory Legend I won't
make floating I'll just put here by
subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
give our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now um because I didn't have
to on this chart and this chart change
profit to dollars because we set that as
the default it definitely saved us some
time so
I recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so I like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so I take it the
second to the top and I drag the top one
down and then
um category above subcategory just for
logical sense excellent and we have our
profit dashboard let's see there is this
check box down here called show
dashboard title so if we wanted to have
the title at the top here you can click
that button any floating objects don't
shift down like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title that's up to you
excellent so at this point we have our
overall dashboard that looks at sales
and profit we have our sales dashboard
and we have our profit dashboard our
profit dashboard isn't 100 Complete
because I forgot to make sure all of
these filters apply to all of these
worksheets so let's go ahead and do that
right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook and you
can see the rest here so if you want it
all on the dashboard and you wanted this
one or something like that then you have
the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one year this
area chart becomes a lot less useful but
if you're looking at two or more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard to
our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action so you can make an
action on a worksheet
you can see right here actions or on a
dashboard actions so since we're linking
between two dashboards this is going to
be a dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made but you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the Highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and Define an action it
was made by clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action or when we look on
our sales dashboard we clicked on this
uses filter button so we should have
several actions here that were all
generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use this filter a highlight
action that we can see from here in
region and go to URL action that we
haven't used if you have any questions
about go to URL please post them in the
comments below it basically allows you
to be able to select a URL here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in the
URL here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
URL that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information it can get pretty cool
okay but we want to link from this
dashboard to one of our other dashboards
and you actually do that using a filter
action so we're going to name that
action go to sales dashboard and we want
it to happen when we click on our sales
sheet so you see right here it shows us
the two sheets that are on this
dashboard when we click on the profits
dashboard we don't want this action to
occur this is our go to sales dashboard
now you can have an action occur on
Hover or select you've seen select
happen that's what our filter uses
filter actions use and on menu so we're
going to do it on menu and the targeted
sheets it defaults to this dashboard
saying when I click on this I want the
rest of this dashboard to update but
instead it's going to take us to our
sales dashboard
so when we click on this I want these
sheets to update now we're going to
Define what filters it's going to apply
by default it's going to apply all of
the filters based on what we click so if
we click here it will filter to just
2013 let's say we click here it'll
filter to just 2013 and it will filter
to the region we selected so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when I click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and West go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now so we can get here
for that information and to get back
click on this up here go to sales
dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now that
happens because it's trying to pass
region information to that dashboard but
this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select What fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and let me go back to that we click to
order date year and it goes to the
Target data source sometimes your target
data source will be a different data
source than the one that you are using
for your Source data source now that
gets a little bit complicated right now
we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this okay and we're going to add one
more
we're gonna add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay if
um One dashboard has region in it and
the other dashboard doesn't have region
in it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard what if
we take out region remove region and
we're just doing it based on year
Okay Okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is so now
it will filter into the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
West it takes you to the dashboard but
it doesn't filter it to West
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to sales let's make one for
profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing where
it's only going to filter it to the year
now you can see oh I started to type in
I didn't show you this before but you
can search text so we started typing in
year and it shows you that under order
date you have all these different
options in this dashboard right now if
you remember we're using the continuous
one that is marked by the little
calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just trading it like a
discrete field okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do is for West here we can select
both years and I'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could put a note in the tooltip for
this that this doesn't work for region
linking from this area doesn't work or
perhaps you could not have this total
line on the same visualization you could
have a separate visualization that shows
the total or an area chart instead and
that will let you not have this problem
of go to sales dashboard not linking
appropriate so now we're going to create
our final dashboard our segment
dashboard and it's going to use a
parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or OK and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same if we go forward again
segment analysis and profit and sales by
segment that allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make a profit and sales it's going to be
a bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet consumer corporate and
home office and then we're going to look
at it segment and we're going to make a
matrix with category and we get to fill
in this space with our visualizations so
we're gonna do sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount of sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
and it's nice and easy when the two
marks cards are based on a different
measure to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on a bar chart
now if we had profit in front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales another way you can fix it say you
wanted the profit access here over here
for some reason you can right click on
the axis and put Mark type or oh move
marks to fret
another way to change it we don't need
both of these so let's not show that
header and we don't need this to be
labeled profit because it's for both of
them so the way you get rid of that is
actually you click edit access
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes and we have three sets of bar
charts across
excellent the next chart we're going to
build oh so right now they are it
automatically added the colors based on
measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by Tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them's named profit
one of them's name sales and we know
that you can come here click color and
hit edit colors and it will open this
dialog box but you can also come here
and double click on a color pops open
that dialog box let's pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20.
let's pick colors from this palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever and you make it more opaque you
start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
so stick with the Tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top customers Buy sales and this is
where we're going to use our parameter
where we made our top end customers so
let's bring in our set of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set
that's what we have our in and our out
we're going to break up our set by our
segment as it's part of our segment
analysis and we'll bring in our customer
names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for our users
of this dashboard they're like in and
out of top end customers by sales maybe
we want this to say something a little
bit more user friendly so let's make a
calculated field and we're going to call
it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if and we're
going to use our set top in customers by
sales and since it's an inner out set it
treats this like if it's in top end
customers by sales
then top
we're gonna do a streak so it's going to
be top and then we want to use the
number that's in our parameter so we
have to convert it from a number to a
string and we have to concatenate them
together in Tableau you could use a plus
side top and always make sure you have a
space between what you're concatenating
together that's something that I tend to
forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in the set then top blank
customers else if it's not in the set we
will just call it other and in Tableau
you always need to end your if statement
with an end here it tells us our
calculation is valid while we're here I
want to show you a little trick there's
this arrow button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau and it even sorts It Out by
different categories so if we didn't
know how to make this into a string we
could go to type conversion we could
click on string and it gives you an
example also when you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then I clicked on string and
I'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of Tableau also in Tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press Dash Dash or slash slash and
type in this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's drive profit onto color and you
can see this person has a negative
amount of profit despite their big sales
so that's important for us to know and
we can change our color like we did
previously to go from red to blue
and we can create our Center to zero and
now we can see the negatives really
quickly
no they're not the only one neither I
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to show in
or out we just are going to allow them
to show how many but we do want to be
able to have them filtered by category
so let's show that filter and by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen that is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really Dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its Legend and total customers by
sale and it pops up with its Legends and
filters and it pops up with its
parameter now I'm going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are workbook wide meaning
that it's going to exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if I I've changed it to 10
and if I come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why I should name my sheets
let's see if I can find it
nope
here we are sheet13 in sheet 13
we have our top ten so I've got a 10 and
I've got a 10 over there and if I change
it to 20 and I go back to my segment
dashboard it is also changed to 20. so
it will affect all sheets always very
important to know great so here's our
visualization here are some of the more
useful Legends so let's make this
floating and put it over by the
visualization it matters for we can do
the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these affect all the
dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole workbook
[Music]
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating Legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
Developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence and
Tableau we talked about how to install
Tableau public and how to connect to a
data source we also talked about
creating calculated Fields like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between Dash
today we will be learning about the
topics we discussed in part
live versus extract data sources we'll
talk about joins and unions and we'll
look at table calculations we'll look at
the rank functions and we'll look at
actions specifically URL actions we'll
talk about reference lines and bands
we'll look into some insights in the
data such as delay analysis also we'll
learn how to build a waterfall chart and
then finally we will learn about level
of detail calculations while making two
different visualizations
in part one of this Tableau training we
introduced Tableau Basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards if you missed part
one please check out the link in the
description below
now let's discuss the difference between
a live connection and an extract
connection first it's important to note
that these different types of
connections are not available in Tableau
public it's always a live connection and
a live connection is where the data will
update based on when the source of the
data updates so if any if you're
connected to a database and something in
the database changes then you'll pick up
those changes when you open the report
as it will query that database when the
report is opened whereas an extract
connection is extracted into creates a
subset of the data that improves
performance so when you're looking at it
locally on your computer you have an
extract of that data set that subset of
the data right on your computer or up in
Tableau server depending on where you're
looking at it and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when they're refresh updates it
so without a refresh set for that
extract you won't get the new data as an
example of this let's say that in our
sample superstore we have Kelly Williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
Sarah Smith
[Music]
we'll save it now let's go back to our
Tableau workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see Sarah Smith come in over
here in our extract it Sarah Smith
doesn't come in if we cook to refresh
the extract it doesn't refresh the
extract until we navigate to sheet1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see Sarah Smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day or once every
several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get Sarah
Smith's data coming in next let's talk
about joining data in Tableau so here we
have the people table but let's say we
want to join it to our orders
information so I'm going to start with
our orders table and then we're going to
pull on people and Tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then Tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side and the people
side what we'd like to join on and then
we have the options to do an inner join
a left join a right join and a full
outer join let's review quickly what
these look like so say we had two tables
that we wanted to join together one of
them was the student table that had the
student names and the key to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade ABCD F and incomplete we
can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at so if we were to do an
inner join
that would only take the rows where the
join could complete so we have one that
could join to one just fine but we don't
have two and we don't have three a
doesn't join to anything so this row
would be not included and then four five
and six would all join so that would
look something like this where we would
see Adam when we grab student from this
table and grade from this table we can
see Adam had an a Beverly had an a Dale
had a d Elizabeth had an f and Frank is
incomplete and Charles is missing also
you don't see any B or C in this list of
grades for a left join it's going to
take everything
from the left table and only the pieces
from the right table that apply to the
left table so it looks pretty similar to
our inner join only Charles shows up so
the join wasn't able to complete since a
doesn't exist in grade but we include
Charles anyways and grade becomes null
for Charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and then returns null we look up
a inside the grade key Perfect Right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table so it grabs all the
grades a b c d f and incomplete and only
the rows from the left table that join
appropriately so since Charles isn't
joined appropriately he doesn't show up
we also have B and C showing up even
though it doesn't exist in the student
table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer Joy
where it takes everything from both
tables whether or not the join is
complete complete so we have all of the
people where the join completes we also
have Charles where the join doesn't
complete from the left to the right and
we have B and C where the join doesn't
complete from the right to the left so
those are our options in tableau
here in our sample Superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is not in the people
table that's when you would do a left
join
for our purposes we'll do an inner join
now let's say we had a second Excel
sheet here that had more orders and you
can do a union which is just adding more
orders by dragging that second order's
table right underneath the original
orders table you can see it says their
drag table to Union and that's helpful
for if you have an Excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate Excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to Union and it would take
these orders and then add the rows
instead of the columns for the 2016
orders
for example we've added people but as a
join and that will first put in all of
our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order columns so it would
have the same data the same order ID
ship date but we wanted to add more rows
then that would be when you Union now
we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category we also have percentage of
total sales a long table down so the
difference between these two things are
one of them is made using
the calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales which basically makes the database
find the total sum of sales regardless
of these Dimensions we pulled on so it
gives us our total number so this will
be sum of sales for bookcases and this
will be some of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one percentage of
total sales along table down is what's
called a table calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done in
Tableau it's processed locally right
inside of the table after the
aggregations have occurred there are
some pros and cons of doing it this way
so for this percent of total sales
I had to create the table calculation
here and it does the fixed sum of sales
where it finds the sum of sales for the
entire database and since it is fixed it
will ignore filters so for example I
took off both of the sales and I'm just
going to put on the percent sum of sales
and let's say we wanted to see how
office supplies and Technology are as
percentages of sum of sales and ignore
Furniture so we can grab category and
we'll control click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit OK
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
whereas if we take sales
and double click it and it adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation and
click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match and that's
because it does take into account the
filter of category so let's pull the
filter category off and we can see that
they're both out of a hundred percent
now and each of these take into account
um the same amount of data since we have
no filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table then you need
to use a table calculation however when
you push the information back to the
database to do the calculation it's
doing it as part of the query to the
data source and it can save you some
time and so which one of these is faster
sort of depends on what data is
available already when the original
query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
Tableau first let's add a second data
source so we can do that by coming up to
data and clicking new data source or you
can just click this Plus data source
right here and click Microsoft Excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store pull on sales and we will
rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them based on who had the
highest sales to the lowest sales we
could create a calculated field
s ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank function
and we're going to put in sales now we
receive this error here so when we hover
we see what that Arrow says oh you can
click and it says all Fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated so
we can make some
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when I click on rank it
will tell us that it Returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row and it says identical values
are assigned identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on Rank by sales and
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one D is next and
c and b are tied 20 and 20.
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place but
now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these we'll
click duplicate
and edit let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense Returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click OK double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five it goes one two three four so
it doesn't include that Gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe I wanted to be in the order I
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that'll move sales to the front and
put rank dents at the bottom so now we
can see sales we can see Rank by sales
we rank dense by sales
now let's duplicate
and look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that I
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists Tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply and okay
and then double click rank Modified by
sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on ring
modified and it says it Returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by Rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both received the same rank
here but they received the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
foreign
copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank uni
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click like unique and we
have one two three four and five so what
it's doing is let's quickly look here so
Rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you'll
Define so it defaults to descending and
it's saying the biggest is the best
so in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do four and it's doing
that based on the ASCII values of the
store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase B comes
before lowercase C uppercase B is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data and
we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in Tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before in our Tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask in the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at category so we'll drag
category onto columns and then we're
going to look at sales so we'll drag
sales onto rows and it will create three
bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
on two rows again
and let's take
subcategory and bring it on to color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to move from the sales
by category sheet to the sales by
subcategory sheet and also filter down
that sheet to only the category we want
to see so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list and what sheets
do we want to affect we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other data source simply click rank
example it will show the rank example
data source so we just want sales by
category to be the source sheet and the
target sheet we want it to be sales by
subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available to create this filter
and hit OK so now we have our go to
subcategory on select we'll hit OK again
and let's make this a little wider so we
can see and so when we click on
furniture it will take us to Only
Furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make Tableau drill to a lower
level
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions you can see that we have the
action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category two let's
say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category two
and hit OK and hit okay now when we go
to worksheet actions
now you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory great so we have
our sales by category two let's bring it
to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories in the colors there
now we can take a look here
and sort by subcategory based on some of
sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just a way
that I like to view it so let's do a
highlight action and we're going to do
it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory and look at it over top of
our sales by category stacked over top
of sales by sap category so we want both
of those let's make our dashboard
automatic for
testing purposes and we'll go to
dashboard we'll click create actions so
we're going to add an action it's going
to be a highlight action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by subcategory be the target
sheet for all Fields okay okay and on
select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
I want to see all these small ones or I
want to see this one and these small
ones or whatever then it will highlight
the ones that you drag and select now
this is also true of our sales by
subcategory and sales by category so
when we clicked on technology it
filtered to just technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click office supplies and Technology we
get office supplies and Technology now
if we go back to the dashboard we can
see that this dashboard is now filtered
also to office supplies and technology
and that's because we're using the same
sheet and when you navigate away from
that sheet it doesn't mean that your
filter goes away
so when I click undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so if
you're going to have two things affect
that sheet just remember that just
because you navigated away from what you
selected doesn't mean that what you
selected goes away that filter will stay
there and it shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a URL action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so I'm going to double click State
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a filled map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put State onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label so we can
see the sales amount let's quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're gonna lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with the
dollar sign and
so on great so now we have our sales map
and we're going to create
uh worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to URL
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it Wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet cheap Six which we should rename
and we're going to have a URL in here so
this will take us to Wikipedia and then
whatever you put at the end of the
Wikipedia link it will take you to that
page on Wikipedia so we're going to take
State and add it to the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up croquet click OK let's
rename our sheet to
URL
filter by state
and so when we click on Texas okay back
to URL filter by state let's go to our
worksheets
and go to our actions and on the go to
subcategory
it is also affecting this URL filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here in sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it will Auto Select new sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on Texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on Texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on Wiki and it
will open up our browser with the
Wikipedia page for Texas this can become
really handy in the event that you have
data that maybe has an order ID and you
can take that order ID and insert it
into a URL in your system so that it can
take you to your web interface page for
that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of California
which um it can have information about
the languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
Tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to URL action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this URL won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our Wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit OK
OK and now I'm going to click on
Oklahoma
it'll open up a page for Oklahoma
but let's unselect Oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit OK and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on Oklahoma
instead of taking us to Oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to Oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to Texas and this will change to Texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
line
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics Pane and it is something that
comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so let's mate our
visualization we'll do our category and
subcategory again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it on to text so that's
not what I want so let's do sales onto
rows and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to Analytics
and we code to drag our reference line
onto our visualization it says you can
add the reference line for the whole
table for a pane or for a cell
so if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to Define our cell so
each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
cell each one of them gets a reference
line you see how it added those on this
is our dialog box we will look at that
in just a moment so let's remove that if
we take reference line and put it onto
pane
that's going to be similar to having
category and a color so each of these
different colors is now a pain
reference line onto Pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it on to table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do find out the
average for each section so I'm going to
take category and put it back onto color
and we'll take reference line and put it
onto pane now we have our reference line
it's based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it is taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs so it's taking an average across
these added up sections you could also
have it be total where it's adding all
of these up and it makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case a constant which is where you
get to define the value and so if we
wanted it to be 200
there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average or the median so let's
stick with average and now you can see
it's labeling the line as average we
could also have it label the line as the
value so now we can see that the average
is this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon and then the value average this
amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
OK
and so in that case when we click on
tables you can see our
recalculated average line
so the average for tables for just
tables is the sum divided by the number
so the sum of tables is 206 966 divided
by one is still 206 966 so selecting
just tables isn't really helpful but if
we wanted to know the average of tables
and we'll control click appliances and
we'll control click binders oh there we
go all three of those are selected we
can see the average of those three which
is this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those five categories
and those are reference lines now let's
duplicate this sheet
and I'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
fans
click on this reference line right click
and click remove and it takes it off we
have the same thing for reference bands
we had with reference lines where you
can have it be for the whole table per
pane or per cell so let's do a reference
band for the whole table so it's doing
entire table and it's taking from the
minimum to the maximum now we could
change the minimum to be the average to
the maximum and now that will highlight
the whole table everything that's above
the average becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you could add lines so we have a
line for the average or the maximum you
can make it thinner you can make it
dotted you can change your fill so maybe
if you don't want it to be quite that
dark you can change it to be a little
bit of a lighter color of gray and you
can have show recalculated band for
highlighted or you can remove that and
that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making several
different kinds of visualizations such
as bullet charts if you have any
questions about that please comment
below and the simply learned team will
get back to you now let's do another
analysis on average days to ship
and for this one we're going to look at
it by state
and we're going to look at it by ship
mode
and so we'll take average days of ship
and put it on columns and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's change the
order of these really quick if we come
up here to ship mode and we click sort
we click manual we can have same day
above first class so that it kind of
goes in order of priority so same day
first class second class standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do if the
average days ship is less than or equal
to two
then we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't a
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're going to call it
an early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
late
and else if let's get the rest of them
and average days of ship is not less
than two
greater than two
and less than five
then on time
on time
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement if
statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it onto color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment as orange and shipment
late as red
we could double click on the color and
we can change shipment early to Green
and now we can see
the best ones the on-time ones and the
ones that stand out is late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the District of Columbia
has second class as a late shipment
you can see that all of these
share the same access size so they all
go from zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to Six
if we click edit axis you can choose if
you want that to be the case so it's
like right now all of them use uniform
access range for all rows or columns and
that's really nice because it's easy to
compare Colorado to Colorado to Colorado
if you change it to Independent axis for
each rows you can see now this one only
goes from zero to not even one whereas
this one goes from zero to six and you
can compare it with color but you can no
longer compare it with size across all
of these different categories so uniform
access range is the default in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall looks like at the end and talk
about how it works so after we build it
we'll talk about some of the benefits of
having a waterfall chart so what we're
going to do is build it over time for
this visualization we're just going to
look at the year of 2014 so I'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014.
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month so you can see that I
chose the one that has month and year
and then when I chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from profit to our running
total of profit
so you can see that it takes January and
then it adds February to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to we now we have our running total
where it will some January and February
for the February Mark and then some
January February March for the March
mark if I take profit
and put it here you can see January is
negative 3000 and February is positive
two thousand but here it's the sum of
those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a gaunt bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have we're going to
call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit with
the negative side in front
oh it looks like I've done this before
so now we have a new name because I
added a space at the end so hit apply
and let's um delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative Profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit and we're going to use that to
determine the size
of the Gant bar so what it does is it
takes where the line was and it adds the
size of it to be the size of profit but
because the line was at the top and we
didn't want to build the profit up we
had to change it to negative profit so
it would build it down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative 3000 when we started and it
grew up to be almost back to zero and
then we can see that from there on out
we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are November
and March November being a little bit
bigger and you can see where we started
at the beginning of that month and where
we ended and that's how a waterfall
chart works so it lets you go through
over time and see exactly where our
problems were and exactly which months
helped the most where we started and
where we ended for each month next we're
going to talk about level of detail
calculation and we'll talk about those
first by showing an example so I'm going
to bring all my customers on
by name and then I'm going to bring on
order ID
and it's going to add all members but
then I'm going to change order ID from a
dimension to a measure and we have a
count distinct so now we can see each
customer and how many orders they have
so let's sort it and we can see one
person has 17 orders and we have one two
three four five six seven
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show how many
customers had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization and bring on
metrics that are at a level that is
different from what's shown on the
visualization so
in order to do this we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us the number of orders
per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer so let's
call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are two other level of detail
calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in some of our simply learned classes
and if you have any questions please
comment below and we can answer them so
we're going to do it fixed and you can
choose
dimensions and they could compute the
aggregation using only the specified
Dimensions so it'll ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order ID
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors I
will hit okay
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension and then
pull it out onto our columns and now we
can see one two three four five six
seven eight up to 17. so that means we
had
some customers just order one and some
customers order 17 and we had them order
everything in between so if we never had
a customer that had nine orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer ID or
name
let's do ID because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure and it's
going to be account distinct and so now
we can see
how many customers ordered how many
items
so we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest to smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail LOD
ders per customer
perfect now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to do an analysis about
new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time we're going
to use these
so that it makes an axis instead of just
change to line instead of Dimensions or
something that is not continuous and
then we're going to take our customer ID
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
kind of distinct customer ID and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day I think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
we click on Central we can see Central
now this is including all customers but
say we only wanted to include a customer
when they're making their very first
order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
foreign
to their first order date the Min order
date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on the visualization
and it won't let you put those two
things together so we're going to
use our level of detail calculation
again and we're going to make this fixed
per customer ID
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of trying to return
something different based on the
visualization it will always return the
Min for each customer ID so if the order
date on the visualization is equal to
this order date
yeah the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else
existing
end
so when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that the new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date apply okay and now we can take our
new field
which is new or existing drag it onto
filters and we only want new we'll hit
apply
and we can see that we have new
customers but less over time
so
so now we're going to change this count
distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time how our new customers are
adding up so it's taking the prior value
and adding our new customers and then at
the end we get our total customers for
each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day and you
can see places where it like levels out
so we can see we have a lot of new
customers and it's increasing but then
here for the region of East there kind
of is a level spot where we're not
getting new orders and that seems to be
the same for each of them so for
February of 2014 why were we not getting
any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red it
looks like the west region leveled out
as well but picked up sooner and started
getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view new customers over time and it's
only possible because we were able to do
a level of detail calculation here on
new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified Dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
in summary today we learned about live
versus extract Tableau Data sources we
learned about joins and unions in the
data sources we also looked at table
versus database calculations we looked
at how the different ranks compare we
built some actions into our dashboards
filter actions and highlighting actions
we also looked at URL actions we built
dashboards that used reference lines and
ones that use reference bands we did
analyzing of average days to ship and
delay analysis we build a waterfall
chart and we also looked into some level
of detail calculations and that brings
us to the end of our video on business
analytics and intelligence full course
2022 by simply loan I hope it was useful
and informative
if you have any queries please feel free
to put them in the comment section of
the video we'll be happy to help you
thanks again stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign